cultural research and environment
chaired by the gentleman from new york
mr schuyer
and the subcommittee on energy and
environment of the interior committee
which i have the honor to share
our purpose today is to discuss nuclear
winter
this is a matter of such importance that
mr schuyer and i decided to hold a joint
hearing since we had scheduled
separate hearings and this seemed a more
efficient and
effective way to go
i hope that today's testimony will
result in a better understanding of
questions that nuclear winter
immediately calls to mind
what is it what are its effects how does
it change our thinking about nuclear war
what should nuclear winter cause us to
do that we had not done before we knew
about it
another question some of today's
witnesses will describe the nuclear
winter phenomena
others will tell us how they believe our
strategic posture should be modified in
the light of it
before we begin i want to say that it
troubles me
that we were nearly into the fifth
decade of the nuclear era
before our military planners explicitly
accepted the potential destructiveness
of the climatic effects of nuclear war
such effect that is now believed could
rival the damage resulting
from more familiar effects of blast fire
and fallout
it's worth reflecting
upon the consequences of an attack by
our strategic air command and on the
soviet union
had it occurred in the late 50s or early
60s
at that time by all appearances
we possessed an overwhelming superiority
our military leaders had reason to
assure the president that the united
states could attack the soviet union and
expect little or no retaliation
if on the basis of such advice the
president had decided in such a crisis
to launch an attack
our targeting doctrine i've been told
would have led to the detonation of
thousands of megatons
over russian cities
the result would have extended far
beyond destruction of the soviet society
some scientists now believe that such an
attack would very likely have created
catastrophic climatic changes
in the northern hemisphere
had this happened our own society might
have been destroyed even if the soviets
had not been able to launch a single
weapon
if nuclear winter could creep up on us
this way what other surprises might be
in store
the discovery of nuclear winter is an
anticipated development that means
nuclear war would be even worse than we
had feared
by the nature of things the unexpected
is more likely to fall on the negative
side of the ledger
nuclear winter was found on ground
that had already been well plowed by
strategic theorists and planners
the failure of analysis is the sort of
event that should lead us to question
confident assertions
that security might lie in the next
technological breakthrough
we should for example be skeptical of
promises that a star wars defense will
allow move away from a strategy of
mutual deterrence
based on fear of annihilation
star wars we are told could make
possible a strategy based on defensive
systems
and as desirable as this might be in
principle it is unlikely to work out in
practice
in fact by its nature star wars would
probably do more to create tensions and
to reduce them
finally i hope we will not be distracted
by smokes
by snake oil
the belated discovery of nuclear winter
should help us to realize at long last
that the path to peace may be through
arms control rather than through a
never-ending succession of weapon
systems
disguised as bargaining chips
the gentleman from new york mr shaw here
thank you very much
mr chairman i want to express my
appreciation to you and your staff
for the wonderful cooperation you've
extended our staff in
working out this joint hearing
it's appropriate today
that we have this joint hearing
in as much as today is the first day of
new of serious uh discussions of
of nuclear
countdown nuclear strategy that will be
taking place in geneva
under the
nuclear winter
theory that we're discussing
the fierce aftermath of a nuclear attack
would send plumes of smoke soot and dust
from burning cities industrial sites and
forests lofting high into the atmosphere
and within weeks these particles would
cover the northern hemisphere and slowly
drift into the southern hemisphere
blocking out most of the light and
drastically reducing land temperatures
under such conditions survivors of a
nuclear holocaust
would face extended darkness and
freezing temperatures rivers and lakes
would freeze over plant life would
wither and food production would be
virtually eliminated in the ghoulish
season of nuclear winter the so-called
victors of such a terminal battle would
have little in the way of the spoils of
victory as the effects of nuclear winter
spilled over the far corners of the
remnants of our earth
it's apparent that the implications of
nuclear winter impose new realities of
nuclear arms control strategy and
nuclear deterrence
at the very least the nuclear winter
theory raises profound implications for
the u.s and presumably for our soviet
colleagues too
imposing on all of us
the necessity of new thinking creative
thinking on issues such as nuclear
weapons planning procurement deployment
targeting and command as well as for
arms control and civil defense
much of today's hearings will focus on
the recent department of defense report
the potential effects of nuclear war on
climate which was requested by our
distinguished colleague from colorado
tim worth who is
here with us today
in my view it's difficult
to square the
17-page dod report with
a mere five or six pages devoted to the
strata the policy implications of
nuclear winter with the statutory
mandate uh imposed by our congress on
the secretary of defense to conduct a
detailed review of the current
scientific studies and i quote a
thorough evaluation of the implications
of the theory and a discussion of the
manner in which the results will be
incorporated into nuclear weapons arms
control and civil defense policies
nor are we assured by the level of
resources committed by the department of
defense to
the study of this policy
despite an overall weapons research and
development budget of 30 over 39 billion
dollars
the dod requested a meager two and a
half million less than half of the
amount that the president's own science
advisor
george keyworth requested for this study
public debate on this issue must proceed
from a careful scientific base and be
guided by the best evidence available
our intent is to air this evidence as
openly as we can today the issue of
nuclear arms strategy and tactics and
the impact that the theory of nuclear
winter would have on that strategy is an
issue which transcends all others in
importance indeed the fate of mankind
rests in the balance rests on our
ability to cope with these incredible
forces which man's ingenuity
has unleashed
do you want to introduce the others
are there further opening statements mrs
schneider
i would like to commend my two
colleagues and the two chairmen of the
joint committees here for convening such
a hearing i think that there is very
little question that the hearings that
we're holding today are of profound
importance
i recognize also that in the public's
minds there is a feeling that we are
facing disaster at every turn and the
calamity lurks behind every bush this is
very unfortunate because far from crying
wolf the information that we are going
to be receiving today is from scientists
who represent a variety of disciplines
on a topic that is as important as any
that we are ever likely to face the ego
ecological consequences of nuclear war
the report that has been released by the
pentagon on march 1 called the potential
effects of nuclear war on the climate is
an important addition to the awareness
on the atmospheric side effects of
nuclear war but unfortunately this
report does not add much to our
understanding those effects nor to the
development of a mechanism to further
investigate this problem i find it
unfortunate that the report carried a
tone of defending current policies to
state that it is not our policy to
target population centers is a very
little solace when the destruction of
the world's ecosystem is a possibility
also the strategic defense system would
in fact discourage the soviets from
increasing their nuclear arsenals is the
result of the report and i think also a
result of delusional thinking
to suggest as the report does that fire
effects could be reduced by detonating
the bombs closer to the earth and then
as a postscript adding that such a
tactic would be an increase in fallout
points out the critical need for
understanding that a nuclear war would
be totally unlike anything we've ever
experienced on earth
uncertainty is the hallmark of our
understanding of the possible side
effects of the nuclear war in the last
40 years we've certainly had the
opportunity to experience much with
nuclear weapons we've learned that we
are capable of totally destroying cities
causing burning mutilations of various
victims and when exploded in the
atmosphere that they produce radioactive
fallout can cause illnesses large
amounts of dangerous by-products
including strontium-90 could enter our
food chain
but i guess the worst news about the
nuclear weapons that we are currently
evol developing
is what we don't know
we don't know how many explosions the
planet can absorb before it is
permanently altered we also don't know
how the ozone layer might be affected by
high-level bursts
we also don't know what it means to win
a nuclear war this examination of the
potential for a nuclear winter needs to
be expanded so that we can understand
the lowest limits of irreversible damage
to the ecosystem it needs to be
developed by a group that is independent
that has total and complete access to
required information and that is led by
individuals who are create courageous
enough to follow the data wherever that
may lead
we have a responsibility as members of
congress to ensure that every policy
maker in the world is aware of these
findings albert einstein had said that
the nuclear age would change everything
well everything except the way we think
certainly we have a continuation of the
view of warfare that is as ancient as
the practice itself the more weapons the
better
unfortunately it will be exceedingly
difficult to change that kind of
thinking
congress is constantly faced with the
demands for additions to our nuclear
arsenals and the fact that we respond so
readily is evidence of our failure to
recognize that we have crossed an
important threshold one that demands a
fundamental rethinking of the manner in
which we provide for our defense thank
you mr chairman
distinguished gentleman new mexico is
ranking republican on our subcommittee
he's recognized for an opening statement
thank you chairman
we in this country believe that the
nuclear winter issue is a serious is of
serious concern and should be studied
the soviet union is not taking the
nuclear wind winter issue as seriously
as the u.s does
there are some major questions about the
nuclear winter scenario it hypothesizes
that half the world's arsenal of nuclear
weapons would be detonated frankly many
people do not consider that to be a
credible scenario
has an analysis been done of other
scenarios where less weapons are
detonated
do the results of such an analysis also
produce a nuclear winter
likewise the nuclear winter scenario
depends on the release of large amounts
of smoke and dust into the atmosphere as
a result of massive fires started by
nuclear weapons effects there's a wide
range of variation on how much smoke and
dust would be produced
clearly a
key research need is to better refine
the estimates of how much smoke and dust
will actually be produced
this committee's jurisdiction is
civilian uh r d
we should look into whether the existing
research efforts in
climatic effects and fire etc are useful
in analyzing the nuclear winter scenario
we should also consider
whether the research efforts in studying
the nuclear winter possibility will
provide helpful insights into
understanding natural phenomena of
peacetime interests
the nuclear winter issue should be taken
seriously
we should ask what are the policy
implications of the possibility of
nuclear war
the most obvious one is that we should
avoid a nuclear war
since the possibility of nuclear war is
being viewed with universal horror it is
hard to imagine that we need to have our
resolve to avoid a nuclear war
strengthened
the second policy implication is that we
should work towards arms reduction right
now the u.s is meeting with the russians
in geneva for that very purpose
clearly we're proceeding along the
proper lines
if indeed we reach agreement on arms
reduction
it will only be meaningful to the extent
that all parties comply with the
agreement
the u.s being an honorable country will
clearly comply with any treaty and arms
control we need to verify that the
soviets would also comply
therefore we should ask whether or not
the present technologies
of our verif of verification are
adequate
and also we should consider what
additional research and verification
technologies should be studied
finally the nuclear winter scenario
tells us that we need to think about
other possibilities for defending our
country that do not rely on nuclear
weapons
is the president's strategic defense
initiative the answer
mr chairman i will look forward to the
answers to these and other questions
during the hearings of the various
witnesses thank you
the gentleman from colorado has been a
leader and
among those of us concerned on this
issue
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
schuyer for such a prompt response to
the report that came from the pentagon
and having this hearing i think now just
12 days later
i would also like to associate myself in
particular with the remarks of the
gentlewoman from rhode island who i
thought was very very clear and careful
on the subject here we have the pentagon
effectively agreeing that the concept of
nuclear winter is a valid concept
but the next step what are the
implications of that appear to be
ignored what are the implications for
the notion of first strike what are the
implications for the question of
survivability
the pentagon seems to say to us even
though we recognize that nuclear winter
is a valid concept the implications are
that we should continue to do more of
the same it just doesn't seem to me to
be a logical conclusion uh from uh the
evidence that's available that's why
we're having this hearing today is to
see if that logic holds up or if there
are further implications for the
pentagon that they should uh be pursuing
in response to the law
passed by the congress requiring them to
look at this in great detail look
forward to this hearing and i again
gentlemen thank you very much for
putting this together further opening
statements
if not we'll proceed with our first
witness today who is dr carl sagan of
cornell university who's been in the
forefront of the
discussion on this important subject dr
sagan you're
kind to be with us today and we'd be
glad to hear from you thank you
representative udall
i'm very pleased to be here
can somebody turn my microphone on
thank you i can do it myself i see
um
some years ago
when uh
the
first results of our study the so-called
taps study on nuclear winter were
becoming clear to those of us working on
it
long before it was publicly released
uh
it became clear to me that there were
serious policy implications
on
the issue not only uh
the consequences in the northern
hemisphere but the
consequences uh elsewhere in the world
the possibility which emerged clearly
from our calculations that
something
much smaller representative lujan than
a full exchange would still lead
to
almost
the same effect as the full exchange
provided cities were targeted in fact on
that one of our cases was a case where
less than one percent of the world's
strategic arsenals were
employed
but uh
artificially constrained to uh to
be targeted on cities only and there we
got
temperature declines of tens of degrees
for months
so
being a
a novitiate in this strange subject
i felt the need to to talk to
more experienced people
and we were able to put together a
private discussion in fact here in the
capitol with
a range of senior
[Music]
workers in this field in previous
administrations and other
masters of dark arts
and uh
the uh the distribution was very good
the most senior member of the the group
who was there was uh april harriman in
fact
and at the end i i presented what the
scientific results were presented some
hint of
what seemed to me the policy
implications
and one response
by a senior practitioner was the
following he said
look
if you think that the mere prospect of
the end of the world is enough to change
thinking in washington and moscow you
clearly have not spent much time in
those places
and so by these standards perhaps the
department of defense report represents
slight progress
uh
i see in the charge given by the
congress
to the department of defense requests
for quote comprehensive study
request for quote detailed review
request for quote thorough evaluation
and
i must say
i do not see this report as
coming
within light years of
that requirement if this were a
a
paper assigned in a
graduate seminar at cornell university
i think i would give it a d
maybe c minus
if i was in a
friendly mood
for 40 years the department of defense
has in effect assured us that there are
no long-term climatic consequences of
nuclear war
that the climate is not endangered there
are reports by the government through
the years saying nothing to worry about
then some scientists stumble upon a
possible global climatic catastrophe
attendant as i said even to a relatively
small nuclear war
at first we hear that this is liberal
propaganda or distortions invented by
proponents of a nuclear freeze
then there are other studies they tend
to confirm the general picture
then the national academy of sciences
the royal society of canada the
pontifical academy of sciences
the president of the united states and
eventually even the department of
defense
acknowledges that there might be
something to worry about here
nuclear winter
if it were brought about
would be a disaster unparalleled in the
history of the human species
and what is the department of defense's
response
it's that uh while nuclear winter might
happen there are significant
uncertainties of course
nothing has changed
that the correct answer to nuclear
winter is to continue to build many more
weapon systems in aid of reducing weapon
systems at some future unspecified time
peculiarly nuclear winter turns out to
justify all the policies that the
administration has just embarked on
remarkable coincidence
there are no agonizing reappraisals
there are no changes in doctrine or
policy
from their point of view the discovery
of a doomsday machine hiding in the
arsenals of the united states and the
soviet union hardly matters at all it
doesn't change anything
and
by comparison let's uh compare this with
the study released
just two months earlier by the royal
society of canada the equivalent of the
national academy of sciences of our
northern neighbor
which says we conclude that the nuclear
winter hypothesis does indeed modify the
global strategic position and then they
go on to
indicate in what way and i'll mention a
couple of things about that report in a
moment
mr weinberger's 70-page report
talks about the possibility that dangers
from nuclear winter will be comparable
to the other horrors of nuclear war
well how bad are those other horrors
according to a study by the world health
organization chaired by
nobel laureate in medicine sunni
bergstrom of sweden
as many as 1.1 billion people
might be killed outright in a central
exchange involving not just the united
states and the soviet union but europe
china and japan
and
another 1.1 billion people would die
subsequently from the prompt effect if
they did not receive immediate medical
attention which of course would be
unavailable because the doctors and
hospitals are by and large concentrated
in the target zones
well 1.1 plus 1.1 equals 2.2
2.2 billion people according to this
estimate it obviously nobody knows for
sure might be more might be less well
that's roughly half the people on the
planet just a little less
if as the
department of defense now acknowledges
the
long-term effects
radioactive fallout nuclear winter and
so on
might be comparable or even larger
then the department of defense now
acknowledges that nuclear war might mean
the extinction of the human species
and in that sense this represents a
an interesting departure for the
department of defense
certainly i would say nuclear war
means this the destruction of our global
civilization
and uh a non-incidental aspect of which
would be the
destruction of the united states as a
functioning political entity
nuclear war is bad for government bad
for labor bad for business
bad for people on a scale that remains
unreflected as far as i can see in this
administration's policies
now
one
significant
consequence
of
nuclear winter is that nations far
removed from the conflict nations if
there are any that have no part of the
quarrel between the united states and
the soviet union
nations in the southern hemisphere might
be utterly destroyed
without a single nuclear weapon falling
on their territories it's a possibility
you will hear later
uh from dr schneider and others on uh
recent work on involvement of equatorial
and southern latitude regions
the royal society of canada says quote
nuclear winter globalizes the
environmental impact of nuclear war
close quote
there is no hint of this in mr
weinberger's report
there is no reference to the royal
society of canada report
there is also no reference to a report
done by
a branch of the air force
a branch with
what i think is the best acronym in the
business
cadre cadre the center for aerospace
doctrine research
and education at maxwell air force base
in alabama
this report was prudently commissioned
by
the office of the department of defense
something like a year ago mr wagner will
not let's be able to tell us more
details about that
i visited with them in the early
days of their work
this is a
bunch of
majors and lieutenant colonels and some
faculty members from
university of alabama georgia tech
seemed to me very good very broad very
conservative
well
they've produced a report
nobody seems to know where it is
or what's in it
i understand it was published in january
what is in it
be most interesting to know
what this branch of the air force
designated to study the policy
implications of nuclear winter has to
say about it also be interesting to know
why is it that that report has not been
released
the military implications of nuclear
winter seem to me
to be very broad
for example consider the question of
battle management and damage assessment
there is a nuclear war you have launched
some warheads you wish to see whether
they have done what they're supposed to
do
how do you find that out if the target
zone is sucked in
with uh smoke and dust and fine debris
that is a
narrow military consequence
of nuclear winter there's no hint in the
department of defense's report that
anything like that
might uh be of interest to them although
doubtless it is
and then there are
additional ranges of questions
from
how well do tanks function at uh minus
10 or minus 20 degrees centigrade
how well do air breathing engines
do in uh sit
all the way to major strategic questions
for example the credibility of the
policy of extended deterrence
against a soviet conventional attack in
europe
in the face of nuclear winter put boldly
would the united states risk nuclear
winter at home in order to defend west
germany
that seems to me an issue
worth thinking about um are there
implications for protracted wars do we
have to envision submarines that sit in
the abyssal depths for uh six or nine
months until the
soot from the first minor exchange if we
could imagine nuclear war so limited
settles out so that we can then have the
second round
it seems to me that even from the
narrowest of perspectives of the
department of defense this report is
inadequate
the
report does worry about
what is generally called an asymmetry of
perception
what if the united states is worried
about nuclear winter and the soviet
union is not worried about nuclear
winter might there then be some
strategic advantage that redounds to the
soviet union because they are in this
hypothesis too foolish to see what the
consequences of nuclear war are should
we also be too foolish to see what the
consequences of nuclear war are it's a
very curious question and it has lots of
good answers for example a
major high-level joint
study between the united states and the
soviet union of the policy implications
of nuclear winter if the administration
is worried about uh what the soviets
know and believe there are means to find
out there are means to
enlighten the soviet union on this issue
if
there are some deficiencies felt
now
asymmetry of perception is one thing
asymmetry of vulnerability is another
is there a difference in the
consequences for the united states and
the soviet union if there were a global
or even northern mid-latitude nuclear
winter
let me read
three sentences from the royal society
of canada's report
the soviet union's sensitivity to small
climatic fluctuations is well known
since
1972-73 they have endured repeated
drought-induced or frost triggered crop
losses on a staggering scale
mostly in the new lands opened up in the
last two decades
the nuclear winter hypothesis predicts
much larger stresses for the interior of
eurasia
a nation hard-pressed to cope
effectively with current natural
climatic variability will face a vastly
greater threat
there is no hint
of asymmetry of vulnerability in the
department of defense report
there is nothing on implications for
agriculture at all
nothing on
biological implications except that they
probably would be bad
nothing on
the
uh functioning
of society
after a nuclear war is a consequence of
nuclear winter
let me again
just pull out the royal society of
canada's report whereas the side of
canada is a very small organization very
limited resources compared to those of
the department of defense
here for example
mr chairman is a graph
of how
the the area of canada capable of
growing mature wheat declines
as there are temperature declines
so
with a one degree decline it's all
down there with a two degree decline
there's hardly any place left in canada
where wheat can still
grow
be very interesting to see this graph
extended into the united states what
temperature declines are necessary to
wipe out agriculture in the american
midwest
this is surely within the ability of the
department of defense to do
no hint of any such study
is shown here and incidentally in the
the greatly
attenuated national plan for studying
nuclear winter there is uh no money at
all allocated for biological
agricultural social or uh other
implications it's all and strategic
implications everything is
is in the physics
now
it is
to me
remarkable
that there is virtually nothing in this
report
uh
about the implications of nuclear winter
for the relations of the united states
with other nations
and uh there have been within the last
year some dozen
prime ministers other national leaders
of various nations most of whom are
allied with or friendly to the united
states expressing grave concerns about
whether nuclear winter has
implications
for
those nations and their relations with
the united states and the soviet union
and uh these uh proposed implications go
all over the lot
um some nations uh uh
concerned that uh nuclear winter
makes them much more vulnerable but
other remarks for example one which if i
read it right in the new york times
attributed to prime minister papandreou
of greece
says
if there's nuclear winter then greece
will be destroyed anyway never mind
whether soviet nuclear weapons fall on
greece so what the heck we might as well
have american military bases here uh at
least that's what it seemed to me the
new york times was saying i may have
misread it
uh an unexpected consequence
now on the question of uh funding for
further research i've indicated uh first
of all the the grave
omissions
in the uh plan that was uh encouraged by
the president's science advisor george
keyworth and
as far as i can tell mr q earth did a
very good job uh in recognizing the
seriousness of the problem
uh originally this was supposed to be uh
50 million dollars over five years
uh it now has been reduced to something
like half of that and there's an
interesting question about how much of
that is really new money and how much of
that is uh simply re-labeling money that
has been
already programmed
to
study areas of this sort
also
a an important part of the
administration's funding plan is how
little money is
given to the national science foundation
which
is as far as i can tell the sole source
of support for university scientists
independent scientists scientists not
already working for the department of
defense of the department of energy
to study this
i'm sure the administration does not
wish
to have its funding plan
be misinterpreted
that
the administration is afraid to sponsor
further research on the subject by those
who are not directly under their thumbs
university sciences especially it is now
subject to such a misinterpretation
uh
for 40 years
this administration most of the
principles
in it
have been implacable foes of arms
control
now
we are told and this seems to be one of
the principal conclusions of the
department of defense's
report
they say in effect
give us a trillion dollars more or less
for star wars
and another trillion dollars more or
less for new offensive weapon systems
and trust us we are dedicated to arms
control
the department of defense is full of
people i know from first-hand
discussions with grave misgivings about
current strategic policies
current arms buildups and star wars
i find it remarkable that the dod does
not consider it its duty to present both
sides of the argument
congress does not hear from experts
within the government who have grave
doubts on these issues
loyalty to the official doctrines of the
moment is the paramount consideration
whereas a free debate
in which uh
both sides are confident that under
those circumstances the truth will out
that seems to me the prudent approach to
issues of this magnitude and this
difficulty and this seriousness
mr chairman i have a just a couple of
concluding remarks and
they are on
star wars and the connection between
star wars and nuclear winter
and
i i do this only because
star wars seems to be the
lead motif
of the the report by mr weinberger
on nuclear winter
first of all everybody acknowledges that
fully impermeable
strategic defense systems are not in the
cards
uh certainly not for the next few
decades
i point out that a system which is uh
between 90 and 99 percent impermeable
far in excess of what
most
even sympathetic critics believe can be
done
but such a system would permit enough
soviet warheads through an essential
exchange to destroy the united states
so even after a trillion dollars
there is a very serious question of
whether the united states could survive
a nuclear war
uh i also point out that uh
if it is true
that the destruction of uh
of a hundred cities something like that
is enough to trigger nuclear winter even
a full-up star wars system
might not be able to stop it and if
there were an exchange and the soviets
did not have their own strategic defense
system then american attacks on the
soviet union alone would be sufficient
to trigger nuclear winter at least
possibly
second point is that one of the major
soviet responses they've already
publicly announced that they would be
driven in this direction if the united
states appeared
uh ready to
go ahead
with a
serious
strategic defense initiative is for the
soviets to build more offensive nuclear
weapons systems to saturate
to uh
overwhelm
the defense system but that is the worst
possible case for nuclear winter what
nuclear winter says is that there are
too many nuclear warheads in the world
and for
the response to nuclear winter to be a
sequence of events which leads to the
soviet to greatly increase their
arsenals
seems to me profoundly foolish star wars
is a kind of maginot line in the sky
and it has all of the deficiencies of
the standard maginot line uh except that
it's
vastly more expensive and that
it
can lead to much graver consequences
even than the magenta line mentality did
now the actual situation to bear in mind
in a uh in a full exchange some decades
from now uh with a star wars system is
to imagine something like 10 000 nuclear
warheads in the air from the united
states towards the soviet union in near
space
surrounded by a cloud of something like
a million decoys and penetration aids
your job
should you choose to accept this
assignment
is to pick out every one of the ten
thousand warheads
ignore every one of the million
penetration aids and decoys and you have
ten minutes or less to shoot down all
the warheads
if you miss a few percent
everybody is dead
that's your problem
you're willing to bet your life on a
battle management computer
where the program is too difficult to be
written by human beings
it has to be written by other computers
the program is too difficult to be
debugged by human beings it can only be
debugged
by other computers
the system cannot be tested at all short
of a nuclear war
and now
the system can only be operated by a
computer no humans involved except
for the consequences
and if the system fails the world is
destroyed
now i submit to you that you have to be
really looney tunes to bet the human
race on this one
the only way to be really sure
is for major
dramatic
bilateral
verifiable cuts in the strategic
arsenals
congresswoman schneider quoted
albert einstein who said in 1945
that uh the advent of nuclear weapons
had quote
changed everything
except our way of thinking and thus he
said we drift towards unparalleled
catastrophe close quote
that's what's most missing from this
report
even a hint of a change in our way of
thinking thank you very much
thank you dr sagan for a provocative and
interesting
introduction to this important subject
today
we apparently have good attendance from
both subcommittees i suppose we ought to
operate under the five-minute rule in
fairness to everyone
yes indeed all right
i'll defer to my colleagues and begin
with the co-chair of these hearings the
gentleman from new york mr schuyer
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
uh
dr sagan you've given us a a great deal
to chew over
and the question is where do we
intervene where do we crank in this new
factor of nuclear winter into existing
arms control
arms control
strategy of all kinds
the defense department does have
some ameliorating limits on a nuclear
hits for example
they have under the sea up the single
integrated operational plan
they do have restraint a
a criteria known as restraints on
collect collateral damage and that
means that they will normally use the
smallest weapon
to take out whatever the target is they
won't engage in overkill on any one
target now that seems to indicate at
least a
a move in the right direction that they
are thinking of
minimizing
uh damage above and beyond what is
necessary to take out a particular
target
can you conceive of
another criteria that would involve
perhaps
a an urban
an urban
fire critical mass which is what
produces nuclear winter
uh that would take into account number
of weapons kill a tonnage of weapons
number of cities hit
the the spread the distance between
cities prevailing winds temperature time
of year and so forth that would give the
defense department some kind of maximum
number of
nuclear weapons
total killer tonnage distribution and so
forth that would provide a further
uh
limiting
criteria as they they've already
established one but this would be a
further limiting criteria addressed to
the concept of nuclear winter and
addressed to the concept of avoiding
uh whatever the threshold is
assuming there is a threshold and that
we don't just move gradually by
incremental steps incremental steps into
a darker and darker and darker uh period
can you think of some way that under
this overall master plan that they call
sia
such a factor could be introduced
well first of all the united states is
not the only uh the only power that can
trigger nuclear winter so even if we
were a hundred percent convinced that uh
the latest psyop makes uh every effort
under
under firm controls not to
target populated areas not to do all the
things that would maximize nuclear
winter there is the question of the
strategies of the soviet union britain
france and china all of whom as far as
we can tell might have arsenals large
enough to trigger nuclear winter and the
other
the last three mentioned
uh
because of the nature of their arsenals
are primarily targeted on cities
entirely soviet cities
uh so that's that's the first
concern that i would raise about this
issue
any solution to this problem that
involves
targeting
raises questions of verification
how will the soviets be able to believe
us that we don't target soviet cities
how will we be able to believe the
soviets that they don't target american
cities
will we have american military officers
looking into the innards of the uh
the guidance system program of
of soviet missiles will we allow soviet
officers to do the same for american
missiles it seems
extremely unlikely
and therefore bland assurances on the
nature of the psyop or the rice up the
soviet equivalent
simply don't carry much weight it seems
to me
on the question of
whether u.s
psyop
does or does not
maximize nuclear winter there are
diversity of points of view
for example
admiral noel geiler
the former deputy director of the joint
strategic target planning staff the guys
who do the targeting
said in testimony before the joint
economic committee
um i can't remember some months ago
that
the co-location of strategic targets
and uh cities
and strategic targets and forests was so
great
that even an exchange which was designed
only to hit strategic targets would burn
cities
and along those lines the report by mr
weinberger that we heard talking about
has a very curious phrase
it says our strategy consciously does
not target population
now maybe consciously means
intentionally or maybe consciously is
intended to be counter poised to
unconsciously
the uh
the
it's very hard to understand
how you could imagine a central exchange
in which um
submarine
ports are not targeted
there in cities
in which secondary airfields distributed
over a country are not targeted they
tend to be
in cities in which command and control
facilities are not targeted they tend to
be in cities
any thought of decapitation involves uh
targeting cities
and uh it would be very interesting to
uh to hear a presentation
on precisely how it is imagined that
there would be a nuclear war at various
levels in which cities are not targeted
maybe there is such a an explanation
isn't that a sort of a semantical
problem
it seems to me a little disingenuous for
either our country or the russians to
say they don't target cities i agree
what they do is target strategic
uh strategic
targets industrial
targets
government targets and so forth and they
are generally located in cities by
accident
everybody's highly moral nobody intends
to kill people it just turns out that
strategic targets kill people
that attacks on strategic targets kill
people
okay um one final thing on that
congressman sure i'm not sure to what
extent congress has
oversight
on psyop
but it seems to me it's clearly and
properly a highly classified area but it
seems to me that because the details of
the targeting are now
of general concern that it would be
useful
for
some selected members of congress under
some
properly secure circumstances to look
into psyop and see if what is alleged is
in fact true i couldn't agree with you
more on that there seems to be an urgent
need for a congressional oversight
we all have a top security clearance but
it seems to me that at a minimum
the members of the armed services
committee the unit the foreign relations
committee and the intelligence committee
uh should be briefed and should be
involved not only in briefings but in
input on just the kind of uh value
judgments that we have been talking
about how do we factor in
the concept of nuclear
uh winter in our sea up plant
thank you mr chairman gentlewoman from
rhode island
thank you mr chairman uh
dr sagan i'm curious about
which of the many uncertainties
we ought to attack first the department
of defense recognizes the importance of
improving our understanding of some of
the technical underpinnings of the
convincing hypothesis of a nuclear
winter
and i'm just wondering
to what degree is there some
variation on the
actual quantitative impact of a nuclear
winter the lawrence livermore national
laboratory has suggested that this
concept may include the whole concept of
a nuclear winter could include a whole
range of possibilities and not just an
extended period of sub-freezing weather
the fact that there would be firestorms
and the heat would rise
thereby minimizing the the freezing
temperatures
how uh how quantitative can we get in
the predicting of this information and
should we seek further research into
this area
on the part of the department of defense
or other federal agencies
nuclear winter is not a problem amenable
to experimental verification
at least not more than once
and few of us wish to perform the
experiment
it is therefore
restricted necessarily
to the best theoretical physics the best
computing programs and the best small
simulations that can be managed
every one of those of course should be
vigorously pursued and i'm concerned
that the level of funding that
the administration under uh
restricted budgetary circumstances to be
sure
uh has proposed is inadequate
but at the same time uh
and and by the way uh other witnesses
will will provide uh
their opinion on the degrees of
uncertainty dr carrier for example who
chaired the national academy study
but at the same time
it seems to me it would be a
a grave error
to say
that we should not look into the
biological the societal the strategic
implications of nuclear winter until all
the facts are in because all the facts
may never be in
here is a sentence from the royal
society of canada report on
on this very question
at some point the strategists have to
accept the probability of the predicted
consequences and incorporate that
judgment into their thinking
scientists tend to cloak their
predictions in a shroud of ifs and buts
royal society of canada is not
criticizing scientists that's the nature
of scientific work but uh every aspect
of the nuclear strategic issue is
surrounded by uncertainties and there
are uncertain we just talked about one
what are the
soviet psyops what are the american
psyops what is the uncertainty of the
strategic defense initiative what is the
uncertainty of the gaps
the famous window of vulnerability how
uncertain was that it drove
uh the arms buildup partly that we are
now in
i would like to see an even-handed
concern
about
the
reliability and verifiability of every
aspect of this problem
okay let me
also ask you the department of defense
report reviews some of the soviet
perceptions and the conclusion that they
reach is that the soviets have really
done very little work on this subject
are you in agreement with that the
soviets in my view
have not done nearly as much as they
should and i hope will
it is uh however fair to say
that the first three-dimensional general
circulation model applied to uh to this
problem that uh that gave results or at
least one of the first two
was uh
a soviet program
uh admittedly run on a computer with
roughly the capability of an ibm pc
and uh
and with
a program that ultimately comes from
oregon state university
but
they at least did the study
the vice president of the soviet academy
of sciences evgeny velikov
told me that
he has a budget of 2 million rubles for
the next few years
to work on this problem
it'll be very interesting to see
what the money is used for if it is but
if we are to believe his statement at
face value the soviet program is roughly
the same order of magnitude as the
present u.s
program but i think it is absolutely
proper
to raise public concerns about the level
of the soviet research
effort in this area
have you
been involved or had the opportunity to
review some of the data that's being put
together by other federal agencies
such as for example noah that who is
reviewing the the climactic alterations
and to some degree the biological
impacts of a nuclear winter i was a
consultant to the
national climate uh office at noaa that
put together a plan
to
study nuclear winter i
was one of the
reviewers of it i thought it was by and
large a very good plan
and i
testified
i believe before
mr shuri's committee to that
to that effect
but it is
greatly
compromised by being restricted only to
the physical effects
nothing about biology nothing about
society nothing about policy strategy
and doctrine i think in the federal
government could best supply us with the
societal analysis of the impact of the
nuclear winter good question and uh
i
had correspondence with mr keyworth on
on just this issue
i believe that this as many other
aspects of the nuclear winter
implications question ought to be farmed
out to
universities research institutes and so
on and not
restricted to the federal government
thank you very much gentleman from
colorado
thank you very much mr chairman
dr sagan again thank you for for your
help when congressman leach and i
initially proposed this amendment and it
was passed by the congress it was our
belief that this was an enormously
important discovery nuclear winter
and that the pentagon should do two
things
uh first the pentagon should come back
to us and tell us if they believed that
the
concept of nuclear winter was valid
and second if it was valid what then
were the implications
on the first they have come back to us
and said yes it is valid
on the second
from your testimony and i would suggest
from my own reading they have not come
back to us and really told us what the
implications of this might be now you
said that if this were a graduate paper
at cornell
you might generously give it a d
other actions that you have would be
either to throw
the graduate student out school hard to
do in this case we can't do that with
the department of defense we can't throw
them out but we can the other thing that
you do is to say to them go back and
redo the paper right you give them an
incomplete
now
it seems to me that we have the
opportunity of giving them an incomplete
and one of the uh obligations that we
have if in fact the concept of nuclear
winter does have very broad implications
for
our targeting for our arms control
initiatives for
how we are developing our whole strategy
toward the soviet union then we should
go back to them with a series of further
questions
which we in the congress clearly are
capable of doing
what would be the first three questions
that you would go back to the pentagon
with saying assuming that they have
agreed the nuclear winter is valid they
have done so what then are the next
three most important questions to face
the pentagon with first short-term
question i would raise is
please provide immediately the report by
cadre on the policy and doctrinal
implications of nuclear winter
i think
that
would not involve going back and doing
any more work
it's just uh department of defense
left home part of the assignment
then beyond that
i would uh
uh i mean my understanding is that that
report exists it's locked up somewhere
and so there isn't any rewriting
necessary it just someone has to reach
into the drawer and hand it to the
congress
that ought to be done it seems to me if
congress requested uh in 24 hours after
the request
that should surely
um
be a significant first step
okay
all right our uh
next witness is dr carl sagan of cornell
university a man who
needs no introduction he comes to us
today from the
center for radio physics and space
sciences we welcome you and
we're very pleased that you would take
the time out of your
schedule to come to a place like
washington where everything seems to be
living in today and not in
tomorrow to share with us your
particular view of how
our past and our present
may well affect our future carl thank
you very much
thanks very much senator dernberger
senator gore senator burdick i'm
glad to be here
uh as i understand my uh
my function it is uh to
give some sense of what the greenhouse
effect is to try to say something about
uh
greenhouse effect on uh on other planets
uh
to uh again underscore that this is uh
is a real phenomenon
and then
perhaps i can take liberty to say
a few remarks about uh
what to do about it
the
power of
human beings to affect and
control and change the environment is
growing as our technology grows
and at present time we clearly have
reached the stage where we are
capable
both
intentionally and inadvertently
to make significant changes in the
global climate and in the global
ecosystem and we've probably been doing
on a smaller scale things like that
for a very long period of time
for example
slash and burn agriculture
which has been with us for tens of
thousands of years probably
changes the climate to some extent
uh by changing the albedo the
reflectivity of the earth
that uh massive changes uh have occurred
is clear from the historical record for
example egypt was once the bread basket
of the roman empire
uh it may be the same
role as the american midwest plays today
that is certainly no longer the case
it's not a greenhouse effect
issue it
may be an over grazing issue but is an
example of how humans are perfectly
capable of making
these unexpected and inadvertent changes
because the effects occupy more than a
human generation
there is a
tendency to say that they are not our
problem
of course then there are nobody's
problem
not on my tour of duty not on my term of
office it's something for the next
century let the next century worry about
it but the problem is
that
there are effects and the greenhouse
effect is one of them which have long
time constants if you don't worry about
it now it's too late later on and so in
this issue as in so many other issues
uh we are passing on extremely grave
problems for our children when the time
to solve the problems if they can be
solved at all
is now
if you um
if you ask what determines the earth's
climate clearly the main the main thing
that determines it is sunlight sunlight
is what heats the earth
uh not all the light that uh
arrives at the earth from the sun goes
to heating the earth some of it is
reflected back it's just the uh the part
that is absorbed
and what happens is there's a certain
rate at which sunlight is absorbed by
the earth's surface
and there's a certain rate at which the
earth's surface
radiates to space
what comes from the sun is in the
ordinary visible part of the spectrum
that our eyes is sensitive to
what the earth radiates into space is in
the infrared part of the spectrum longer
waves than red that our eyes are not
sensitive to but it's as legitimate
excuse me a form of light as the kind
that we're
that we're uh used to
now if you calculate what the
temperature of the earth ought to be
from how much sunlight is being absorbed
uh equaling how much infrared radiation
would be radiated to space
you find that the earth's temperature
by this simple calculation is too low
it's about 30 centigrade degrees too low
and
why is it too low it's too low because
something was left out of the
calculation what was left out of the
calculation the greenhouse effect
uh
the air between us is transparent
except in los angeles and places of that
sort uh in the ordinary visible part of
the spectrum we can see each other
but if our eyes were sensitive at say 15
microns in the infrared we could not see
each other the air would be black
between us and that's because in this
case carbon dioxide carbon dioxide is
very strongly absorbing uh at 15 microns
and other wavelengths in the infrared
likewise there are parts of the infrared
spectrum where water vapor absorbs where
we could not see each other if uh if we
were only as far apart as we are in this
room
if you add these infrared absorbing
gases to a planetary uh to a planet
then what happens is
the sunlight comes in as before but when
the surface tries to radiate the space
in the infrared it is blocked it is
impeded by the absorbing gases and so
the surface temperature has to rise
so that there is an equilibrium between
what comes in and what goes out so this
is the greenhouse effect it is a
misnomer for more reasons than one it's
a misnomer in particular because that's
not how the florist greenhouse works but
that's a very minor point
there are other gases which absorb in
the infrared
uh all of them many of which have been
mentioned already nitrous oxide methane
the halocarbons and these are products
partly of
agriculture it's fertilizers
refrigeration
aerosol spray cans and so on all
products of our technology
we don't generate much water into the
atmosphere but we certainly do generate
a great deal of carbon dioxide through
the burning of wood and fossil fuels and
apparently benign
[Music]
activity who could object to humans
burning
oil and coal gas and wood
um
i'd like to stress that the greenhouse
effect makes
life on earth possible if there were not
a greenhouse effect the temperature
would as i say be
30 centigrade degrees or so colder and
that's well below the freezing point of
water everywhere on the planet
the oceans would be solid after a while
a little greenhouse effect is a good
thing
but there is a delicate balance of these
invisible gases
and
too much or too little greenhouse effect
can mean too high or too low uh a
temperature and here we are pouring
enormous quantities of co2 and these
other gases into the atmosphere every
year with hardly any concern about its
long-term and global consequences
now
certainly not all aspects of
how
increased
co2 and other gases into the atmosphere
affect the climate are known there are
still many uncertainties although the
overall picture is i think quite clear
and
quite widely understood and accepted but
there are questions about
aerosols about clouds you heat up the
earth how much increase or decrease in
cloudiness is there how does that change
the albedo or reflectivity of the earth
there's questions about the
ocean
and
its response time to an increase in co2
there are feedback effects
and
therefore it is certainly worthwhile to
spend some additional money on further
research on the subject
another point is that
the significant temperature changes on
the earth between
ice ages and out of ice ages glacial and
interglacial time periods seems to be
connected with quite small changes in
the amount of sunlight that reaches the
earth due to changes in
the earth's orbital properties and that
is a
suggestion
that
the earth's climate system may be uh
very delicately dependent on the sorts
of factors
that we're talking about here and that's
why it makes sense to study past
climatic change
on the earth as an attempt to
obtain some calibration
another source of calibration is the
other planets
every planet with an atmosphere has some
degree of a greenhouse effect the most
spectacular case by far
is the greenhouse effect of venus it's
the nearest planet it's a planet about
the same mass radius density
as the earth but
it
is spectacularly different in
several respects one of which is that
the surface temperature is about 470
degrees centigrade 900 fahrenheit
and that
enormous temperature
um
is not due to its being closer to the
sun because venus surrounded with bright
clouds and in fact
because it reflects so much light back
to space if that's all that was
happening it would be cooler not warmer
than the earth
the reason for this uh
absurdly high temperature on the surface
of venus which is uh well understood i
mean soviet spacecraft have landed on
venus and in effect stuck out a
thermometer there's no doubt that the
surface temperature is very high
and and later u.s spacecraft have as
well
the reason is a massive greenhouse
effect in which carbon dioxide plays the
major role now the amount of co2 in the
venous atmosphere is much larger than
here
the atmosphere is almost entirely carbon
dioxide and there's 90 times more of it
there than here
but it is an indication of what
can
happen in an extreme case you look at
mars or jupiter or titan the big moon of
saturn and you have additional examples
of greenhouse effects different gases
different amounts of sunlight reaching
the surface different planetary albedos
and cloudiness
and in all those cases there is also a
greenhouse effect
in addition
it has been possible to calculate those
greenhouse effects
fairly accurately so that the kind of
theoretical
armamentarium
which is used to calculate the
greenhouse effect greenhouse effect
changes on the earth is also used for
other planets and therefore can be
calibrated to some extent against those
other planets if we keep coming out with
the right answer in all those different
cases then probably we understand fairly
well how greenhouse effects work
it would however
be worthwhile
in along the lines that
senator gore was talking about
to
have an increased program through nasa
to understand the greenhouse effects on
other planets this might be a very uh
practical uh application
of planetary exploration
as you've heard the the best estimates
they certainly have some uncertainty
attached to them are that uh at the
present rate of burning of fossil fuels
the present rate of
increase of minor infrared absorbing
gases in the earth's atmosphere that
there will be a several centigrade
degree temperature increase
on the earth global average
by the middle
to the end
of the next century and that has a
variety of consequences including
redistribution of local climates
and through the
melting of
glaciers
an increase in global sea level there is
concern
on a somewhat longer time scale about
the collapse of the west antarctic ice
sheet
and a general rise of
many many meters in in sea level
so
we we have a kind of handwriting on the
wall
certainly there's more research to be
done but as i say there is a consensus
what can be done about it
the idea that we should
immediately stop burning fossil fuel
has such severe economic consequences
that no one of course will take it
seriously but there are many other
things that can be done
one has to do with
subsidies for fossil fuels more
efficient use could be
encouraged by
fewer government subsidies
secondly there are alternative energy
sources
some of which are
useful
at least locally
solar power is
certainly one that might be of more
general use
safe fission power plants which are in
principle possible
and then on a longer time scale uh the
prospect of fusion
power fission infusion power plants in
principle
vent no infrared active gases and
therefore
whatever other problems they may
provide they do not provide a greenhouse
problem
uh
i'd like to close by just saying a few
words on the
the kind of perspective that this
problem as related problems posed to us
here is a problem which
transcends
our particular generation it is an
intergenerational problem
if we don't do the right thing now
there are very serious problems that our
children and grandchildren will have to
face
it is also a global problem it is no
good if uh just one or two major
industrial nations take
major steps to prevent
a
major increase still further in co2 and
other greenhouse gases because other
nations may
through
their industrial development
caused the problem by themselves and not
to say that this is inevitable but just
to give an example
uh the largest coal reserves on the
planet are the united states soviet
union and china china is undergoing a
very major
industrial development
um and the burning of coal is certainly
uh something that must be very
attractive for the chinese looking into
uh the future
i would say that there is no way to
solve this problem even if the united
states and the soviet union
were to come to a perfectly good accord
on this issue without involving china
and many other nations that will be
developing rapidly in the time period
we're talking about so uh here is a um
a
sense in which the nations
to deal with this problem
uh have to
make a change
from their traditional concern
about themselves and not about the
planet and the species a change from
uh the traditional short-term objectives
to longer-term objectives
uh and we have to bear in mind that in
problems like this
the initial stages of uh global
temperature increase one region of the
planet might benefit while another
region of the planet uh suffers and
there has to be a kind of
trading off
of benefits and
and suffering and that requires a degree
of international amity which certainly
doesn't exist today
i think that what is essential for this
problem is a global consciousness a view
that transcends our exclusive
identifications with the generational
and political groupings into which by
accident we have been born
the solution to these problems requires
a perspective that embraces the planet
and the future because we are all in
this greenhouse together
thank you mr chairman well thank you
very much just a um
frustration on international amity uh
some of us made a brief
trip in august through uh
sweden switzerland
germany and then i went into poland
concerned about what we call acid rain
and
some of those consequences and
as i went
the urge in me
for some
forum
for international amity who just it kept
crying out particularly when i got to
poland which is the
home place of
my mother's side of my family and
to
see the self-destructiveness of that
economy and
on the people of that country
and the lack of amity on the part of the
czechs
part of the
east germans it's just a frustrating
experience you must all of you must
experience it every day of your lives
and
i i hope there is an answer in something
other than legislation
but it is your concerns and those many
of us
people who are
familiar with some parts of this this
problem and related problems uh
i guess have to take somehow take this
place beyond
an amendment to require the united
states contribution to the united
nations to be no greater
than the contribution of the soviet
union
and to somehow
lift the people that claim a right to a
place in the united states senate beyond
that kind of a view of the world and
and uh lifted up somewhere closer to the
the real issues that affect people and i
just why i had to say that i was
listening to
to your comments um
let me ask you and i intend to ask the
other witnesses
[Applause]
this and that is whether the following
is an accurate summary of the current
state of our knowledge on this subject
now for the first time there is
international scientific consensus that
global warming can and will occur
while there's still uncertainty
surrounding these predictions it runs in
both directions that is while global
warming could be less than expected it
is at least as likely that it will be
much worse
third all predictions are based on the
assumption that a new man-made
atmosphere will behave in the same way
that natural atmospheres have in the
past
fourth global warming much like fever in
a human being is serious in it itself
but
is also a symptom of massive
perturbation of the natural physical and
chemical processes and fifth
relatively painless actions can be taken
which would slow the warming trend for
example the use of cfcs and spray cans
could be banned throughout the world
maybe cars and trucks could be required
to meet stringent carbon monoxide
standards such as those in the united
states again maybe depending on our
international amity
and forests can be reseeded
is that a
fairly accurate summary of the current
state of
our knowledge
i uh the only uh statement
in
there that uh i would have some quibble
with is the one which goes
that
scientists are assuming
that the
the atmosphere with the new
with the increased uh
infrared absorbing gases in it will uh
act the same as the present atmosphere
uh i don't believe there's any such
assumption there are calculations from
first principles but apart from that
what you read seems seems
you were
invited to testify because you're
something of a
scientific generalist and one of your
best qualities is the ability to explain
complex scientific issues in a way the
layman can understand and you have also
worked on a variety of these issues
one scientist who works in this field
was recently asked why he was devoting
so much time and attention to it when
there seemed to be more urgent
problems in his response was that in his
judgment climate alteration was the most
serious threat to humanity and global
peace short of nuclear war
those seem like
strong words even from a person who's
committed
his entire life to the problem uh you
are more of a generalist than the person
i'm quoting and you have spent
time considering the implications of
other threats including nuclear winter
in the context of potentially
cataclysmic events
how would you score climate alteration
it's
i recognize the need for a rank order of
catastrophes so we
we know which one to devote our
attention to first
um
but uh i would hope that we could uh
concentrate on several potential
catastrophes at the same time which two
or three
i uh certainly agree with your uh
anonymous informant that uh
nuclear war is uh far and away heads and
shoulders uh
the most dangerous threat to the nation
and the world and
possibly the human species
i also agree that
the
sorts of
climatic effects that
we're talking about today
are very serious
because they have global
purview
and
because they're so intimately tied to
something which we are so reluctant to
give up for clear economic and other
reasons namely the burning of
fossil fuels
in 1945 after
the first nuclear explosions
einstein
said
that everything had changed except our
way of thinking
a remark that certainly is still
applicable today and i think is
applicable to this particular
issue
and that's what i was trying to uh to
stress in my testimony that there is a
kind of uh
global
and intergenerational thinking
that is essential for dealing with these
problems the nuclear war issue as well
and
other candidate catastrophes like aids
and other new epidemic diseases
all of which cannot be resolved except
on a
an international global basis the
eradication of smallpox for example to
take a successful example
was done at the expenditure of
a few tens of millions of dollars by a
planetary
effort
by the medical community and uh is an
example on of a problem that certainly
was considered very difficult uh some
thousand years ago
uh that is now uh
it's completely gone there are no more
cases of smallpox on the planet so it's
a reminder to us that these problems can
be solved but
not
if we persist in
keeping to our
narrow
frames of interest in space and in time
thank you
thank you
dr sagan
a lot of has been written about a lot of
people spoken about some of the adverse
effects of increased carbon dioxide and
other gases
are there any benefits
that is one can argue that some of the
colder climates of our country you know
warmer
temperatures would help
well having just come from upstate new
york i know what you mean senator vargas
the
the distinguished scientists who
will follow me on this panel
would be better qualified than i to
answer that question but
it is clear that increased carbon
dioxide uh
for many plant species produces a more
luxuriant growth that's true both of
crops and of weeds but uh
that might be considered a benefit also
the one that you just uh talked about
there
are places that are cold which will be
happy to be warmer there are places that
have a moderate climate that will be on
unhappy about being warmer and that's
that balancing out of uh pluses and
minuses i was talking about before but i
don't think anybody will be happy about
the inundation of all the coastal cities
on the planet
except i suppose the uh
the uh people who live on the new on the
new coastlines who will be delighted to
have
boat traffic yeah
are there
is there any
difference of opinion at all within the
scientific community
over this trend
that is you know with increased carbon
dioxide and other gases building up
that um by sometime next century it's in
year 2075 year 2080.
again the overall temperature will have
increased x number of degrees fahrenheit
defer to uh doctors
manabe and
others
on this but
if you look at the 1982 national academy
report
uh i've got the exact title but uh
climatic effects of co2 a reassessment
something like that
they talk about a few
dissenting
uh scientific papers
and in indeed that is a few scientists
who say the effect is not nearly as
severe as has been widely advertised and
the academy's report uh gives a uh
very uh succinct
uh explanation about why these studies
are inadequate so your judgment the vast
preponderance of
the
thinking of the community is the is in
accordance with what you're saying yes
okay
what what's the best international
arena
within which to address some of these
problems i mean we have to create
a new
forum organization should we work within
some existing
organizations do we deal with this an ad
hoc basis uh what
guidance can you give us at least in
your thinking as to how to
get other countries to a think about
this
including this country
b how to
work in some cooperative constructive
bases
well it seems to me that
that
the situation has to be arranged
that everyone benefits
and
a developing country that is being asked
to forego readily available uh supplies
of fossil fuels
uh has to be given something of value in
exchange
and uh if we develop uh fusion power
plants that are effective for example
then it seems to me there has to be a i
wonder if you give any thoughts to
process in addition to the information
substance i think
i'm going to have to break and get over
to vote and um
well i want to express my appreciation
to you thank you being here today on
behalf of all of us and for those who
aren't here
okay
um i've got to leave too
okay well i didn't have a good answer
anyway
well you have about 15 minutes to think
about
the hearing thank you very much for
coming did you want to do you want to
stay there to ask more questions oh well
i have more questions that we can if
he's busy i can tell him directly
i'll write questions too
[Music]
afternoon welcome to the national press
club
my name is mary kay quinlan i work for
ganette news service and i am president
of the club this year
i'd like to welcome my fellow club
members and their guests in the audience
today as well as those of you who are
listening to this program over one of
the 303 national public radio stations
or watching on one of the 2300 cable
systems affiliated with c-span the cable
satellite public affairs network
before going any further i would like to
remind our members of some coming events
on wednesday october 8th public
television personality aleister cook
will speak about changes in america
since his arrival here in 1932
and on tuesday october 14th our lunch
and speaker will be violeta chamorro the
owner and publisher of la prensa the
last independent newspaper in managua
nicaragua that was closed in june by the
sandinista government
dr robert gale of the usc school of
medicine will speak to us in early
october
please watch for the date to be
announced his topic will be the short
and long-term implications of the
chernobyl incident
i'd like to remind those of you in the
audience that if you have any questions
for our speaker today and i trust that
you will
please write them on the cards that have
been furnished at your tables and pass
them up to me i will ask as many as time
allows
i'd like now to introduce our guests at
the head table and i would ask our
guests to please stand briefly when
their names are read and i would ask you
in the audience to withhold your
applause until i have read all the names
first seated at my far left is mitch
waldrop with science magazine
next to him is bob garfield crane
syndicate
on his right is craig koval with
aviation week in space technology
next to him is stephen g kellman of the
san antonio light i would like to offer
congratulations publicly to mr kellman
he is this year's recipient of the
baltimore suns h.l award which was
presented just before this program
started
next to him is gil klein with media
general newspapers and a member of our
speakers committee who helped organize
today's luncheon
next to gil is andrean novelist
television writer and producer who
co-wrote the cosmos television series
and she is also the wife of our speaker
i will skip our speaker for the moment
uh seated to his right is randy allen
the vice president of pyramid video and
chairman of the national press club
speakers committee
next to randy is james i hauck the
managing editor of the baltimore sun
on his right is jan zigler with united
press international
next to her is don kirkman with scripps
howard news service
on his right is bill rubery with the
richmond times dispatch
and at the far end is chris joyce with
new scientist magazine
billions and billions
our guest speaker is probably one of the
few people in public life who can be
immediately and universally identified
by a number
on on one level dr carl sagan has become
the mr rogers of astronomy
with his clear
clear speaking style he has made complex
theories of the universe so
understandable for the average public
television viewer that he has become a
cult hero
instead of football workers gathered
around the water cooler have actually
been heard discussing uranus and black
holes on mornings after his show
on another level dr sagan is a serious
astronomer he is the david duncan
professor of astronomy and space
sciences and the director for planetary
studies at cornell university
he has played a leading role in the
mariner viking and voyager expeditions
to the planets for which he received the
nasa medal for exceptional scientific
achievement
among the many other national and
international awards he has received
his scientific research has enhanced our
understanding of the greenhouse effect
on venus dust storms on mars the organic
haze on titan the origin of life on
earth and the search for life elsewhere
contrary to popular stereotypes about
physicists and mathematicians dr sagan
is a man of words as well as of numbers
he has written more than 600 published
scientific papers and popular articles
and is the author co-author or editor of
more than 20 books
one of which the dragons of eden won for
him the pulitzer prize
and on still a third level dr sagan is a
public advocate
in the early 1960s his concern about
transmitting earth germs to the moon in
unsterilized rockets led to the united
states and the soviet union setting up
standards for sterilizing space vehicles
to prevent biological contamination
recently research that he and his
colleagues have done on the long-term
effects of nuclear war have made nuclear
winter a household word and have put a
crack into international defense
planning
he is president of the 100 000 member
planetary society the largest space
interest group in the world and he is
now as he will tell us today a major
advocate of a joint u.s soviet
expedition to mars
at the same time he is publicly battling
the concept of star wars and its huge
drain on national research spending
dr sagan our audience here in this room
listening on national public radio and
watching on c-span
may not reach billions and billions but
certainly the thousands and thousands of
us are waiting to hear what you have to
say dr carl sagan
thank you for that generous introduction
i'm delighted to be here
with you i
have 20 minutes in which i want to talk
about
two or three
very serious
questions and then i'll be delighted to
answer questions on them or anything
else on your mind in the question period
in the last few thousand years human
beings have
devised an extraordinary set of
technological advances which have
enhanced our lives have
helped to diminish disease and increase
well-being although there's a great deal
more work to be done
but at the same time
that technology has developed
weapons of increasing sophistication and
power to such an extent that we have now
reached the extraordinary moment
where
our global civilization and perhaps the
human species itself is in peril because
of the
possible misuse
of this technology
for me the uh
the dual content
of technology is
very clear
because the same technology
that i am involved with in the
spacecraft exploration
of the planets
rocket technology nuclear technology
electronics computer technology
is also
the very same technology
that
is used to
devise
and produce
weapons of
horrendous grotesque destructive power
of which we have amassed
we humans some sixty thousand sixty
thousand
nuclear weapons almost thirty thousand
so-called strategic weapons waiting
for the orders to be launched halfway
across the
planet even a tiny fraction
of these weapons
could produce a catastrophe absolutely
unparalleled in the history of human
beings
for example
how many cities do you think there are
on the planet earth
if we define a city as having a hundred
thousand people or more there are only
twenty three hundred cities on the earth
that means that the united states and
the soviet union if they so wished
could
targeting two nuclear weapons per city
destroy every city on earth
and have uh almost 20 000 strategic
nuclear weapons left over to say nothing
of
almost 40 000 so-called tactical nuclear
weapons
this is clearly madness
there is no need for these weapons they
serve no conceivable military purpose if
the function of a nuclear weapon is to
discourage the potential adversary from
using his nuclear weapons a tiny
fraction of the existing arsenals
would suffice
we
live in the year of chernobyl and
challenger
these are
high technology high visibility
projects of
the soviet union in the united states in
which enormous amounts of national
prestige have been invested
they are the last things you would
imagine would go wrong
in those societies because they have so
much to lose if something does go wrong
and there were confident estimates some
only a year before the catastrophes
about how improbable such catastrophes
would be
an article
in a soviet life quoted authoritatively
a uh
soviet deputy minister talking
specifically about the chernobyl reactor
it's a curious coincidence saying that
the average time you would have to wait
for a catastrophic accident at chernobyl
was tens of thousands of years the next
year boom
nasa officials
were widely quoted as saying that at the
then current launch rate of
of the space shuttle you would have to
wait 10 000 years or more before there
was
an explosion on launch
boom
the lesson is
that despite our best intentions we can
make serious technological mistakes
we also know many examples consider the
kal-007
incident that there are serious human
mistakes that happen this is also the
century of hitler and stalin
and we realize that madmen can achieve
high office
in modern industrial states
or
people can go mad while in office if you
put those together
the likelihood that the technology will
go wrong if you wait long enough
the capacity of humans is part of our
being human to make errors
and the possibility of madness in high
office
and you combine that with a world
littered with 60 000 nuclear weapons and
you have a prescription for the most
serious disaster that we have ever faced
and at the same time
almost everybody at least in this
country
goes on as if that's business as usual
no crisis nothing to worry about
occasionally
there are concerns
at
the time the reagan administration took
office there got to be a great deal of
concern about the consequences of
nuclear war partly because of the
the activities of
physicians organizations indicating
how
inadequate
american medical care the best in the
world to be sure would be in case of
even a small nuclear war
in fact
the estimates of the number of people
who would be killed outright in a major
exchange between the united states and
the soviet union range
from hundreds of millions to a few
billion people killed and that's just
from the direct consequences
and from the longer term consequences
including
radioactive fallout and
climatic change such as nuclear winter
the estimates are that another
uh
few billion people
might be killed well a few billion plus
a few billion
is getting
very close to the total number of people
on the planet
now it seems to me there are only two
conceivable solutions to this problem
one is
to reduce the arsenals
so that in the worst case the worst
concatenation of
technological failure misunderstood
orders madness and high office you could
not destroy the global civilization
massive bilateral verifiable divestment
of nuclear weapons
and this is uh of course the
uh proclaimed stated policy the united
states and the soviet union
the only trouble is every year those two
countries add to their strategic
arsenals enough weapons to destroy once
again
every city on the planet they talk a
good game
the other possibility
is a defense
something that would protect you
with high reliability protect the
civilian population of your country
in case of
the worst happening
and this is star wars and star wars has
it must be acknowledged
a major political objective that is to
calm people's
justifiable fears
about
nuclear war
there are many things that can be uh
said about star wars
and
for example i had a debate with general
abramson at the state department
in
late july on this issue but i would like
to there's so many things wrong with it
you can talk for hours just to listing
the
dangerousness and foolishness of star
wars but let me give a few examples
one has to do with porosity
in the best case
if we spend a trillion or two trillion
dollars if we have
decades of technological development
how many soviet warheads would get
through
and the answer according to advocates of
star wars
in
the department of defense for example to
technologically competent people will
give you some number of oh maybe eighty
percent maybe ninety percent something
like that
suppose it's ninety percent ninety
percent of soviet warheads can be shot
down reliably
that means of course that ten percent
don't get shot down soviet union right
now has well over ten thousand strategic
warheads
if you let ten percent of them get
through that's a thousand warheads a
thousand warheads is enough to destroy
the united states utterly
so by the testimony
of the program's advocates
it cannot protect the civilian
population of the united states which
was you remember
the objective
in
the president's speech where he talked
about making nuclear weapons impotent
and obsolete but since then there's been
a change what senator gore of tennessee
calls bait and switch
and now it's justified well it'll defend
missile silos or it'll confuse the
soviets
that's a very different story
the soviets can of course add
to their uh
strategic offensive forces to overwhelm
whatever the united states at great
expense
manages to do in the way of defense
the soviets can out fox
by uh
decoys and penetration aids they can
underfly the system because it does
nothing for a low altitude or
or a speedboat delivery system or cruise
missile delivery system or uh
or nuclear weapons uh in small airplanes
i remind you that the small airplanes
filled with bales of marijuana penetrate
the united states every day
and it is ruinously expensive one
trillion dollars is half the national
debt
one trillion dollars is twice the total
indebtedness of all third world nations
to all western banks a trillion dollars
is too much to take casually you have to
get your money's worth for a trillion
dollars
and finally star wars has the problem
that
the soviets perceive it
the more generous of them as economic
warfare the less generous of them as a
token of u.s intent
to do a first strike on the soviet union
they recognize that it cannot protect
the civilian population of the united
states but if the u.s made a massive
first strike on the soviet union star
wars might be enough to mop up
the residual soviet forces that might be
used for retaliation
so
star wars
cannot protect the civilian population
the united states can be
overwhelmed underflown outfoxed is
ruinously expensive and is likely to
increase the chances of nuclear war
except for that it's a terrific idea
what we really should be doing
the first
thing on the agenda the thing that's
most clear
because it has the largest leverage on
the nuclear arms race is a treaty
banning further tests of
nuclear weapons
in 1963
the united states unilaterally
stopped
testing nuclear weapons above ground
the soviet union immediately responded
with its own unilateral moratorium just
by accident it was a coincidence same
week
and this
de facto moratorium became a du jour
treaty the 1963 limited test ban treaty
and from that time to this not a single
u.s or soviet nuclear weapon has been
exploded
on the ground
in the air
or in space
on august 6
1985 the 40th anniversary of the bombing
of hiroshima the soviets announced a
unilateral moratorium on underground
nuclear testing and invited the united
states to follow suit
the u.s response has been to explode 20
nuclear weapons
and to contemptuously reject
the soviet invitation
it
is a very good way
to halt the further escalation of the
arms rates it's not enough in itself we
want to decrease the arsenals
but it's an excellent first step
to
defuse
the technological drivers
of the arms race on both sides
it is clear that the soviet leadership
is under pressure from their own
hardliners the offer will not remain
open forever present expiration date is
new year's day
and i think there is an urgent necessity
for the united states to follow suit
this is clearly indicated in public
opinion polls both houses of congress
have
have
urged that the united states
join the soviets in this and many
mainstream groups are supporting it just
as an example
[Music]
just in a few days
and i will be there
a venerable organization the american
public health association meeting in las
vegas
is going to have a massive demonstration
at the nevada nuclear test site on
september 30th to protest continued
nuclear testing by the united states to
urge the united states to come to its
senses and uh there is every indication
that there will be a massive civil
disobedience that means
crossing a white line and getting
arrested for trespassing
by very respectable physicians and
health professionals and others and i
give this to you just as one example
of uh
the
recognition of the seriousness of this
issue
by almost everybody but the reagan
administration
i'd like now to come to my last topic
and again it's this
bifurcation that the technology
implies
we have vast abilities there is an
extraordinary amount that we can do
the u.s space program is in deep trouble
it has lost a sense of purpose which in
fact it lost shortly after the apollo
program and since then it's merely been
let's develop machines
a shuttle a space station never what
they're for and in particular the
exploratory goal which was the triumph
of the apollo era
has been completely lost from the us
space program at the same time the
european space agency and the japanese
and
the soviets have
had gradually increasing sophistication
and vigor in their
programs
something that to me makes an enormous
amount of sense
is a joint
u.s
soviet manned and woman
mission
to mars as part of a long-term program
the science would be extraordinary
mars is a world of wonders i will not
take the time to describe it but
it is a just fascinating place a billion
years ago
water was flowing on mars there were
rivers and lakes and possibly oceans
something happened between then and now
and might be good for us to discover
what
but i don't think that you can justify
sending humans to mars purely for the
science you can send robots and they're
a whole lot cheaper
but just as apollo
was primarily a political program it was
the us response
to the
bay of pigs and debacle and the fact of
the first people to orbit the earth
happened to carry soviet passports
so now also
such a program could only be justified
by
political on political grounds
but the story has changed it is not
competition but cooperation which is
called for now
and the joint soviet american
program
could capture the imagination of people
all over the planet to show that these
two nations could use that high
technology on behalf
for a change
of the human species
and to blaze a pathway into the third
millennium
eventually making
the human species a
multi-planet species
the cost
looks to be
less than the apollo program
vastly less than star wars roughly the
same as a single major strategic weapons
system
it is as if
god said to us
i set before you
two choices
you have the technology
to destroy yourselves
you have the technology
to carry yourselves
to the planets
and the stars
it's up to you
thank you
[Music]
so
as you can imagine we have questions on
a wide variety of topics today dr sagan
this first question would like to know
why do you not support the impetus which
the strategic defense initiative has
given to basic research in the fields of
laser nuclear and space technology
thanks
because that argument is
basically flawed
in
the case of apollo for example
we heard
that uh listen apollo is
really great because of spin-off that's
what we're hearing here spin-off
for example
because of the apollo program we have uh
stickless frying pans or uh cardiac
pacemakers
well if we want to have stickles frying
pans or cardiac pacemakers we can get
them
directly by investing in stickleless
frying pans and cardiac space makers
pacemakers without spending 25 billion
dollars to send some people to the moon
that's not the way you make a pacemaker
and in just the same way if we are
interested in lasers for surgery
we should develop lasers for surgery and
not go via the route of a hydrogen bomb
exploded in space to shoot down
some
foreign missiles
in violation of about four different
treaties the united states has solemnly
signed i forgot to say that before
the spin-off arguments
are an indication
that the other arguments have been found
wanting
and i don't think for a moment we ought
to be bamboozled by spin-off arguments
it's too much money a trillion dollars
for
for laser surgery you can do laser
surgery for the tiniest fraction of that
if that's what you're after
france through a united nations
initiative has proposed the
establishment of an international remote
sensing agency which would serve to
provide total global reconnaissance so
every country would be able to observe
every other country totally would you be
in favor of such an activity
thank you
uh
there are many
advantages of
of the space program
meteorological satellites which
which save enormous amounts of money in
avoiding crop damage
communication satellites which are
binding up the planet a historic
revolution occurs because of
of communication satellite scientific
satellites which
it will be no surprise to you that i
think is a good thing
but by far the most important kinds of
satellites have been
military reconnaissance satellites this
is why
i'm not opposed to
military activities in space it's only
weapons in space i'm opposed to
military reconnaissance satellites
prevent
the hotheads and paranoids on each side
from thinking the worst of the other
it's a way to see what the other side is
actually doing in terms of military
capability and troop movements and
treaty compliance and all the rest
and so it is enormously stabilizing
and that's why lyndon johnson said that
those satellites were worth their weight
in gold and they are and by the way
that is a one of the many reasons why
the challenger disaster
has a disaster is a disaster in many
senses the us has an important kh 11 and
kh-12 satellite technology which can't
be put up into space
because we don't have the booster and at
the same time the united states does its
share of saber rattling all around the
world very dangerous to do that
without having
the
optimum satellite reconnaissance now
if the monopoly
in satellite military reconnaissance is
held by only two nations and they are
the uh the contending superpowers
there is a clear
danger
that they will in public utterances at
least
uh distort
what they see for domestic or foreign
political purpose
if they were an independent
organization
some other nation which didn't have a
political acts to grind if you can find
one or some international
organization
then this
possible misuse of
satellite reconnaissance capability
could be avoided but more than that
the rest of the world could be
clued in
to what is actually happening by the
united states and the soviet union
and the french spot satellite for
example
uh was
recently
used to see
what is the state of soviet preparations
for
resuming nuclear testing if the united
states
does not
reply except by exploiting more nuclear
weapons
so to to make
a long answer short i think it's a
very desirable thing to involve other
countries just as
it's very desirable to involve other
countries in
verification
of
for example
compliance with claimed moratoriums on
nuclear weapons testing
the natural resources defense council
washington-based public
service organization has an arrangement
right now with the soviet academy of
sciences in which american scientists
and seismometers are at the soviet
nuclear test facility at semipalatinsk
monitoring the soviets
they don't monitor any soviet explosions
just american explosions
that is an example of a private
organization
helping in this way
the heads of state of or government of
india sweden and four other countries
have said they would be glad to take
over the monitoring on both sides of
compliance with a comprehensive test ban
treaty and i think that's a good idea
this questioner
notes that opponents of the joint u.s
soviet mars mission fear the soviets
would use it to steal american
technology and then use it for weapons
would you give us your reaction to that
please
well or the other way around maybe the
americans would steal soviet technology
and use it for weapons which you have to
bear in mind is that in this sort of
planetary exploration space technology
the soviets are very good
the soviets were
the first to
land the spacecraft on the moon they
were the first to photograph the back
side of the moon they were the first to
land working spacecraft on the surface
of venus
that's a tough place
venus has a surface temperature of 900
degrees fahrenheit
it has a surface pressure of 90 times
the pressure in this room and an
atmosphere which contains hydrochloric
acid hydrofluoric acid and sulfuric acid
being the first to land a spacecraft
there and take pictures and all that is
not easy
uh you remember the soviets did a
sent two spacecraft to halley's comet
just last march united states did not
send anything because we couldn't afford
it
by the way how expensive was it it was
exactly as expensive as a
single b1 bomber
of which the united states is committed
to
buy a hundred 99 evidently would have
compromised national security
uh american scientists
have prepared reports for the office of
technology assessment have testified
before the senate foreign relations
committee on just this issue
and
what they say is that the two countries
have uh very near parity on this sort of
issue but even if there was some
technology transfer in both directions
uh
you have to look at what we get in
exchange
and the idea
of the united states and the soviet
union getting some practice in working
together on high technological systems
before
the cameras
the television cameras of the planet is
worth a great deal
just picture it for a moment
the
interplanetary spacecraft is constructed
in earth orbit
uh
little astronauts and cosmonauts are
welding
moving girders
building stuff together and it's all on
television over a period of a year or
two
then they board the spacecraft again
televised they take off for mars it's
some nine months journey
they
orbit mars they then get into a descent
module they land on the surface of mars
americans and soviets together on behalf
of the human species
again the television cameras show this
happening they then explore mars they go
on let's say some wheeled vehicle down
an ancient riverbed looking for fossils
in the banks or whatever there is
there they spend some time months let's
say on mars that's all before the
television cameras then they come back
to earth with mars samples whatever
wonders they have found and that's all
in television imagine such a sustained
period of many years in which the united
states and the soviet union together
maybe with europeans and others
are
doing something a great adventure great
exploration high scientific merit
together
and everyone on earth sees it
that it seems to me is worth a great
deal
this questioner would like to know why
do you put such faith in u.s soviet
cooperation in a venture to mars in
today's climate of political distrust
distrust tends to be self-propagating
distrust breeds distrust
there is no reason
to
for the soviets to trust us
or for us to trust the soviets on any
issue except i hope this is true
that each nation wishes to survive
that each nation wishes to have its
people survive and their children and
their grandchildren
there are very powerful human reasons
why i think we can rely at least on that
and for that reason
doing things together even small things
is well worth doing
sigmund freud said
a long time ago that it is shared action
between nations
that leads to the diminishment
of mistrust
the united states and the soviet union
each have a list of abuses by the other
as long as my own
you ask for the justification of any
abuse that one of those countries does
and i'll tell you about an abuse that
the other country does
but this is a treadmill
there's no way of getting off this
unless you're willing to break out this
is a way of breaking out without
compromising national security without
involving anything to do with nuclear
weapons it could be done for example in
parallel with whatever divestment of
nuclear weapons i sincerely hope the two
countries would be done it also has the
right time scale in order to make a a
useful goal for the national space
program
it is not so far in the future as to be
impossible to do
uh in the lifetimes of people uh working
now and it's not so short term as not to
to focus the program it's exactly at the
right uh technological distance in just
the same way that apollo was the right
technological distance in 1961 when
president uh
kennedy uh
asked for an american to be landed on
the moon and brought back safely by the
end of the decade
and by all
standards
present studies suggest
that the technological leap
from president kennedy's speech to
apollo 11 is less
than the technological distance from
today
to a landing of humans on mars
you refer to the importance of
television coverage of all events
attendant to that and since you are
before an audience of journalists this
questioner would like to have you grade
the savvy and accuracy of science
technology and space reporting in the
united states today and compare that to
the reporting that you see in other
countries
what shall i say there's some good in
this
a whole lot bad
uh one complaint i have is that science
has a kind of panache
which is used to cover other stuff
on television you see people who are
called science reporters but they're not
science reporters they're medical
reporters they're technology reporters
they're not science reporters
when people win nobel prizes
in chemistry or physics
how many times have you gotten a
coherent explanation of what they win
their prize for
some guy oh i i was really surprised
they woke me up in the middle of the
night my wife said she didn't believe it
yeah i'll be glad to go to stockholm
[Laughter]
what was it for
we never hear
the
virtually every newspaper in america
um
has a daily
astrology column
a daily astrology column
astrology is of course a hoax
there's no such thing
all tests show it doesn't work it's been
known for hundreds of years
why do we have astrology columns those
newspapers don't have a weekly astronomy
column by and large
how is that how many major american
newspapers have
one
science
correspondent never mind a science
bureau one person whose job it is to do
science never mind technology never mind
medicine those are important i'm talking
about science
you have
you have
pages and pages of stock reports
minuscule quantitative information
pages after page
does everybody understand how to read it
no but it's considered that there is a
subset of the readership the newspaper
for whom that's important
newspaper feels it has an obligation to
provide for that subset
you look at the sports pages
box scores
w-b-r-b-i-s-o
what's that
if you're not a baseball fan you don't
know
you pass that by but there's enough
people who are interested that the
newspaper considers its obligation to
show that detailed quantitative
information
where is the page which gives the
detailed science information where is
the page that encourages youngsters to
think about it that shows them they can
understand the mere appearance of
science in newspapers would say to kids
look
it's not too hard for you it's in the
newspaper everybody knows newspaper
isn't hard i must be able to understand
this
it must be okay
science
see i think there is a vast
underestimation of the intelligence and
curiosity of the american people
when we did
our cosmos television series constantly
had that that happen and just recently
it's been
amy and i and some others we did it
something called cosmos a special
edition and again we're getting people i
mean ordinary people not not
fancy academics truck drivers
hairdressers
taxi drivers
saying to us oh i wish there was more of
that on television that's what i'd like
i learned something the first time in
months i learned something from
television
or people say
often but by no means always women say
i had always thought i was too dumb to
understand science
your program showed me i could
understand it it gave them a
self-confidence a
feeling that they could go further lots
of people went further because of cosmos
i think in television in magazines in
newspapers in radio
much more could be done to
convey
science
to the average person and it's important
it's important first of all because we
are a scientific species we're the only
species in the planet that does science
it's intrinsic to us we're curious we
want to find out
but also as
as i tried to say in my in my talk
understanding science is central
to solving
the very serious technological problems
which faces how can we challenge
clear
false
statements
by one government or another
if we don't understand the underlying
technology it's not harder the
technology you have to understand to
understand the nuclear arms race to
understand the star wars to understand
any of these
issues
is not more difficult than what you have
to understand to follow the sports pages
and i believe there's a real obligation
to get that information to the american
people our lives may depend on it
doctor say and what do you think it
might take to get
newspaper editors to devote more space
and energy to covering science
a reasoned argument
divine intervention somewhere in between
those two
[Applause]
that's actually a good transition to
this next question uh this person would
like to know why should not creation
science be to be treated equally with
evolution in our classrooms
because there is no such thing as
creation science
[Applause]
evolution is the backbone of modern
biology you cannot understand the nature
of the biological world without
understanding evolution
i maintain that evolution is a fact not
a theory
science uses the word theory in a way
that's different from how it's used in
everyday life
in everyday life people say oh that's
just a theory meaning you invented it
while putting on your slippers as you
got out of the bed
this morning
but in science a theory is a very well
supported body of knowledge there's the
atomic theory
you know that
everything is made of atoms
people don't say oh it's only a theory
uh
evolution is a theory on that level it
is very clear that evolution happened
all you have to do is look at the record
in the rocks
if you have an undisturbed sedimentary
column
at the top are the beasts and vegetables
the fossils of the bees and vegetables
around now
as you go deeper down you go further
back into time as is clearly indicated
by uh
by radioactive dating and you find
fossils of
animals and plants you don't know
who are those guys they're not around
now
also down there
how come there's no cows how come
there's no people down there just
dinosaurs and trilobites
it's very clear down
down there
many of the plants and animals around
today weren't around they hadn't come
into being yet
up here
those guys those dinosaurs and
trilobites they're not around anymore
they've all become extinct
life evolves now that doesn't say that
that when i say evolution is a fact
that's not the same as saying that the
mechanism of evolution is a fact there
there is still significant debate
uh on for example the extent to which
natural selection explains everything or
in which
cosmic disasters have changed things and
so on
but i think evolution is absolutely
clear cut and of all the nations on the
planet this is about the only one in
which it's a
a serious issue
and it's a serious issue
for
emotional reasons that is
a lot of people who don't want to be
considered an animal
i'm sorry i'll be glad not to call you
an animal if it offends you
but we are animals
we have evolved and it's very important
self-knowledge and then of course the
problem the the main reason is that
there are people whose belief in the
literal truth of every jot and tittle in
the book of genesis is offended by
evolution
but the book of genesis i must say
is not literally true
it has problems it has internal
contradictions
genesis chapter 1 contradicts genesis
chapter 2.
just to start at the beginning
the bible
clearly implies that the earth is flat
it talks about the four corners of the
earth in many places
remember maybe you remember the
the time that satan takes jesus to a
high mountain to offer him all the
kingdoms of the earth
from that high mountain you can see all
the kingdoms of the earth
only if it's a flat earth
if the earth is round you can't see the
kingdoms on the other side
at least satan
thought that the earth was flat and
nothing that the author of that section
of the bible wrote contradicts it
the bible is a great literary document
it's a great historical document it's a
great ethical and moral document but it
is not a scientific document
and
i think that is something which
is clear and ought to be taught and
creation science so-called is merely an
attempt
to introduce contrary to the clear
intent to the first amendment
and i certainly share your
fondness for it
of a particular
secular sorry a particular religious
viewpoint
imposed on the educational system in the
united states not only would i like to
to see first amendment lounges i'd like
to see the whole united states declared
a first amendment zone
[Music]
dr sagan this questioner asks do you
believe there may be more to be learned
in our inner space namely our oceans
rather than in outer space
i don't like to compare the two this
questioner says but would you like to
give us your thoughts
well there's a lot more up there than
down here uh so you know more but
there's no question that the uh the
remaining major unexplored area on this
planet uh are the oceans they have uh
great uh
economic importance great scientific
importance and uh
and uh very nicely there is a range of
submersibles now
uh maybe you remember uh the the
vehicles exploring the titanic
which are opening up a whole new
generation of
of undersea science and i'm i'm all for
it by the way
there
this is not the only place with an ocean
titan the big moon of saturn looks to
have an ocean of uh liquid hydrocarbons
uh and it'd be nice to explore that too
and if opec gets out of hand there's an
economic possibility
although the freightage will be high
this questioner would like to know what
will be the fallout of the split in the
scientific community uh especially at
universities on the merits of star wars
thanks so this is a there's so many
things to say about star wars i didn't
have a chance to to mention this
it's not just
academic community it's also industry
you waive a trillion dollars at the us
aerospace
community and
and
academia
and you're going to find no matter what
the merits of star wars are a whole lot
of people sign up
and what is more there is a danger
that you will produce a
kind of technological momentum
all just to
keep making money and perquisites of
power and promotions and stock options
and all that
that you can't turn off
the political power
of
a an already politically sophisticated
industry
that is devoted
to
maintain what one flag
officer described the feeding frenzy
can be enormous
i am very proud of the academic
community that so many
scientists who could have
been supported by star wars have signed
a pledge i've forgotten how many people
it's
something over 8 000 i believe
top ranking academics from the best
physics departments in the united states
saying that they will not accept
any support to work on star wars
but of course lots do because they have
miles to feed they have families that
have mortgages
and every time that happens
someone is taken out of the civilian
economy out of working on pure science
out of working on things which will
maintain
the economic position of the united
states in the in the world and into
something which has virtually no
economic uh value the dollars put into
star wars are much less efficient in
stimulating the
economy than
dollars put into
domestic technology
or even pure science
dr sagan what is your reaction to
nasa's cancelling some 11 major
scientific missions that were to fly on
the space shuttle should the private
sector get behind these missions
financially
and should the academic sector formally
protest in excess of military missions
well when challenger blew up and the
shuttle program was put on hold
there were a superb set of scientific
missions that were in the pipeline
ready to be launched
by by shuttle
there was for example dear to my heart
the galileo spacecraft to jupiter first
spacecraft to orbit a planet in the
outer solar system for spacecraft to
send an entry probe
into the atmosphere of jupiter to as it
descends to the atmosphere to examine
what's their fantastic mission or the
hubble space telescope
by far the largest optical telescope
ever put into earth orbit promises to
revolutionize our knowledge of cosmology
the large scale structure of the
universe information on
on the origin and fate of the universe
search for other
planetary systems most extraordinary
expected harvest all that's just
sitting around
the cost of maintaining
the hubble space telescope
is
something like a million dollars a day
just to
maintain it
and uh where does this money come from
uh where does the money come from to
maintain the scientific and
technological teams will be needed later
on to launch the thing to
to
study the data that's sent back
so the loss to nasa is not merely the
obvious human tragedy
and the technological setup setbacks and
the money needed to replace a shuttle if
that's what we're doing
but these subsidiary effects which are
extremely serious i don't think there's
any chance that private industry will
put up the hundreds of millions to
billions of dollars for pure scientific
satellites private industries in the
making money business and you can't make
money just knowledge which of course
leads to money
on a longer time scale but
industry is not interested in longer
time scales
no the only way to solve this problem is
to put more federal money into
resuscitating nasa
which
is in desperate trouble in great there's
a great demoralization there is no goal
or direction
to nasa scientific and technological
teams are breaking up
scientists who i know
are leaving the top-ranking
technological institutions
within nasa or that support nasa
and
and we have a real crisis which has the
danger at least in the middle term of
being irremediable that is if all those
people leave and then we get somebody
else in the white house who says wait a
minute this is really very bad we we
have we need nasa
uh the people to do it
may uh may not be so
easily acquired
so i maintain there is a genuine crisis
which can only be solved a
by a larger nasa budget
and b
and almost more important
a
coherent sense of the national goal in
space of the united states
i will do so
this next question
is apparently from one of your
television fans uh this person wants to
know
assuming that the universe is expanding
does that imply that it is finite and if
it is finite what is beyond
great question
um
i can best answer
by an analogy
consider a sphere
and in
the way this is often described a
balloon
and that's to represent the universe but
it's a two-dimensional universe
that is it's just the surface of the
balloon which is the universe
let's say and on that surface there are
flat two-dimensional things
uh flat galaxies flat stars flat planets
flat astronomers
now
consider that universe
is it finite sure there's only so many
square inches or centimeters
on
on its surface
but what's on the other side there isn't
any other side the surface is all there
is you go around and you come back to
where you started from now you'll say oh
wait a minute there's a whole lot of
space inside and outside but that's in
that third dimension that those flat
guys can get to
now up everything one dimension and you
have a kind of sense of what the
answer is to the to the question
the universe can be in einstein's words
finite but unbounded
i think you now have part of the answer
of why there isn't more science
reporting in newspapers
if that wasn't clear then that's my
fault
this questioner would like to know why
should we want to establish colonies in
space anyway
well
colonies in space covers a multitude of
of ideas some of which i
i don't think are good ideas
for example the idea of a large
self-sustaining human community in earth
orbit
which could be done by the way could not
conceivably solve any population
problems every day on the planet there's
a few hundred thousand more people born
than die
so you would have to launch a few
hundred thousand people every day just
to keep the population uh at a constant
rate and you will recognize that uh even
when nasa was doing well this was beyond
its capabilities
there are some people who think it'd be
good idea to
to have
self-sustaining communities of human
beings on other planets so if the worst
happened here that at least there would
be human somewhere i don't think that's
a good idea either
because i think it
would just a little bit
uh add to the to the sense that
the worst
isn't really the worst
but in the long term
after solving our problems here
the idea of humans
moving out into
the space frontier after the earth is
all explored
appeals emotionally to a whole lot of
people not to everybody james van allen
has described this as a kind of religion
in which a lot of people feel it but
they can't tell you what the
justification for it is
but
we are an exploratory species
remember we come from
hundreds of thousands of years of hunter
gatherer ancestors
people who roamed nomads that's who we
are and i believe in our
gene somewhere
that urge is there
the earth is all explored except for the
ocean bottoms that a previous question
are asked about it's natural to look out
to the planets uh to do this and
i gave before some some political
reasons why i think it would be good to
do
united states and soviet union together
but i recognize that not everybody might
find these find this last
in the genes argument a compelling
argument still a lot of people feel it
dr sagan as usual we have way more
intriguing questions than we have time
today before i ask the last question let
me present you with our certificate of
appreciation for being here today and a
national press club paperweight which
can weigh down your newest theories i
guess
the the last question that i have is
from someone who would like to know when
can we expect to spot sagan's comet
well i'm not sure what uh what that is i
i annie and i wrote a book called
called comet
and uh
since i'm very unlikely to discover a
comment i guess that
more properly called
sagan hyphen dreams comet is the only
one i'm likely to have and
that's out in hardback right now it'll
be on paperback in november
[Applause]
do the questions
[Applause]
oh
thank you so much
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
watch called is the strategic defense
initiative in the national interest
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
friends and colleagues
i want to welcome you here today to
debate
on the question is the strategic defense
initiative in the national interest
to address this topic we have with us
two men who might be characterized as
the architects of the president's
strategic defense initiative
and two of the program's most formidable
critics
each of our participants holds an
impressive set of credentials
and unparalleled advocacy skills
there is little doubt that they will do
credit to their respective points of
view
this debate has been organized by space
watch a non-profit research and
investigative organization
uh i want to thank the staff under eric
first for their capable organizing
effort to bring
all of this together
this event could hardly
be more timely
three weeks from today
president reagan
president reagan and general secretary
gorbachev will be in the midst of a
major summit meeting here
in washington
while the primary purpose
of
the summit will be to conclude
a long-awaited treaty to eliminate
intermediate and short-range missiles
in europe it will also set the stage for
other critical negotiations
for the inf treaty is just the tip of
the iceberg of arms control measures
needed to reduce the enormous strategic
nuclear weapons arsenal of both
superpowers
whether this whether the strategic
defense initiative proves to be a
bargaining chip
or an impediment to achieving deep
reductions in strategic nuclear weapons
remains to be seen
but our hope is that this debate will
provide a provocative prelude to the
washington summit
moreover i would hope that our
distinguished panelists will provide
insights and some effective debating
points for those of us who will wrestle
with these difficult questions in the
congress and equally important to those
who will be running in 1988 for the
presidency of the united states at this
debate we intend to disprove a
pessimistic axiom written by british
critic cyril connolly who once said
where there are two alternatives one
intelligent one stupid one noble one
ignoble one serious and sincere one
undignified and one false one farsighted
one short we invariably choose the
latter
we have agreed to the following ground
rules for this debate
by a flip of the coin
we have agreed that the speaking order
will be as follows
it will open with richard pearl
then to richard garwin then to james
abramson and then to carl sagan
opening statements will be limited to
five minutes and we will be strict about
adhering to these time limits
in the front row we have a timer who
will signal the chair and the speakers
when the clock is down to 30 seconds for
rebuttals we will reverse the speaking
order allowing no more than four minutes
for each panelist
following the rebuttals we will allow
questions between the panelists in the
original order each panelist will be
allowed one question directed to one or
both of the opposing panelists responses
will be no more than two minutes and
finally each speaker will be given three
minutes for their closing statements and
the closing statements will be presented
in reverse order of the opening
statements then it will be the
audience's turn everyone should have
received a card upon entering the room
if you would like to put a question
to one of the panelists write your
question on the card and the panelist
you would like to address it to and also
your name
there will be space watch staff members
with name tags to pick up the cards
throughout the debate
i will i will then put the questions to
the panelists we will try to hold as
much time as possible for your questions
without any further delay let me
introduce our panelists
dr carl sagan
is the david duncan professor of
astronomy and space sciences and
director of the laboratory for planetary
studies at cornell university in
addition to more than 600 published
scientific papers and popular articles
dr sagan is author co-author or editor
of more than 20 books including
comet contact and the dragons of eden
for which he was awarded the pulitzer
prize
his emmy and peabody award winning
television series cosmos became the most
widely watched series in the history of
american public television and has now
been seen in 60 countries by over 300
million people the accompanying book
also called cosmos was on the new york
times bestseller list for 70 weeks
and is the best-selling science book
ever published in the english language
lieutenant general james a abramson is
director of the strategic president's
strategic defense initiative
organization he is responsible for
managing and selecting key research and
development programs designed to
eliminate the threat posed by strategic
nuclear ballistic missiles and to
increase the contributions of defensive
systems to u.s and allied security the
general is a command and test pilot with
more than three thousand flying hours he
has a bachelor of science degree in area
aeronautical engineering from the
massachusetts institute of technology
and a master of science degree in the
same field through the air force
institute of technology at the
university of oklahoma in addition
general abramson holds three honorary
doctorate degrees in engineering from
new york university from utah state
university and from rensselaer
polytechnical institute the honorable
richard pearl from 1981
until may 1987 mr pearl served as
assistant secretary of defense for
international security policy from his
office at the pentagon he had
responsibility for theater and strategic
nuclear weapons policy trade and
technology exports european and north
atlantic treaty organization policy and
negotiations between the united states
and its western allies and the soviet
union
since leaving the department of defense
uh secretary pearl has become a resident
scholar at the american enterprise
institute in washington dc and a
contributing editor of u.s news world
report he has concluded a contract with
random house for a political novel that
is intended for publication in 1988
and finally richard gowen who was born
in cleveland ohio
and received a
degree
in a phd in physics from the university
of chicago in 1949 after three years on
the faculty of the university of chicago
he joined ibm corporation in 1952 in his
at present ibm fellow at the thomas j
watson watson research center yorktown
heights new york adjunct research fellow
at the kennedy school of government
harvard university andrew g white
professor at lodge at cornell university
and adjunct professor of physics at
columbia university in addition he is a
consultant to the us government on
matters of military technology and arms
control he has published more than 200
papers and has been granted 34 united
states patents
so that is our
panel it is a distinguished one
we look forward to
a lively and enlightening
debate
and we will begin with an opening
statement
from richard pearl
i must say mr chairman as i
look at the audience
i'm reminded of the story of machiavelli
on his deathbed
do you have a microphone
can you hear
a priest was summoned and arrived at
machiavelli's side
and he leaned over and said
do you renounce the devil and embrace
the lord
no response
he repeated the question the second time
without response in the third time
finally after the third time machiavelli
slowly lifted his head from the pillow
and he said father
this is no time to be making new enemies
at the risk of
making enemies i intend to
discuss today
the view that
the strategic defense initiative is
indeed in the national interest
and i will do so under five broad
categories first the current situation
then
what is the strategic defense initiative
something about the soviet program
something about defensive systems
conceptually
and finally some remarks about the
future of technology
the current situation is easy to
describe
as of today the united states
is wholly incapable
of stopping a ballistic missile fired at
our territory even a single
ballistic missile even a missile fired
by accident
even a single missile fired by
let's say an errant soviet submarine
commander
no capability whatsoever
we would have to watch it complete its
trajectory and reach its target
this is unprecedented in human history
that a threat
as obviously large as the threat of the
nuclear weapon striking our territory is
should go without any response
whatsoever
it represents unprecedented indifference
to the need to provide even minimal
insurance
against the possibility of an accident
or a miscalculation
for those who believe that the most
probable
nuclear war is a nuclear war
launched and initiated
as part of a plan to achieve political
purposes
or for those who believe that an
accident could take place
it seems to me basic common sense
to deal with both contingencies
including what i happen to believe is
more likely which is the possibility
over time of an accident
now what is the strategic defense
initiative as a response to this
situation it is first of all
a research and development program
no decision has been made to deploy
the fruits of that research and
development program
nor could one intelligently be made
before the research and development and
testing and evaluation is complete
the program is aimed at determining
whether
we have the
technological
and financial resources
to develop and perhaps eventually deploy
a defense
that would
strengthen our national security
and give us reasonable insurance against
the possibility of an accident
but we can't answer that question until
the research development testing and
evaluation are complete
and i find it surprising
that men of science without waiting for
the answers without waiting for the
research to go forward
have made up their minds
a strategic defense that might result
from the program of research and
development that we have underway
need not in my judgment be a perfect
defense although there are those who
believe it must
a partial defense
would protect us against an accident or
a miscalculation a partial defense would
strengthen deterrence by protecting the
critical elements of our own deterrent
posture
the soviets have a strategic defense
initiative they don't advertise it but
they've been hard at work developing
technologies very much along the lines
of those that we have underway
and indeed they invest massively in
defenses
conceptually
we do a great deal of a defensive nature
we put concrete around our missiles so
that they can't be destroyed or we make
them mobile or we hide them under the
oceans and submarines
i see no fundamental difference in
concept between the sort of passive
defenses that we all recognize as vital
to maintaining an adequate deterrent and
the active defenses that could serve as
a last resort
as a device capable of intercepting
ballistic missiles when all other
passive defenses and when the nature of
the u.s deterrent has failed if it does
to deter or if an accident takes place
finally let me say that i find it
difficult to believe
that we can stop the march of technology
now and forever almost arrogant to
believe that
the soviets are at work and will
continue their program we couldn't
verify a termination of their program if
they claimed to do so
and to believe that in the year 2050
let's say
we will be where we are today with
respect to defensive technology is to
ignore the lessons of history so the
issue before us
is whether we will be part of the effort
to develop this technology and explore
our options
or whether we will drop out of this
effort and leave it to others
to make their decision and their
determination and perhaps to emerge
with a monopoly of strategic defense
capability
thank you
our next panelist dr richard garwin for
an opening statement
let us return to the origins of the sdi
the march 1983 speech by president
reagan
where he noted that deterrence of
nuclear war has worked and will continue
to work but that it is morally
preferable to rely on defense
we need however a defense so good that
we can threaten no one then we can give
up our own nuclear weapons and it won't
matter whether the soviets retain theirs
if they use them against us they'll do
us no harm
they will rust they will become impotent
and obsolete
four days later secretary of defense
kasper weinberger said that we were
seeking not any kind of partial defense
but a total total and reliable defense
and he saw no reason why we couldn't
achieve it
four years later this february in his
testimony secretary weinberger said that
the administration seeks a completely
effective system that will be a
thoroughly reliable defense and will be
able to destroy soviet missiles as they
come out of their silos
and if any should be missed then at the
separation phase and so on we would
destroy them we would protect entire
continents it would not be designed to
protect missile sites or anything of
that kind but would protect populations
well those are great hopes and great
promises and that's how the sdi
uh began
but that president is ill-served by the
pretense that has deceived secretary
weinberger
that permits him to believe that the
president's goal is still the goal and
the promise of the sdi
indeed that goal is now stated by the
sdio organization as enhancing
deterrence of nuclear war whereas the
president's aim was explicitly to
replace deterrence
the president's goal was to be able to
give up persuasion of the soviet leaders
not to attack us or our allies instead
rendering a nuclear attack harmless
last year in a debate with me in
baltimore general abramson special
assistant defined quantitatively what
sdi must accomplish for its leaders to
believe that they have successfully
carried out their mission and deterred
nuclear war
he said the soviets could right now
destroy 6 000 military targets in the
united states with their strategic
nuclear weapons
he said that if sdio could show us the
way to limiting the soviet targets
destroyed in the united states to 3 000
then the soviets would be deterred
not accomplishing their military goals
they would never attack
but what about defense of population
that we've heard about now that was the
president's goal
would we defend our cities no he said
there's no military benefit to the
soviets in destroying u.s or allied
cities so they would not strike them and
we would not need to defend our
population
according to sdio the russian bear has
become the soviet pussycat
apparently sdio says we are to forget
about preventing uh soviet compulsion
coercion of u.s or its allies
we're supposed to forget about the
threat the secretary pearl has been
stressing for the last 15 years
by that logic nuclear war could be
reliably prevented and freedom preserved
by our unilaterally giving up our entire
military we would have no more military
targets to be destroyed therefore no
threat of war
more realistically there is now the very
real prospect of deep cuts in the soviet
nuclear weapon force beginning with 1500
warheads to be eliminated in the inf
treaty to be signed in three weeks here
in washington
and a cut of 50 percent or more in
strategic nuclear weapons this is a
surer way and a quicker way to preserve
those military targets in the united
states than by continuing with the
research program which is bound to fail
now am i against strategic defense
absolutely not
i think the unprecedented indifference
that you heard about from secretary perl
ignoring the threat of the missiles
fired by accident of a single missile
fired by an errant soviet commander
ignoring the threat to the minutemen is
caused by the fact that the leaders of
the united states have not had presented
to them
limited programs to accomplish these
limited options soon and economically
over the decades i've been much involved
in this sort of thing and have proposed
for instance closing defense of the
minuteman silos taking advantage of the
fact that a minuteman silo survives if
you can keep the nuclear warheads more
than a couple hundred yards away
no interest in this government or in
previous administrations because we do
not regard the threat to minute man as
real
in 1983 president reagan's scowcroft
commission on strategic forces said that
minuteman vulnerability could well occur
but that the overall force would be uh
invulnerable and deterrence assured
because of the presence of the
submarines and the aircraft
as for the accidental launch of any
number of soviet missiles we can solve
that problem in a year and i've written
about it for many years
by retaining on the soviet missiles in
operation as well as on our own missiles
the command destruct link that you saw
works so well on the two solid rocket
boosters in the challenger accident the
same is true against terrorist launch of
single icbms we have a weapon already in
place it's called the cia if we need a
backup it can be the minuteman ii to
perform a nuclear intercept thousands of
kilometers away
thank you
thank you uh doctor
our next panelist once again lieutenant
general james abramson
throughout this debate what you often
hear are
my judgment over simplistic arguments
on a very very complex subject so i must
start with a description of what the
program truly is and build on what
richard pearl has outlined and secondly
reject what i consider to have been the
simplistic arguments
and in fact
dr garwin is often defining for me
what my objective is the objective is
very clear the objective was laid out in
the president's program and has not
modified it was a three-fold challenge
that the president laid out
the first one was isn't there a strategy
that might
be more effective for all the unknowns
of the future
and that strategy is one a search for a
strategy that would not keep the nation
naked to the worst weapon that's ever
been developed in history
secondly that a strategy by itself is
insufficient in fact to
prevent war
in fact the strategy must be supported
by true technical development so it can
be implemented
and finally a very important element
right from the start
was to use
our development to use our technical
prowess
to enhance the ability to achieve
meaningful arms reductions in the
process and it is the combination of all
three of these elements that truly is
the strategic defense initiative it is
not merely an attempt to build a lasers
or to go to war in space now
the technique that is often used is in
fact to def to debunk this concept is to
reach way out into the future
and to take three basic kinds of things
the first one
is to define a poor system one that we
can't afford
the union of concerned scientists have
often done that and if you go through
their various reports from the first one
in march of 1984
where they defined what it is we're
trying to build and said that for a
particular kind of laser it would
probably take something like two
thousand four hundred battle stations
and then costed that
and over time have finally come to the
point that for those same conditions
that in fact it is not two thousand four
hundred but is on the order of uh as uh
dr garwin indicated in his nature
article uh 46 to 50.
then he shifted gears uh changed the
fundamental problem uh and went back to
the 2000 and by the way dick and when i
was in school
it really wasn't effective to
when i got the answer wrong to change
the problem i usually didn't get any
credit for that
the same kind of
reasoning has occurred in several other
places but let me move on
in some cases they make
a simple analysis which is either
irrelevant or wrong
and use that in the arguments to say
that it cannot be achieved
and again the union of concerned
scientists and laying out their
discussion on the neutral particle beam
scientifically made the dramatic error
that made this in fact an impossible
achievement and in fact is incorrect
finally
they say that it can't survive very
often and one of the ways in which they
approach this
is that they do a theoretical analysis
and which is practically uh and
operationally not significant
now all of those are arguments that are
often used but frankly those are
detailed
the fundamental principles that each of
you should consider
is do we forever wish to rely only on a
vision that is dominated by a single
weapon and that weapon being and having
our country and perhaps their country
laid open to that weapon
now
the single most important characteristic
of any
deterrent strategy
and by the way
very often and in fact in my last debate
with you carl
there was a final assertion that what
we're dealing with here is destabilizing
what we must do
is look to the single most important
characteristic of any deterrent strategy
and that is
does it when the crisis develops when
the problems develop when the
misunderstandings develop does it
discourage a first strike with these
powerful powerful weapons or does it
discourage it so i would like to leave a
challenge in fact two challenges with
the
other members of this panel
and they are to explain how it is that
defenses truly are destabilizing and
secondly
to
explain how it is that they will deal
with the fact that the soviets have such
an aggressive program
searching in each of these fundamental
areas because remember the soviets have
been invaded they understand
just how it is
that a nation cannot survive
particularly under surprise attack
they learned that
in
1942 and in
the first world war
so if you would please explain
what your proposal is to deal with and
there are many of these over in the side
what the soviet challenge is in
strategic defense and for those of you i
won't go into all of the details of that
for those of you who would like to see
it there are some booklets on the side
that explain it
thank you general
and our final opening statement
will be presented by dr carl sagan
thank you congressman markey
there are almost 60 000 nuclear weapons
in the world
nearly 25 000 of them
so-called strategic weapons
which are designed
to go from the homeland of one nation to
the homeland of another
there are only 2 300 cities on the
planet earth if you define a city as
having 100 000 people or more
and this is one of many ways of
indicating
the grotesque
disproportionality
between
the power of the nuclear arsenals of the
united states and the soviet union and
any conceivable use
it
is very likely that in case of a
so-called central exchange between the
united states and the soviet union
the
long-run
ultimate
deaths
will be several billion people
and given these stark and unprecedented
perils
it is natural to try to find a way out
of this trap
that the united states and the soviet
union have set for themselves and the
rest of the planet
jury rigging booby trapping the planet
earth with 60 000
weapons of unprecedented
ferocity and destructive power
the idea therefore of defending
against a massive attack by the
potential adversary is attractive
and was reflected in the president's
march 23rd 1983 speech
in which he explicitly
talked
about population defense
not to enhance deterrence
not improving the balance of terror
not shooting down an errant missile or
one launched by
by a terrorist group or a rogue nation
but defense of the continent of the
united states and this has clearly been
the intent of the president and the
recently retired
secretary of defense
but because this is so difficult to
manage
there is a temptation
to shift the ground
to invent more modest
objectives uh and that is why we now
hear
of uh
these uh other objectives and this is
sufficiently serious that it has been
called on the floor of the senate a bait
and switch
tactic
the population
is drawn in by the prospect of being
defended even against a massive soviet
attack and when they're in the used car
salon
then they are offered something more
modest and the hope is that no one will
notice
sdi is fine
if it is perfect that is if no
significant number of soviet warheads
leaks through
the shield
the most optimistic numbers you can hear
from technically competent advocates of
star wars is 70 80 or maybe even 90
percent of incoming soviet warheads
destroyed
well take the more optimistic number if
ninety percent are destroyed ten percent
get through
ten percent of say ten thousand soviet
warheads is one thousand warheads one
thousand warheads is much more than is
needed to obliterate the united states
the shield is leaky
now this is different from the usual
presentation say on network television
where what you see
is a uh two or three
warheads on lazy arcing trajectories
each of which has the letters c c c p on
them so
we know whose they are
and then screen left
comes a spiffy laser battle station with
the letters usa on it so we know which
one that is
and then there's a noise like
three flashes of light and surgically
removed from the screen are the three
soviet warheads and that's that
[Applause]
this is the video arcade version of sdi
and it has dominated the thinking of
most americans on this issue
an actual representation which we've
made an attempt in this painting by john
lomberg to the right
to demonstrate
is
an over taxed
us sdi system
shooting down some fraction of the
incoming warheads with hundreds or
thousands of warheads penetrating the
defense
landing on u.s territory and that's what
all those little orange mushroom clouds
are that you don't see on network
television representations
of star wars
there is
a
delusion of perfection
if you look at the
weapon systems
that have been procured during this
administration and look at the immense
numbers of embarrassing failures
if you look at the 241 deaths of the
marines in lebanon or the 37 deaths on
the uss stark
if you look at the shuttle disaster or
if you like chernobyl
it becomes very clear
that the enormous reliability required
for star wars will be the same
contractors responsible for all those
other systems responsible for star wars
is simply not achievable and that is its
most serious defect it has many defects
but that's its most serious one
that concludes the period for
our opening statements we now
move to the
rebuttal period and the speakers will be
recognized in reverse order
and so for a four-minute time period now
we will recognize those speakers and we
will begin with dr carl sagan
we will leave it to
the
decision of the various teams and their
choices to have dr gowan begin on the
rebuttal period we will recognize dr
garwin for four minutes
thank you
let's bring us back to a discussion of
the sdi program on which general
abramson has been in charge of spending
some five billion dollars
and for which the fletcher committee in
1983 which wrote the technical blueprint
for the research program said that some
70 billion dollars would be required
70 billion dollars over about 10 years
so that's what we're discussing and the
things that are being said now not what
people may or may not have said before
i want to address a couple of the
questions that have been raised
for instance in december 1986 the former
head of system design studies for the
sdio joined with four colleagues to
publish a proposal for early deployment
of an sbi defense incidentally it had
2000 defensive satellites but of a
different type from those that general
abramson was talking about
but two years ago president reagan
signed national security decision
directive number 172 which said that no
sdi system could be considered for
deployment unless it was adequately
survivable and cheaper to build than to
overcome by more offense
why is that well this addresses the
question that general abramson asked how
are defenses destabilizing
because the state department published a
an official explanation of this nsdd-172
it said that if it was not adequately
adequately survivable it would provoke
attack on the system provoke nuclear war
rather than prevent it
and if it were cheaper to build than to
overcome with more offensive weapons it
would stimulate a nuclear arms race in
offensive weapons rather than quench one
i see however the same kind of head in
the sand ostrich behavior toward this
question of survivability and cost that
has led to the challenger disaster and
to a number of other uh failures and
centrally directed programs
it is worse this time because we are not
up against nature cold launch weather
we're not up against the engineering
realities of a supersonic transport
airplane we are up against the
cleverness and determination and
resources of the soviet union which if
they wanted to have their weapons
negated could just throw them away so
obviously it's worth a great deal to
them as it is to us to maintain the
effectiveness of our nuclear weapons
let me address another question as to
why the soviets have such a large
program in defense and in every one of
these areas discussed in the sdi first
they don't
the defense literature itself says that
there is no evidence that the soviets
although they work in neutral particle
beams for fusion research and so on no
evidence that they have a weapon program
in neutral particle b
that we are proposing they have had in
the distant past anti-satellite tests as
we have had and they have a deployed
system for defense against ballistic
missiles in the moscow area their one
site permitted under the 1972
abm treaty just as we had a better
system operated for the year 1975 76 in
grand forks north dakota
the key to the question though of
destabilization
is in the other part of general
abramson's request the soviets know the
perils of a surprise attack and that's
exactly why they fear a ussdi
that is exactly why casper weinberger
said that the a soviet sdi program would
be the worst strategic nightmare he
could imagine because a system incapable
of defending against a first strike
might be very good at defending against
a retaliatory strike the little that's
left after the other side has been
disorganized
next we we turn in rebuttal to
richard pearl
well thank you mr chairman
dick garwin believes that arms control
is a superior way to diminish the threat
that we face
but dick arms control and sdi are not
necessarily mutually exclusive
i can recall not long ago when the
soviets said there would be no
agreement on intermediate forces unless
we abandon sdi
and we in all likelihood will sign
precisely such an agreement when the
summit takes place in washington
moreover
our proposals to reduce offensive forces
met with
soviet rejection
until the president launched the
strategic defense initiative
i'm glad to see that
dr garwin believes in limited defenses
so do i
but i'm touched by
professor garwin's confidence in the
cia's ability to deal with all
contingencies
it's
not a confidence that i share
and i see no reason why we shouldn't
have the insurance that would go with
knowing
that if a missile should be launched at
us we would have some capability some
chance
of preventing it from doing the
destruction it would otherwise do dr
garwin says that the sdi program is
bound to fail
what is it that's bound to fail all
research and development in this area
even the development of limited defenses
of partial defense
even a defense that might strengthen
deterrence by depriving the soviets of
confidence that they could launch an
attack against us
and have enough of their weapons reach
their targets
to diminish
unacceptably our capacity to respond
and how do we know it will fail
history is littered with the
intellectual debris of people who
believe that things could not be done
for men of science i find this
certainty not skepticism but certainty
that our research and technology effort
must fail truly astounding
dr garwin believes that there's no
evidence that the soviets have an sdi
program
but i can assure you that the soviets
are investing heavily in a broad array
of technologies
all aimed at determining what kind of
strategic defenses might be deployed and
the evidence on this is overwhelming
now some of you may have noticed that in
his remarks
carl sagan
refused seriously to respond to the
notion that there are objectives and
purposes of the sdi program other than
the construction of a perfect defense
he much prefers
to erect as a straw man the concept of a
perfect defense and then attack that
i don't believe that one needs assume
a perfect defense in order
seriously to face the questions of
should we be without any defense is
there not something in between
perfection
and absolutely nothing
that makes sense that's in our national
security interest that might protect
lives if a disaster should happen
he accuses the proponents of sdi of
having switched objectives
as though a program could have only one
objective and the most demanding
objective
most military programs have multiple
objectives and that's as true of the sdi
program as it is of many others and one
of those objectives
is to strengthen deterrence by
diminishing the soviet capacity to
execute an effective attack
and another one a vital one in my view
is to deal with precisely the kind of
accident that dr sagan referred to in
another context
he reminded us of chernobyl he reminded
us of the challenger accident and yet he
would sit here and deny us even a
research and development program
knowing that accidents can happen
and i regret to say that over the long
run accidents undoubtedly will happen
there is indeed a video arcade vision of
sdi
but it is carl sagan's not that of the
program managers
the program is exploring a broad array
of technologies we don't know whether it
can be done
we're withholding judgment about whether
it can be done but we'll never know
until we try and if we reduce
a broad and serious program to a cartoon
then i can understand how one would be
discouraged from proceeding forward
that isn't the program that we've
embarked upon
and i think we all have to answer the
question of whether we are prepared
so eerily so breezily
to take the risks
of having no program whatsoever with
whatever consequences that may entail
thank you
next in rebuttal dr carl sagan
thank you i think we're seeing an
important shift in the uh opinions of
those
outside of the white house
who are supporting sti
uh note the concentration
in general abramson and mr pearl's
uh discussion on enhancing
deterrence
uh it is as if
they have acknowledged that defending
the civilian population is impossible
it's an admission of the failure of the
president's vision
and if there is a cartoon representation
of sdi
it is ronald reagan's representation
and i think if they wish to distance
themselves from the president's vision
they should do so explicitly
on the issue of
other ways of enhancing deterrence
that's no problem at all but is sdi the
most effective
the
most reliable way of enhancing
deterrence
and we can argue that there are many
other ways to do that
mobile land-based missiles
de-merving
submarine
fleet ballistic missile submarines
and
other new technologies by no means clear
that anything like sdi is the best way
to enhance deterrence
as for research and development of
course there should be research and
development but nothing like the three
to four billion dollar cost that we have
today
i'd like to say something about cost
naturally the advocates of sdi do not
wish to put a dollar tag
on what a full-up
system will cost
secretaries of defense former
secretaries of defense of both political
persuasions have made estimates in the
one to three trillion dollar range which
gives us some idea
of
what we are talking about
general abramson in one of our past
debates uh has stated that if it was
anything like one trillion dollars he
would recommend to the president not to
go ahead
and that is a very important and
straightforward statement from him
the
kinds of expenditures we're talking
about in the present fiscal climate is a
prescription for economic ruin
the united states in the last
six years has gone from the largest
creditor to the largest debtor nation in
the world
the present national debt is not only
larger than that of any previous
administration it is larger than the sum
total of all previous administrations
back to that
of george washington
uh the united states
has spent
uh each year
an increment in the defense department
budget during the reagan administration
which just equals the increment in the
national debt each year it is not very
difficult to see that there's some
connection between the two as a result
of these sorts
of expenditures
a rhetoric opposing fiscal
irresponsibility a reality embracing it
the united states is now
in many respects something like an
underdeveloped nation
we're 17th in the world in infant
mortality one quarter of the population
is functionally illiterate patent
applications are steeply down they'd be
much more steeply down if not for
richard garwin
there are
there are homeless in the streets of
every major city 20 million people go
hungry every day there are half as many
degrees advanced degrees in science and
technology granted in the united states
each year than there are in japan with
half our population
the united states is 14 percent of the
population with safe water and on and on
and on
the question is
whether national security is merely
developing more gadgets
and i'd like to just close with a one
sentence quote from dwight eisenhower
the problem in defense spending
is to figure out how far you should go
without destroying from within
what you are trying to defend from
without
[Applause]
and
finally
in
rebuttal
general james abramson
uh dr sagan i thought that that was a
very interesting
outline of many problems although i
thought this was a that this nation and
other nations have but i thought that
this was a debate about strategic
defense
and talking about baiting and switching
i haven't got the foggiest idea in terms
of what the relationship is
between
education and payment and sdi
now that's
that's the real issue here and in order
to deal with the real issue and the
investment it's important to understand
what we are spending on the research
program
the research program consumes over the
last three years less than one percent
of the department of defense
budget
it consumes
and the average over the last three
years less than one quarter of one
percent of the total federal budget so
if the implication carl is that by
eliminating sdi you are going to solve
all those problems you're a brilliant
problem solver and i hope very much that
you would be elected to a position of
responsibility to do that
i think there's one more key element
that out must be outlined
notice the difference as
one when we say that we are attempting
to enhance deterrence
nobody has explained why defenses cannot
enhance deterrence because after all the
first objective is to prevent that
nuclear war in the very first place
uh and
the the contention that we have moved
away from the president's vision
is dr sagan and dr garwin telling me
what i'm doing i know what i'm doing i
know what the president wants me to do i
have my direction and it's very very
clear and in the first direction that
came out it said that sdi will enhance
deterrence because after all it is
intended as a first objective to prevent
war
and i think that it's very important to
illustrate that merely because
we recognize that there is nothing
perfect in this entire world
that does not mean that we do not
support
the president's objective of working to
make a very thoroughly reliable or an
effective defense possible
now let me deal with one more key
element of this
and it's important to recognize
the differences between even though they
may be stylistically very great the
differences between what we're saying
here are not so great as one might say
in both cases we are saying there should
be a research program
in both cases that research program
should be aimed at defense
in the case of dr garwin he has said it
should be concentrating on terminal
defense the
the attempt to defend weapons in order
to enhance deterrence and in fact he has
offered several ideas in those something
called swarmjets he's also offered a
unique idea and that's burying bombs
across the northern territory of the
country and blowing it up in such a way
that the dust will stop the warheads on
the way in that's a last-ditch stand i
must say as we one looks at the real
difference here is the thrust of the
program
and one more time i would say we are
searching
in searching for
the most efficient way to do two things
prevent war by interfering with their
strategy
and if the tragedy would ever occur
to find a way to protect as many human
beings on this planet
as we could
as we are as the as the creativity of
our engineers and as the resources that
the congress allows us
uh not only now but in the future uh
that can be applied to the overall
program and we are dedicated to making
it
affordable
and cost-effective at the margin those
criteria
and the really good news
is that we are making progress in all of
these fronts we are making progress in
the strategy
the technical progress is immense at
this point and i invite many of you to
come and look at that spend as much time
as you do listening to both sides of the
debate
seeing what the real progress is we have
the most open program in history
and thirdly
the last challenge the president laid
out
was one where for the first time in
history we have the prospect of true
arms reductions
in spite of all of the worrisome
uh efforts that the critics of the
program have said that this will make it
impossible for the first time we have
the real reductions and we have real
negotiable proposals on the table now
that sounds to me like a successful
strategy and a good news story
thank you general very much now that
concludes the
opening statement and rebuttal period
we're now going to move to a period of
questions wherein the panelists can ask
one another
questions
the
uh
the limitation will be this that
collectively each side will be given two
minutes
to be
decided upon by that side as to how they
will use it in order to respond to any
of the questions which are posed
we would ask
that
in anticipation of that that all of you
out there who have been given cards to
write your own questions that you begin
to pass them down to the center
of each one of the aisles and the staff
will come down and
pick up your questions so that
they can also be posed to the panelists
so let us
uh begin at uh this time
with
uh
a question
by richard pearl to
to dr gowan and dr sagan
carl for how long do you think it is
prudent
safe and wise for us to go on without
any capacity whatever to interfere with
even a single accidentally
launched missile
and recognizing
as you did that we should have an sdi
program but not at the three to four
billion dollar level
what level do you think is appropriate
and how would you organize that program
well
first of all
i think we have heard cia aside
from richard garland ways to do it which
don't involve sdi
for example
the
the
fusing
by radio
signals of
warheads on u.s and soviet strategic
missiles so that if there is an errant
launch they can be
destroyed in flight assuming the good
will of either side
and the use of existing
well if they're really not good well
it's unlikely they would just fire one
one ballistic missile
um
and uh
the other
method that he mentioned was the use of
minuteman boosters and warheads to
destroy
uh missiles not so fused soviet union or
by some other nation or
the idea
of a terrorist group having a ballistic
missile is slightly laughable
sdi does not respond to the most likely
delivery mechanisms of terrorist groups
or small nations which are
nuclear weapons in embassy basements in
washington and
motor boats in harbors as far as what a
prudent level of sdi funding goes
i would think something
around a billion dollars a year
might not be excessive
next question posed by
dr garwin to general abramson and
richard pearl
uh general abramson in a september 21
report from the department of defense to
the congress it says because it cannot
be expected that the soviet threat will
remain static a defense that could be
effective if deployed in the mid-1990s
may not be effective if deployed
significantly later
consequently such delays could result in
the loss of deployment options i gather
then that there is a race imagined
between the deployment of a strategic
defense and the evolution of the soviet
strategic threat
now
your chief scientist told us last year
that sdi would be feasible only if it
could be done in a totally revolutionary
management fashion taking half the time
of a normal program
and you yourself i believe have said
that the launch cost to orbit has to be
reduced from your fifteen hundred
dollars per pound for the space shuttle
by a factor factor ten or so
you would be working with exactly the
same contractors as on the space shuttle
and other defense programs some of which
dr sagan mentioned
how will you and they achieve a 10-fold
reduction in launch costs below what you
were able to do when you were in charge
of the shuttle program
and do that responsibly and predictably
sooner than the soviets can react how
can you assure the nation and our allies
that that can be done
dick
i'm delighted you asked that kind of a
question and i'm afraid i'll have to
answer since you are arguing by analogy
with my personal history
i was responsible for the maverick
missile
uh in the early days that was when i was
in charge of it the lowest cost uh and
most effective missile within its
specifications that had ever been
produced
the lowest cost most effective fighter
that the united states has produced
is the f-16
and in fact i brought that in line in
three years and only i didn't do it
alone i was fortunate enough to have a
national team of exactly those
contractors that you are degrading
and i would say that
when you compare with a space shuttle
first of all when i was in charge of it
it was a safe program
secondly
it was very clear from the start that
the space shuttle was an a generation of
technology that it would not offer the
cost effectiveness
that we would need for not only this
system for
in the future but others
therefore we are embarked on precisely
that and that's the good news of the
program and i can give you example after
example of that the research is not
scientific research primarily of the
kind that is often suggested creating a
new laser or something of that although
part of it is that let me give you one
example
of a good news story of exactly that
kind
in every one of these missiles or in
every one of our systems we would have
to have a
inertial unit something that tells the
missile where it's pointed and how it's
pointed
and we have now achieved what i consider
to be an economic breakthrough in that
area where the past all of these units
cost on the order of a hundred thousand
dollars
and we now have one that will promise in
production to be on the order of five
thousand dollars now i can give you any
number of those but that's part of the
good news story the answer is we will
find a way or we will not propose
uh that it's ready
now we'll stay with the general abramson
as he poses a question to doctors garwin
and sagan
uh
i think that it's it's i've already
asked the key question
uh and dr garwin uh countered by talking
about a type of stability uh that i
think is often confused
there are several types of stability
one is called arms race stability and
that's what's often used
in these discussions perhaps the most
important one and the one the
characteristic of any of these that i
talked about
is this
crisis stability the one where we
have a situation
not where it's merely an accidental
launch or maybe it is in fact this this
this terrorist operation
but where the real issue
is
how do you take away the incentive to
strike
now you have given us
a
uh
you have not answered my fundamental
question could you describe how it is
that relying exclusively on offensive
missiles
forever with all the technical and
political unknowns in the future truly
can offer us the level of crisis
stability the world deserves
uh that's your question we really can't
rely on offensive missiles always
we will have some defense if it is
necessary but the defense for these
limited jobs has to be put up against
other means of accomplishing the same
goals
and that was the recommendation of the
scowcroft commission no defense in our
future
but single warhead icbms in survivable
basing either in silos or mobile
smaller submarines to permit the
reduction of nuclear weapons without
having all our eggs in a single
submarine basket
the problem is that we want to escape
from the fact of vulnerability
and one escape is into fantasy we know
people like that but that is not an
option for a democracy which wants to
take care of itself and even contribute
to the
well-being of the rest of the world
so that's why i propose that we have a
billion dollar a year non-sdi program
the sdi is too much advertising too much
demonstration and not enough performance
and it should be oriented to
investigating whether there are any new
ideas out there the ideas that have been
proposed thus far have been found
wanting if you say maybe somebody will
think of something new maybe and we want
to be the first to do so but will not
think of it in a seventy billion dollar
program oriented toward deciding whether
deployment is possible or not
and finally dr carl sagan for
general abelson and mr pearl thank you
the um
i want to see if i can
succeed in
drawing the distinction i've been
pushing at a little bit
the president on more than two dozen
occasions
has stressed that sdi
is either a
for population defense
or b
is non-nuclear
now it's true that
he proposed
sdi
without much significant
discussion with his advisors when
secretary of defense weinberger heard
about it his comment was it's not a bomb
is it
um
what i would like to ask
is uh is it true what the president says
that it's for population defense and
it's non-nuclear
or
and is that what sdi is working on or is
the president misinformed
well again carl you're posing this as a
choice between alternatives when in fact
it is entirely possible and the sdi
program is indeed intended to explore
a variety of approaches and a variety of
objectives my own judgment you asked the
question earlier if we wish to put
distance between ourselves and the
president why not say so explicitly
my own view is that the president's
long-term vision of the comprehensive
defense is just that a long-term vision
in the practical world of the near
future i think we're unlikely to
accomplish that
but you go to the extreme view of saying
that because you cannot accomplish a
perfect defense in the long-term future
you should have no defense now
and that strikes me as dangerous and
unwise now the program aims at
a layered defense
with varying degrees of capability
undoubtedly evolving over time
i believe that from the earliest
deployment of a strategic defense we
would have the enormous benefit of
knowing that we had some significant
capability to deal with the kind of
accident that you made a persuasive case
is likely to occur
dick garwin wants to do it with
minuteman two missiles
i can remember talking to dick garwin 15
years ago
about the
effectiveness of the program of
ballistic missile defense that was
tailored specifically for that purpose
and his view was as pessimistic then as
his view is today and yet he thinks you
can take an icbm and over
easily convert it into
an anti-ballistic missile device if he
would apply that standard of
assurance and confidence to the sdi
program he might trade places with
general abramson but the fact is
that
the multi-layered approach
offers every opportunity to produce some
early defenses that are partially
effective and depending on the evolution
of technology
it may be possible someday to reach that
more comprehensive goal but you do not
have to accept
and i think would be foolish to accept
that only a comprehensive defense is
worth pursuing and if it can't be
pursued then we should have no defense
at all and that's the essence of your
position
i think i do need to add a comment
uh it is continually posed that a
partial defense or a defense that is
building by phases one step at a time
toward the president's long-term goal is
either to defend strategic weapons or
people and that is not the case if it
were exactly the kind of terminal
defense and limited to the terminal
defense as dr garwin has indicated that
might be the case then we would have to
make a choice do we put those terminal
defenders around
a city or do we put them around a
minuteman field
that's the precisely the function of a
layered defense to ensure
that we can attack the ballistic
missiles at the most efficient area uh
and that's when they're just getting
started and layers behind that and what
we defend depends on what the soviets
are shooting at
uh and we will indeed be defending
people we will be defending people right
from the start it won't be a perfect
offense
but in the long run we will continue
in a responsible way and the responsible
way to build anything as radical as this
is a step at a time to get experience in
that first step and then build toward a
second step enhancing the technology at
each step of the way
let us
just conclude at that point on the
question
uh period and move on to uh questions
from the audience
and um
uh and
we'll begin with a question which is
posed to the abrams and pearl side we
will give them two minutes to answer and
then two minutes to
uh the other side to also comment upon
uh what they have heard the ques the
first question is this
since the soviets are and are likely to
remain adversaries why is an sdi likely
to provoke the soviets to deploy
additional offensive weapons in order to
offset us defensive deployments and to
enhance their own deterrent forces
general abramson mr pearl
two minutes
if we were limited and limited our
thinking to terminal defenses of the
kind that dr garwin is talking about
that would be exactly the case
a single layer with a single countable
number of responsive
missiles all they have to do is to try
to add a few missiles in order to change
that that's very different than a
layered defense for example five layers
with
uh only sixty percent effectiveness at
each layer and by the way this is an
example that's all it is but we have
very real possibilities of building to
that level at this point it's quite
clear that it's possible
uh
instead of just one or two or three
additional missiles we're talking about
293
it's impossible
uh for them within their economic
constraints to deal with a layered
defense by doing precisely that
therefore they would there are logical
people on the other side they're logical
adversaries and they would pick the the
approach uh that
wouldn't break the bank for it
if i might add to that the question
accepts implicitly the notion
that the soviets insist on having
offenses at the level that they now have
them and that they would not be content
with any
lower level of offensive capability and
yet as we look at the soviet offensive
force
thousands of warheads on ballistic
missiles in particular
many of us believe that that force is
vastly larger than the soviets need for
deterrence
and if that is the case and by the way
the soviets themselves said that they
would be prepared to reduce their forces
if in fact the existing soviet offense
is excessive to their needs
over and above what is required for
deterrence then they would need not
respond to the degree to which all that
we were taking away from them was that
additional and quite menacing capability
that i believe they're not entitled to
have
dr garwin in second two minutes rebuttal
it is not i who say that defenses are
destabilizing it is the reagan
administration in explaining the
president's action and i'll just say it
again
unless the defense is adequately
survivable it's likely to start a war
rather than prevent a war
and unless it is cheaper to build than
to overcome it will cause an offensive
arms race now if you don't accept those
uh statements secretary pearl general
abramson argue with president reagan the
defense department and the state
department
now what you appear to be saying is that
you're confident that you can satisfy
those requirements i see no sign of that
i see inside the sdi a willingness to
assume away the threat
to make a straw man response to fire all
the soviet nuclear-armed interceptors
simultaneously because that's least
effective rather than holding them when
the target for when the targets are
within range
i see a continuing misconception that
space mines have to be covert to be
effective ignoring the fact that they've
always been proposed as overt so once
you find out that there's a space mine
which says i am a soviet space mine
there's been no proposal what to do
about it it's no sense saying we'll find
out it's a soviet space mine so i
believe that ignoring the requirement
assuming it away is the way to disaster
and that's why i think that the research
in ballistic missile defense ought to be
done without an sdi organization
let me uh just add going back to what
the question asks
it is certainly clear
that uh if the soviets wish to maintain
a
high probability of a certain fixed
level of damage on the united states
and if they believe that a deployed sdi
will be able to shoot down a certain
number of their warheads then the option
open to them uh there are several
options one is to increase the number of
warheads until it compensates
for the capability they imagined for the
ussdi
and since it is very likely that the
capability uh to do
that involves existing technology and
will be much cheaper than sdi we give
the soviets their the advantage on that
issue in addition
the soviets have opportunities to under
fly sdi if even if sdi
were to work
miraculously
it doesn't touch ballistic missiles on
depressed trajectories it doesn't touch
low altitude aircraft it doesn't touch
cruise missiles it doesn't touch uh
motorboats in in harbors
and finally the soviets have if sdi is
deployed a strong incentive towards
decoys and so-called penetration aids
and
for all those reasons the response to
sdi available to the soviets looks to be
cheaper and technologically uh readier
than sdi itself
the next question goes to dr sagan and
gowan
and that is that
science
entails constant technological
advancement since sdi embodies the
pinnacle of american technology how can
you as scientists justify suppressing it
general abramson said the work is not
science it's engineering and what i want
to do is to go back into a much smaller
program where science and imagination
hold sway and i wouldn't mind having a
general program for reducing the cost of
everything we do in the defense
department as well as in the government
so i think it's great if we can get this
promise of a 5 000 inertial guidance
system into production i think it would
be wonderful to use it in our strategic
offensive missiles as well as in the
defense but that's not an sdi thing
that's a technological thing science i'm
in favor of
cheaper uh products i am in favor of i
just don't think this ought to be done
under the mask of a long-term response
to the president's dream one man's dream
while delaying the near-term
accomplishments in ballistic missile
defense that we could obtain if we did
not have a research and development only
program
dr sagan
one aspect of sdi which i think has not
been mentioned and it's important to not
lose sight of
is that when you wave
a trillion dollars
at the u.s aerospace industry and
scientists and technologists
you will produce what one general
officer described as a feeding frenzy
now what happens
is that any such goal whether it can be
accomplished or not whether it's
feasible or daft
deflects
a large
fraction of the available u.s scientific
and engineering talent away from other
tasks away from improving
deterrence in other ways away from
conventional
arms work and especially away from the
civilian economy
and in that way
sdi can work to erode national security
in the broad definition of dwight
eisenhower that i mentioned before just
one other thing i i was asked but not at
the time that we had a chance to to
rebut by general abramson
what was the connection he said between
education and sdi why do i put at the
feet of sdio uh all of these
underdeveloped nation
qualities of the united states that are
getting increasingly
distressing
the reason is that all of those items i
mentioned can be addressed by money
education can be addressed by money
and you say it's only a small fraction
of the department of defense budget and
even smaller fraction of the gross
national product yes that's true right
now
but if you
succeed in getting into a deployment
circumstance then the budget says
everybody acknowledge go way up so not
only will money be taken away from
education but scientific and engineering
talent will be taken away from education
from the civilian economy and so that's
how all of those items are connected
with sdi
general amazon mr pro will be a little
bit lenient on the time you have for
i'm a little disappointed i think i have
to say frankly because i came here
expecting i would hear a
spirited argument about sdi and what i'm
what i think i'm hearing is
from the other side is nitpicking about
how much money we're spending there for
sdi therefore having a strategic
research program they just want to spend
less money on it than we do and if you
believe carl sagan we're going to
raise or lower the infant mortality rate
if we just divert funds from sdi into
i don't know what program
the simple fact is that
sdi is affordable and manageable
particularly
if one looks at
the enormous investment that we now make
in offensive forces and can look forward
to a future in which we can reduce that
emphasis on offensive forces and use the
consequent budget reductions to finance
sdi
it's all very well to talk about a
trillion dollars in some future but
that's not the program that we're
operating no request has been made for a
trillion dollars
unless the research and development
which is of much more manageable
proportions
indicates to us that we have a
financially sound and technically
competent program there would not be any
proposal to deploy much less a proposal
to deploy at a billion dollars so i
think we are being
burdened with responsibility for a
program that doesn't exist and yet when
it comes down to the crucial issue which
is the concept of whether it is wise to
go undefended
i find that the other side has conceded
the point and both garwin and sagan
believe we ought to have a defense they
would just do it differently from the
way we would do it
in that differences uh there are quite a
few differences and i commented earlier
between what is theoretically possible
and what is operationally effective
clearly
i agree in fact i'm in violent agreement
with both of you
that we must have a survivable kind of
system
dr garwin raises one of his most
favorite of all kinds of issues space
mines
and it is a serious problem it's one
that we do deal with we deal with very
very intelligently we spend a lot of
time and effort working on it he also
knows that much of it we are not allowed
to talk about however let me just deal
with one part of this issue so that you
understand the difference
between the way it is simplistically
offered in the theoretical sense and the
reality uh of this particular kind of
countermeasure and i only offer this as
one example
often dick has explained that an an
orbiting satellite if it's a if it's an
sdi satellite always goes in the same
path uh and therefore it's easy to put a
space mine up there and the image in
your mind uh that comes out of that is
perhaps something like a persian gulf
mine that they just kind of sit
next to one of our satellites and there
it sits and we don't do anything
in fact we make our satellites so that
they can maneuver we give them hardening
so that they can handle nuclear weapons
at least up to a reasonable radius and
those areas are ones we're making
progress in
dick then says aha but a space mine is
simple
and therefore you can put more fuel on
and you can always stay with this
maneuvering satellite let me tell you
from my experience
the last space shuttle mission that i
had was the first time that we repaired
a satellite in space
and
crippen
flew a very nearly perfect kind of a
rendezvous with the solar max satellite
and it took nearly all of the fuel for
maneuvering that the space shuttle had
as we did it
secondly
that even if you can come into that
position and the russians have automatic
uh capability to do that then the game
is not even yet even still
because it is never perfect and once
again let me go to my experience as a
fighter pilot you've watched the
thunderbirds of the blue angels and as
they fly it looks very smooth as they
stay in formation and move with this
system but i can tell you that the
people who are on the wing the wingmen
are sitting there working like mad
putting all kinds of control inputs into
this
the the assertion that dr garwin and the
union of concerned scientists often make
at the theoretical level is
far from the reality of the operational
situation
thank you next question goes to general
abramson and mr pearl and that is under
what circumstances
would you accept a ban on the deployment
of sdi in return for deep cuts in soviet
offensive weapons
of course one has to define the terms in
order to answer that question and i
don't know what is meant by deep cuts
but the proposals that are currently
being discussed in which
offensive nuclear weapons would be
reduced to the order of six thousand
would still in my judgment leave
enormous scope
for horrendous damage and to go utterly
undefended in the face of nuclear forces
of that scale would i think be
dangerous and unwise so i would
certainly not agree to ban
strategic defenses in exchange for
a
reduction of that scale
the president at the iceland summit
proposed to the soviets that we would be
prepared to delay
the deployment of strategic defenses
until after a period of disarmament
during which
all the offensive ballistic missiles
on both sides would be eliminated
he made the point which seemed to me
logical and i hope this is responsive to
the question
that
in the absence of strategic offensive
ballistic missiles no one would have
anything to fear from the deployment of
a strategic defense since it would have
nothing to shoot down
unless the other side cheated
the soviets flatly and categorically
rejected that proposal
giving some
serious rise to the question
why are the soviets so dead set against
the united states
continuing a research and development
and testing program that looks very much
like their own
you have 30 seconds okay fine
two minutes to the
opponents
i think the soviets are so unhappy about
the ussdi because they don't like to
sign an agreement with an insane partner
because they think that the sdi will not
work against a first a soviet first
strike and they ask what we want it for
there's no
real explanation why let me quote
secretary perl back from 1973
in a debate which we both participated
he says if the minute man is vulnerable
there's no need to fear that the soviet
union would actually launch such an
attack but the political consequences
would be dangerous
how to get out of it he said the best
procedure would be to defend strategic
missile complexes with abms
the effect of such defense on deterrent
survival would be substantial as an
alternative however we should press the
soviets to bring their strategic forces
down to the level of comparable u.s
forces
now that's what we're talking about now
the 50 percent reduction would be only a
first step toward much deeper cuts
but those deeper cuts will not happen if
the residual forces are disarmed in
prospect by the deployment of a
strategic defense
i already quoted secretary weinberger as
saying that a soviet sdi would be the
worst strategic nightmare he could
imagine
former secretary of defense mcnamara in
the 1960s said if the soviets deployed
this nationwide abm defense with 5 000
nuclear armed interceptors we will build
50 000 nuclear warheads to counter it if
necessary
the step at a time defense is precisely
the recipe for increasing the soviet
offensive force and at every moment
increasing the potential destruction if
nuclear war comes
sagan
i think we have to bear very clearly in
mind what would our response be
if the soviets were developing an sdi
system of the sort that were talking
about
and
we had to face the possibility
that what they had in mind was a
devastating first strike against the
united states with their sdi system used
to mop up the residual retaliatory
capability of the united states that is
precisely the circumstance that they
have to face with sti then they are
quite properly worried about that as we
would also
therefore there is the makings of a
bargain here
each side four goes
sdi
and is at least freed from that concern
about a devastating uh first strike we
have before us a historic opportunity
may not occur again
for massive reductions in the strategic
arsenals on both sides and considering
the absurdly large number of such
weapons it would be foolish not to take
advantage of that opportunity
next question to dr garwin and
dr sagan
richard pearl
has stated that there is evidence of an
overwhelming level of soviet sdi
research
do you agree that it's possible to
document the level of
soviet
sdi type research
i heard ambassador warren zimmerman in
the fall of 1985 to a group about this
size explained that the soviet union put
about 50 percent of its military budget
into strategic defense
that sounded extreme somebody from the
audience asked whether he was sure and
what was his source he said after
thinking yes he was sure and his source
was a recent cia study about which he
couldn't say anything more
but i happen to have with me the
unclassified testimony of robert gates
and larry gershwin from june 26 1985
and they said that the soviet union
spends about equal amounts on strategic
offense and strategic defense together
about 20 percent of their military
budget
so here this honest capable man whom i
knew personally
was misleading the audience he said 50
percent of the military budget goes to
strategic defense the number in the
document he was quoting was 10 percent i
have no reason to doubt that the soviets
spend 30 billion dollars a year
in our money on strategic defense but
that includes their vast air defense
program operating 10 000 radars ten
thousand interceptors three thousand
fighter aircraft their civil defense
program with three billion dollars a
year or so the operation of their
permitted system around moscow and yes
some research on sdi the answer to which
is not a u.s defense but our counter
measures program which runs at about one
part in 20 of our current sdi program
that's not a counter measures research
program that's a countermeasures
deployment program so i'm not troubled
by the soviet sdi they have a very
substantial effort in numbers if you
believe in numbers then you really ought
to worry about the agriculture gap
because we have two percent of our
people on the farm and they have 30
percent
dr sagan just like to underscore
the fuzzing that is often done by
american spokespersons between
soviet anti-missile defense and soviet
strategic defense which is largely
soviet anti-aircraft defense which in
turn is due to the very great
preponderance of u.s strategic
intercontinental bombers over the
comparable the not comparable much less
soviet force
mr pearl
i hope
i hope those of you who are listening
caught
the word yes buried down deep in dick
garwin's answer
yes he said the soviets do have a
strategic defense
initiative it doesn't trouble him
but the fact that they have one
certainly ought to lead us
to the question of whether we can afford
to be
without one
now
carl sagan wants to make sure that
nobody misunderstands the statistics
about soviet
defenses and in order to make sure we
don't he has pointed out how much they
spend on defense against aircraft and
a variety of other defenses
dick garwin used the figure 30 billion
dollars
it's fair to ask isn't it what does this
tell us about
the soviet view
of whether it is right and proper and
legitimate to have a system of defenses
as you listen to official soviet
spokesman who decry the notion of
defending one's forces
and indeed we've just heard the other
side in this debate decry the notion of
mounting the defense
look at what the soviets are doing
in every area in which they have been
capable of mounting a defense they have
done so defense against our bombers
defenses to the degree they can against
our submarines
a variety of measures intended
to assure that
their strategic deterrent could survive
attack and perhaps to do more than that
we ought to be doing precisely the same
thing
in the most effective way we can
providing for defenses now on the other
side they would have us do it entirely
by relying on offensive forces and only
those defenses other than
sdi
i think the only conclusion you can come
to
is that on the other side they just
don't like the sdi program
well that concludes the period for
questions and now we're going to go to
concluding statements
each
participant will be allowed three
minutes
for a concluding statement
and we will begin with dr gowan
secretary pearl is right i don't like
the sdi program
it was
born in fantasy and is carried out like
the admirers of the emperor who had
new codes
now we don't actually have to be naked
to nuclear weapons we can wear a small
amount of clothes but what is bad is to
believe that you are fully covered when
you are not
i would like to take a little of my
closing time
to point out that the leader of the sdi
program has here
given a couple of comments which are not
actually attributable to me he says i
want to put nuclear weapons in the
ground and blow them up in the northern
territories no not unless you believe
the northern territories are one mile
north of each silo where we would have a
small nuclear explosion which would
never go off because there would never
be an attack if there is an effective
defense same argument as the sdi makes
except that this would really be an
effective countable defense
he points out that the shuttle has great
difficulty maneuvering uh to achieve a
position with respect to a satellite i'm
not proposing a manned a reusable space
mine
that's the trouble with the shuttle it
carries a very small almost vanishing
percentage of its mass into orbit as
maneuvering fuel a space mine can carry
50 percent or 70 percent as maneuvering
fuel it has no other mission
i really do believe that the sdi has to
look at the threat as it will come if
that's the best kind of space mine a man
maneuvering space mine which costs a
billion dollars and carries a percent or
two of maneuvering fuel they don't
understand the space mine threat
the other two counters to the sdi and
the reason why it will not be found uh
to be
uh adequately cheap and survivable
are the fast burn booster the soviets
built missiles as did we
liquid fueled if they go to solid fuel
missiles which they already have the
number of satellites which can
participate in the
attack on the missiles in boost phase
will drop from something like 13 percent
to one or two percent with the missiles
that the soviets have now
with the fast burn boosters that the
fletcher committee considered not a
single one of the defensive satellites
could destroy a soviet missile in boost
phase
the other problem the three problems are
space mines overt space mines fast burn
boosters and the third is nuclear-armed
anti-satellite weapons which the soviets
already have they're called gaga
interceptors they are deployed around
moscow they could make as many of them
as they like they would come up against
the defensive satellites at the time of
a first strike if you believe there
would be one anyhow and they would
destroy them they would carry decoys so
that they could not be injured by the
small rockets which are the defending
satellites only means for the next 10 or
20 years uh to destroy boosters
in fact it is unlikely that these uh
warheads would even be seen by the
defensive satellites so we really have
to look at this we shouldn't look at it
only in controversy like this we ought
to get together and discuss these
matters it would help if the sdi would
read my papers thank you
[Applause]
now for his concluding statement richard
pearl
i'll say i'm sorry to general abramson
excuse me
i think the important thing about the
entire debate is number one we both
believe in some defenses some investment
here that's critical
there is a complete difference about
what it should be uh what the investment
really and truly should be in terminal
defenses or
something that can be much more
effective layered defenses there's a
great deal of difference between uh the
assessment of progress and perhaps most
importantly about where we can
potentially go
the difference is that
these are criticisms which are aimed at
the potential of the future where we
have thousands and thousands of people
across the country who are out there
making the changes and making the future
happen so that when a deployment happens
it will indeed meet the criteria that
the president outlined those criteria
are very clear we haven't
projected any kind of a difference from
those criteria those are first of all
let it be militarily effective second
that it be survivable thirdly that it uh
in fact produce arms race stability by
making it less expensive to build one of
these systems than it is uh to counter
it by building more of the same now i'd
like for you to imagine just a little
bit dr sagan introduced an
imaginative
picture here
think of what an ss-18 truly is an ss18
about nine stories high it's a huge
machine
and that it has it weighs nearly
half a million pounds now just the raw
material and the cost in that particular
system is immense
we are working now for these space-based
interceptors and not exclusively only on
space-based interceptors but on those
systems for something that will be about
three feet high
uh and that will weigh on the order of
150 to 175 pounds now will that be
cost-effective at the margin
there is no question just from the from
the uh
overall kinds of technology and the
differences and what we can produce that
we're working in an area where we have
an advantage
we will not bring forward a proposal
to deploy
until
it makes sense until it meets those
criteria but i can assure you it's
happening very very quickly
regarding dr carwin's point we are
working more seriously on each of those
those counter measures than he
understands he has had access to many of
the classified areas of the program and
i have
specifically authorized him
to go into some of those areas and i
just leave you with one last challenge
dick for some of your systems that you
think are so effective i would ask for
you to bring that proposal
an operationally effective proposal to
me a practical proposal that we can
implement because that's what we're
working on not the theoretical counter
counter measures but the real counter
measures that can be affected
and for his
concluding statement dr carl sagan
last week there was a harris poll
of the american people
concerning the negotiations on reducing
the budget deficit which
may or may not be concluded this week
uh 82
of the american people said
that they did not want social programs
cut
58 percent believed
that significant defense cuts are
essential
for deficit reductions
these are very large
majorities
considering the
enormous
barrage
of
argument
from the department of defense the white
house and their supporters
on the need
for a military buildup two trillion
dollars has been spent on the military
since they've been
in office i think it is remarkable to
see
the independent voice of the american
people on this issue
it is true
that the smaller the scale that sdi is
imagined the cheaper it will be
and therefore the more politically
accessible it will be
if
general abramson and mr pearl are saying
that uh full-up population defense is
only one of the possibilities of
of
sdi fine it is a possibility which is
not very likely
not very cost effective and indeed very
dangerous if the objective is to find
some other way of enhancing deterrence
if the objective is some other way to
shoot down an errant missile let us find
out how to do that
without being burdened by the
president's vision of an overall
population defense
star wars
is a highly porous
system which cannot
protect the civilian population of the
united states
even without
soviet countermeasures
there are a wide range of soviet
countermeasures available to them
the system can be overwhelmed
it can be
underflown
uh overwhelmed by adding more warheads
under flown
by
delivering nuclear weapons by ways other
than higher arcane ballistic missile
trajectories
it can be out foxed
it is an inefficient way to enhance
deterrence
it is ruinously expensive
it is likely
to increase not decrease the likelihood
of nuclear war except for all of that
it's a terrific idea
[Applause]
i would like to see this administration
devote
some small fraction
of the media time and bureaucratic
attention
to explaining why it's important to
reduce the strategic arsenals
in a
massive bilateral
intrusively inspected
missile reduction and to be responsive
to the grotesque
buildup
of nuclear weapons since 1945 to the
present time
something which future generations if
there are any will regard with the same
abhorrence
that we regard the institutions of human
sacrifice or
chattel slavery in terms of simple
planetary hygiene it is essential
that we reduce those arsenals at least
at first to a tiny fraction of their
present numbers and to free the human
species from this specter of massive
destruction thank you
and now
in conclusion uh his final statement
richard pearl
i hope carl sagan that
perhaps when he visits here in december
you will have an opportunity to make
that
impassioned appeal to mr gorbachev
because we have had on the table
from the
from the earliest days of the
administration proposals to reduce
radically the strategic arsenals of both
sides i i find a little curious the way
this debate has taken shape
we are general abrams and
abramson and i on one side
respectively a long time
public official and
a professional soldier and
on the other side we have two scientists
i was brought up to believe that
science has a method and that method is
to identify a hypothesis
to do research and experimentation and
carefully collect data
and ultimately render some judgment
about the validity of that hypothesis
the hypothesis before us today is
whether sdi
will prove to be in the national
interest
and us non-scientists on this side of
the table have said let's collect the
evidence
let's do the research
let's record the results carefully and
then
following the scientific method let's
make a decision about whether we have
accomplished a program that is
affordable and that is in our national
interest that's not a question that we
can answer today and i find astonishing
the certitude
on the other side of the table first
that sdi won't work and second that
there are a dozen different ways to
overcome it if it does work they also
seem to be quite certain about what the
soviets will do
and yet if the soviets take seriously
their judgment about the effectiveness
of the program
carl sagan just said you can under swim
it and under fly it and out fox it they
needn't respond at all except by under
swimming and under flying and out foxy
they don't have to build initial
additional weapons
let me
conclude by
trying for a moment to put this in some
historical context
this debate is not unlike a debate that
took place in
the 1940s after world war ii
when harry truman was president of the
united states
and some of you will recall a debate in
those days over whether the united
states ought to proceed to develop the
hydrogen bomb
it wasn't carried out in public it was
carried out in fact in great secrecy
and the scientific community
pretty much divided 90 percent against
proceeding in 10 4 and the 90 were led
you will recall by robert oppenheimer
and a small band 10 or so led by edward
teller argued that we should proceed
to develop the hbo
the argument of the 90
was that if we proceeded to develop
hydrogen weapons the soviets would do
the same and there would be instability
and great danger
the argument of the minority was that it
was imprudent
not to proceed
we now know
that while that debate was taking place
while oppenheimer and teller were making
their respective arguments
a young soviet physicist by the name of
andrei sakharov
had already been assigned by joseph
stalin the task of developing the soviet
hydrogen bomb
and had harry truman
who wanted to see the
facts as they emerged from the research
and harry truman decided with robert
oppenheimer and not with edward teller
the soviet union would have emerged
in the late 1940s or early 1950s with a
monopoly of thermonuclear weapons
and i leave it to you to conclude how
the
face of the globe
how the values that
carl sagan and dick garwin and general
abramson and i all share
might have been altered
i hope we don't make the mistake
that harry truman refused to make
and believe
that we can stop history and the other
side just by wishing things were
different
[Applause]
i would like to thank all of
the panelists for joining us here today
i believe that we've had
an excellent debate
exchange of ideas and i want to thank
our speakers and i want to thank all of
you who are here
uh for your participation in this
uh important debate
the cannon caucus room has never been as
filled as it is today and i think it's a
reflection of the importance of the
issue which we're debating that it was
able to draw this kind of attention
across uh washington and in fact people
from across the country who came in here
today for this debate i'd like to
thank the staff of space watch who
put
together this
uh forum here today
they
they consist of eric first cynthia kelly
patrick tracy catherine mcgraw arthur
klein and dan charles and i think they
did an absolutely splendid job in
organizing a debate of this of magnitude
and i'd also like to
use this opportunity to offer some
closing observations on the future of
the star wars proposal
i believe that the year
ahead of us is going to be
a year of reckoning for the strategic
defense initiative program
between now and december of 1988 the
president the congress and the american
people have some important decisions to
make
about star wars and national security
decisions which ultimately should be
based on a determination of whether or
not star wars is in the national
interest the president has to decide
whether he is willing to accept some
limits on star wars in return for deep
cuts in u s and soviet strategic nuclear
arms
congress has to decide what level of
funding it wishes to provide for star
wars and whether to limit star wars
testing in order to ensure continued
adherence to the traditional
interpretation of the abm treaty the
american people have to decide on who
will be our next president and whether
they want an administration committed to
star wars testing and deployment are one
committed to preservation of the abm
treaty and willing to discuss limits on
the exotic technologies of star wars
how these decisions will come out is
anybody's guess but i think that in
today's discussion we have had a chance
to look at some of the questions that
must be considered before our country
commits itself to proceeding with star
wars testing and development questions
like will star wars work
or can it of fox overwhelm or be
outflown will it make our cities in
population safer or will it only defend
our missile silos and military command
centers how much will it cost and can it
meet the nitzer
criteria of cost effectiveness at the
margin will it usher in a new strategic
relationship based on defenses or will
it destroy prospects for arms control
and touch off a strategic offensive and
defensive arms race
underlying these questions is a more
fundamental one should we put our faith
in technological solutions to our
problems or should we seek political
solutions negotiated solutions
congress has decided this year to limit
star wars funding to no more than 3.9
billion dollars and to prohibit any
testing outside the traditional
interpretation of the abm treaty that
gives enough time for our next president
to make the decision on whether or not
to go ahead with star wars
one of the great things about our system
of government is that the people decide
who they want to have serve as their
leaders and what direction they want the
country to move towards the final
decision on who our next president will
be
is in the hands of the people who are in
this room the people who are watching
this broadcast and millions of others
across this country for they will be
choosing a new administration to begin
serving in january of nineteen eighty
nine
you and the people like you will
determine who will sit in the oval
office and who will sit across from the
negotiating table from general secretary
gorbachev and making that decision
i would hope that very serious
consideration will be given to the issue
that we have discussed today where the
star wars is in the national interest if
you want to continue to be apprised of
start of space watches uh program of
debates uh throughout the coming year on
this and other issues
please
contact our staff immediately after this
proceeding and we were more than willing
to put you on
our mailing list
if you have any ideas
in terms of how we can frame debates for
a public
discussion
please come forward with those ideas as
well we need the input of all sides if
we are in fact going to be able to frame
this debate in a way in which the
election of 1988 will reflect reflect
the important the informed uh citizenry
uh that we really uh have to have so
once again i want to thank our panelists
dr gowan and dr sagan
general abramson and richard pearl i
think they all did an excellent job and
we thank all of you for your
participation
[Music]
you've been watching a debate on the
strategic defense initiative held by the
organization space watch this program
will re-air on c-span on saturday
november 21st at 11 30 pm eastern time
that's 8 30 on the west coast
[Music]
during the next american profile c-span
asks senators phil graham of texas and
bill bradley of new jersey how they
first
we continue now with a conference on
international policies on the
exploration of space
the program included remarks by
scientist carl sagan the president of
the planetary society
[Music]
our key note speaker for the afternoon
is indeed carl sagan david duncan
professor of astronomy at cornell
university
an active planetary scientist
in addition to being a world figure with
an agenda that's as broad as the
concerns that push humanity um
interesting change in carl's
proposed talk that happened in the last
week and and i'm interested to see how
it will affect
his remarks uh the title that went out
on the preliminary announcement of this
program i think most of you will
remember said what mars can do for
america the title that carl is going to
speak to this afternoon is somewhat
broader what space can do for america
carl sagan
[Applause]
thank you john
well i uh i changed it from uh from mars
to space when i
realized
that the audience would be rather
different from the one at our meeting
the last few days
and uh i wanted to be able to
uh represent at least a range of
opinions uh expressed at our
at our meeting
and uh it is also true that uh the title
says what it can do for america but as
you will see
i will uh try to broaden that focus as
well
imagine yourself as a kind of
extraterrestrial observer
watching the earth over the last 4.6
billion years since its formation
at the beginning especially you see a
lot of things falling into the earth
the final stages of accretion
but you see hardly anything leaving it
an occasional hydrogen atom
that's about it
maybe a big impact sprays debris
off the earth
for 4.6 billion years it's uh
it's one-way traffic
and then
suddenly
just
in the last few decades in our time
that situation changes
suddenly there are
little objects
filled with instruments
leaving the earth
orbiting it
entering into orbit about the sun as
artificial planets
and then
running through the solar system
little elegant space probes
examining
every one of the planets known to the
ancients
from mercury to saturn
and beyond
uranus and
next august
neptune
and
not just instruments but occasionally
people also
mostly they hug low earth orbit
cannot
bear
to leave the mother planet so it would
seem
but 12 of them
go as far as the earth's natural
satellite the moon
this is an extraordinary event it is
an historic event
it is the first
tentative stepping out
into a vast cosmic
environment
and in the long historical perspective
provided we're not so foolish is to
destroy ourselves i think these events
will be
as significant as
when our ancestors
came down from the trees
about 10 million years ago
and when our still more distant
ancestors
crawled up on the land
about 500 million years ago we are
entering
a new environment
far
faster and more promising
than the savannahs of east africa
or
the previously untenanted land
so in the broad picture i think that's
that's the large scale significance of
space
but
on the other hand there are
all sorts of shorter term issues
and i would like to
address
some of the practical benefits
of the space by practical i don't just
mean
making money
but also issues having to do with the
human spirit the human heart
and necessarily political issues
first let me say
that
i
endorse lyndon johnson's assessment
that military reconnaissance satellites
by themselves
justify the entire cost of the space
program and i would say
that that is true for the soviet union
as well as for the united states
reconnaissance and treaty verification
satellites are
essential
they
calm the hotheads and paranoids on both
sides
who otherwise
would be making
prudent worst-case judgments
which
then drives the arms race
and especially as we are entering into a
remarkable new
era apparently
of
significant perhaps even massive
arms reductions
such
satellites are even more important
on the non-military side
it is clear that communication
satellites for example are a
a
self-supporting
extremely profitable extremely useful
industry
if you uh
never mind in the united states suppose
you live on an island republic like
indonesia
where there are
thousands of separate items
separate islands
the laying of submarine cables from
island to island
is vastly expensive
if you have a geosynchronous
communication satellite sitting above
your nation you can talk from island to
island
at much less cost much higher efficiency
the world is now
bound up
via communication satellites
and this has not just a
practical utility for businessmen and
emigrates
but
also a long-term
practical consequence of binding up the
world of breaking down the barriers
between peoples
of uh bringing us all together
something extremely important in fact
desperately needed
the
the availability of direct long-distance
dialing to and from the soviet union i
think is a
very useful
um figure of merit
about the degree of openness
in soviet society it was tried
experimentally for a few months and some
years ago pre gorbachev
and
then
dropped for reasons we might speculate
on
i
i think a
very
important
gesture on part of the soviet government
would be to uh to open up the soviet
telephone system both ways
to world communications traffic
meteorological satellites
are
extremely practical these days were
quite used to
looking at the evening television news
and seeing
a
picture from a geosynchronous satellite
showing clouds moving
somehow
not continuously
and
in the practical value of
of alerting farmers about
disastrous storms and
temperature decreases
these are again extremely cost effective
and there are some other things along
these lines we might uh we might mention
but uh i think this is a
a comprehensive enough list on the
very straightforward practical side to
see
that
space flight is an extremely important
aspect
of modern life
beyond this there is the scientific and
exploratory function
of
of the space programs of many nations
if you step back and just think about it
it's astonishing
that
real money has been spent
by governments
on
astronomy from space on sending
spacecraft
to
other worlds
a lot of money has been spent on that
there's no practical immediate practical
benefit i will
try to indicate a little later that
the
slightly longer term practical benefits
are very significant
but basically this was supported
in order to encourage the increase of
knowledge
and i think uh
the space-faring nations should be
commended for that the united states the
soviet union isa japan
and
fractionally a few others
i'd like now to
turn more specifically to the
nasa program
and
start
with what i think is the the key the
fundament
of the history of nasa
and that is the apollo program
nasa was started uh
before apollo just a little bit before
apollo
it was
formed in part as a response to uh the
successful
soviet
launch of sputnik one
but the
the
formulation of the apollo program
was a specific response
to the orbital flight of yuri gagarin
the first human to orbit the earth
and
this was not just a propaganda battle
the orbital flight of yuri gagarin
indicated a very significant soviet
booster capability lift capability
and must be understood
in the context of the strategic nuclear
confrontation between the united states
and the soviet union
the
flight of gagarin and hermann titoff and
their successors
in precise orbits their successful
recovery
clearly indicated
that the soviet union had
a capability to deliver
nuclear weapons halfway across the
planet
by strategic missiles
and
this was considered to be very worrisome
in the united states not just for the
obvious point that the united states
could be annihilated
the soviet union could also be
annihilated at that time by a uh
much larger u.s bomber force
but also because of the sense of
diminished american self-confidence
and concern about american allies
looking eastward
the apollo program must be understood in
that in that context and you can see it
in president kennedy's uh
famous speech
announcing the apollo program
he did not uh advocate
a
return of a sample from mara
tranquilitatis
he did not
advocate
determining the origin of the moon by
the end of the decade
there was no science whatever
in
his announcement what he said is that
the program would put an american on the
moon by the end of the decade and
and return him safely
president kennedy science adviser jerome
wiesner had a
a deal
with president kennedy
that if the president did not describe
apollo
as
scientific
wiesner would support it
and uh that is with a couple of
exceptions what uh
what happened
apollo was a political program
another way to see that
is
to look at the last
apollo mission apollo 17
which flew i think in 1974.
on apollo 17
the second guy to climb down the ladder
was the last man
the last human to set foot on the moon
he was also the first scientist to set
foot
on the moon
jack schmidt former u.s senator from new
mexico
as soon as a scientist set foot on the
moon it was clear that the program had
gone too far
and it was promptly
promptly cancelled as redundant
apollo was not
a scientific program
i think it's very important to remember
that programs of that magnitude
are driven
by political not scientific reasons
and that is even more true today
when
there's
a lot less spare cash around
than there was in the early 60s
nevertheless
under the apollo aegis
a great golden age of scientific space
exploration
occurred
and i don't know if this is going to
work
i hate to
ask for the planetary society's flag to
be removed but i would like to show a
few slides
i also would appreciate if the lights
could go down thanks
oh maybe it's going to work
well
what i hope to describe to you
is the
timing
of the major missions of the u.s
planetary program
uh
good the lights now seem to be in good
shape now all we need
this is a well-known mass-produced
highly reliable kodak technology
can we do anything about the backstage
light
i'm just trying to think of something to
do
thank you
okay now i really have run out of small
talk
oh that's good that'll take me a minute
pose an intellectual test for the
speaker
uh that's terrific but uh that's not the
slide
i could have the one before that please
ah great thank you very much
um
okay this does slip slightly off the
edge but uh
why don't we have the left-hand margin
and let the right-hand margin fend for
itself thanks
okay so these are
the decades of the us space program 60s
70s 80s
and
here you can see in yellow
the
mariner
missions marina 2 to venus first
spacecraft to orbit
another planet
the uh
the mission which gave
what i consider the definitive first
evidence that the high radio temperature
was coming from the
surface of venus and that
led to confirmation that it was a
massive greenhouse effect
mariner 4 first spacecraft
to
mars
uh
five to venus six and seven to mars
nine the first spacecraft to orbit mars
ten
to venus and to mercury
here in white are the
robotic precursors
to the apollo missions
the rangers lunar orbiters and surveyors
and then here
are the apollos
uh apollo 11
first
space first spacecraft to carry humans
to another world
uh through
apollo 17
in 1973 not 74.
moving target
also we can see pioneer 10 and 11
appropriately named spacecraft the first
to
leave the inner solar system and fly by
jupiter and saturn
the phenomenally successful
viking spacecraft two orbiters two
landers first spacecraft to successfully
land on mars
the voyager spacecraft which are still
functioning
and very well
uh that have given our first given us
our first close-up reconnaissance of
jupiter saturn uranus and shortly
neptune and their rings and their
satellite systems
some 40 worlds
more 45
have been explored by
voyagers and then pioneers 12 and 13 to
to venus first american
spacecraft to
land on venus
now this is a
spectacular record of accomplishment
for a tiny fraction
of the nasa budget as you'll see
shortly
except for the apollo's police cost a
lot the rest of it
costs very little
and uh that is a reminder to us that
other things being equal
uh
robotic spacecraft cost tens of times
less
than a comparable manned mission
well we see this
this big cluster of spacecraft here
and here all done under the aegis of the
apollo program
uh
a few
that come after
viking voyagers pioneer 12 and 13. next
slide please
before you go to the next slide i beg
your pardon can we go back
uh okay um
the arrow of time is unidirectional
you probably noticed that the decade of
the 1980s
did not have a single multi-colored
triangle in it
we have now finished
an entire decade in which the united
states has not launched a single
spacecraft
to the moon
or the planets
ten years
after this golden age of planetary
exploration ten years without a single
spacecraft being launched this is not
just due it's not primarily due to the
challenger
tragedy because it began long before
united states
has opted out
of planetary exploration here is the
the study approval and launch dates of
the three spacecraft missions that
followed
apollo 17
and you can see
that the approval dates for viking and
voyager were still
in the midst of the apollo missions
and pioneer venus just after
so
while we could uh
argue that the uh
the
fascination with
sdi has devoted some has deflected some
intellectual
fiscal
and presidential
presidential uh attention resources
away from the civilian space program i
think the main reason that
this
decline in
planetary exploration has occurred it's
because apollo simply ceased
next slide
here is the
planetary exploration budget
in
percent of federal budget and uh
the highest number here is
0.25 percent so of course it's a tiny
fraction of that as a function of time
here's the big apollo peak
and here is a subsidiary peak due solely
to viking
and it has been at this constant low
level ever since and the next slide
now here are in constant i can't read
what year it is uh constant
1980-something dollars
as a function of fiscal year
1982 thanks
and
the total nasa budget is here in
vivid
pus or whatever this is
and uh
the ossa office of space science and
applications budget seen here in orange
multiplied by a factor of 10.
so we can do the comparison this is the
viking bump and notice how closely the
space science curve tracks the total
nasa funding curve
so
i think a
a realistic case can be made
that the
grand exploratory emissions go up
when the total nasa budget goes up and
down when the total nasa budget goes
down or put another way
that a
grand long-term
objective that involves exploration
is the umbrella or aegis under which
these other missions can be accomplished
can i have the lights please
overhead lights i mean
thank you
so now
nasa is in a
rather different circumstance
it has just emerged from
the
challenger
disaster
i think it is
not unfair to say
that
at least significant segments of nasa
have been in a discouraged
mood
distracted
uncoordinated
in some cases incoherent
american space program has been on hold
the
great exploratory ventures
out into the universe have
virtually ceased
and it is
a very
important question to ask
what could be done to resuscitate
nasa
nasa has not had a coherent goal
since the end
of the apollo program
and it certainly has not had
a
long-term goal deriving from
a coherent statement of presidential
interest
since the end
of the apollo program
and therefore nasa has been left to
design its own justification
and whenever any bureaucracy
is left to do that
it does what all bureaucracies do it
attempts to preserve the jobs of
everybody who's
employed at that particular moment and
you get a very
interesting
pastiche
of unrelated
programs
i would like now to address the issue of
what
the american space program
should do
what should a coherent long-term
goal embracing presidential interest
be about
i think i should say just a couple of
words on on sdi if i don't
you will see a glaring hole in my
presentation needless to say what i
what i am about to say about sdi as the
rest of my talk represents only my own
views
does not represent george washington
university or the planetary
society or
any other organization
i
i think the original
population defense formulation of sdi
is a
tragic
ruinously expensive
mistake
and one if
if actually converted
into hardware would significantly
decrease the national security of the
united states
i'm
prepared to defend that i've done it on
a number of occasions
debated in three public forums with
general abramson i recognize that's not
the uh
the function of this
of this discussion but uh just wanted
you to know where i stood
let's now return to the civilian space
program
and
and talk about what the
overarching kind of goals should be i
see
two principles such goals
they are
neatly
compatible
they
and they have a number of other
connections as well
the first one i want to talk about
is
something that's been very nicely
described as mission
to planet earth
that is
a study of the earth from space
from the same
global perspective
as these other planetary missions have
done
for
other planets
and
this has a great head of steam in our in
our discussions in the last two days
while there were difference of opinion
on a lot of issues i didn't hear a
single
[Music]
negative remark about that
kind of goal
for nasa and there's a very good reason
for it
and that is
that
as the human population has grown as our
technological
capabilities have
have also grown
we have
amazingly come to the point
where we are able
to make significant changes in the
global the physical environment of our
planet
globally
worldwide
by accident
there are a number of these
number of cases of these and let me just
briefly mention
three of them
the
the increasing greenhouse effect
the depletion of the ozone layer
and nuclear winter just say a word about
each of them
first of all because the first two
can be addressed in a very important way
by such
such a mission to planet earth
and
secondly
because i believe there's a very neat
connection
between
the discovery of those
global
dangers
and the exploration of other planets i
want to
put in the plug for that
connection so i'd like to now show a few
of the slides i borrowed these from
professor dutton i'd like to thank him
for lending me those slides
first has to do
with the greenhouse effect
uh wait let me let me say something
generally first i'm sorry to be
so hard on whoever is controlling the
light
could i have lights back on again
if you
if you imagine the earth sitting at its
distance from the sun
with the present cloud cover therefore
reflectivity or albedo
you can calculate what the surface
temperature are to be
so much sunlight hits the earth
it's a certain distance from the sun you
know what the solar constant is you know
what fraction is absorbed you can then
calculate it's done in astronomy 101 all
over the world
what the surface temperature ought to be
when you do that the surface temperature
calculates out to be
30 centigrade degrees colder than it
actually is
and in fact the calculation
if it were true
would speak of an earth in which the
surface temperature is far below the
freezing point and we'd all be dead
what's wrong with the calculation
what's wrong with the calculation is the
greenhouse effect the calculation
neglects the fact that there is a
blanket of air infrared absorbing but
transparent in the visible part of the
spectrum
which surrounds our planet
and that
infrared
absorbing blanket
permits the visible light through to
heat up the surface but absorbs the
sunlight absorbs the infrared radiation
as the surface tries to radiate back to
space that is called the greenhouse
effect
in an inept analogy with what happens in
a florist's greenhouse which isn't this
at all
and
we owe our lives to the greenhouse
effect a little greenhouse effect is a
good thing on the other hand i mentioned
before
that the planet venus
has a
surface temperature of some 750 kelvin
900 fahrenheit about
and that is due to a massive carbon
dioxide greenhouse effect nobody by the
way proposes that
there were a bunch of beings on venus
who
who
went too much into the automotive
industry
and
that's uh that's the reason
uh but venus is a very important object
lesson in case anybody thought well
nothing to worry about greenhouse
effects there is a very good case now if
i may have the next slide and thank you
so here is a
set of observations made from 1958
to
almost the present a ground-based
observing station in hawaii you can see
the annual
variation in carbon dioxide having to do
the seasonal
taking up of co2 by plants but the net
trend
is very clear and monotonic increase in
the co2 abundance
and the same is true and even steeper
with the abundance of methane another
greenhouse gas
the increase in these molecules means
that there is
an increasing greenhouse effect which
ought to result in an increasing
average global surface temperature next
slide
here we can see
the increase in the world's population
from 1850 to
the present
and it's been a absolutely spectacular
exponential growth
in the earth's population
and
the carbon dioxide increase parallels
the industrial growth of the earth next
slide
here is
a set of measurements of the global
average surface temperature
and
this comes about not because anybody was
in earth orbit examining the whole earth
but by putting together with appropriate
weighting
the measurements from various ground
stations a much less reliable method
nevertheless
there is a trend which seems to be quite
clear
according to
james hansen of
nasa's goddard institute of space
sciences in new york
the decade of the 1980s has already had
the three
three hottest years in the last 150 and
if the trends continue
he says 1990 will be on global average
the hottest year in the last 120 000
years
that's something worth paying attention
to
next slide
is just a
neat graphic reminder of the mechanism
of the greenhouse effect which i talked
about before
the
infrared active gases
they don't sit in a layer up there
they're distributed through the
troposphere
visible light through
they absorb infrared radiation heat the
surface of the earth so what what's a
few degrees increase in temperature
nobody can do reliable prognostications
of the local weather
from this cause
but
there are a number of models both the
general circulation models and analogies
with paleo climates in which the carbon
dioxide abundance was higher
and
while these models cannot be believed in
regional detail
something like what they say
is
very probable some of the models for
example predict
a
well all of them do something like a
three to five degree centigrade
temperature increase
by the middle of the next century
which is enough in some models to
convert the american midwest into
something approaching scrub desert
the melting of glacial and polar ice
is
raising sea level so that
a few feet rise can be anticipated in
this period of time and
if the trends continue sometime
in the
century after we may have the collapse
of the west antarctic ice sheet
and the inundation of
every coastal city on the planet
this is serious stuff
next slide
is a schematic
about the
ozonosphere depletion
the uh
a bunch of chemists in the 1930s are
given the job of designing a
perfectly
inert
safe material to act as a refrigerant
in refrigerators and for other functions
they come up with them
it's given the dupont brand name of
freons
specifically designed to be free
nobody figured
that their very inertness would save
them from chemistry near the surface of
the earth
so that when they reach the ozone layer
they would interact with a highly highly
chemically reactive
ozone
begin depleting the ozone layer
increasing the flux of ultraviolet light
through the ozone layer its
thickness if brought to standard
temperature and pressure is only a few
millimeters
and an increase in
ultraviolet light at the surface of the
earth
is uh
dangerous in many different respects
increasing skin cancer
for for whites only by the way
uh but there's a fair number of whites
on the planet
and uh
but that's not nearly as serious as uh
the effect of sub-lethal doses of
of highly sublethal doses of ultraviolet
light
compromising the immune system
and the propagating consequences of
killing
um
one-celled plants that are at the base
of a vast food pyramid at the top of
which sit we
lights please
this is another extremely serious
environmental hazard
produced by human activity
that we've only recently discovered
overhead lights please
and then the third which i just want to
spend a moment on is nuclear winter the
discovery 38 years after the
invention of nuclear weapons
that
the
explosion of nuclear weapons over
and put a different way even a small
nuclear war
can through the burning
of cities produce a global climatic
catastrophe
of
considerably more than 10 degrees
centigrade
temperature decline
over
the northern hemisphere and i should say
that uh
all the recent models of nuclear winter
have converged on the same
answer
now
it would be foolish
for us us inhabitants of the earth also
us americans
to ignore
these very clear signs
that the global environment on which we
depend is in danger
it's essential for us to understand
the nature of the danger
to figure out what we can do to
ameliorate or prevent
and beyond that to try to seek out and
diffuse those other environmental
dangers that we are so far
we so far have been
too ignorant
to detect
there must be others that we haven't
figured out yet
and that's one of the places where the
convergence between planetary
exploration and
and uh
the earth comes because
take a look at the uh
at the greenhouse problem i've already
said the value of venus in convincing
skeptics that there really is a
greenhouse uh
problem
uh but beyond that i'd like to call
attention to the training
of some of the scientists who've played
key roles
in uh in these discoveries
the
one of the most important
uh models of the greenhouse warming is
uh due to jim hansen and his colleagues
at the goddard institute of space
sciences in new york
i've already alluded to some of their
work
that's already a connection but the
connection goes much deeper
where did dr hansen
develop his interest and expertise on
greenhouse effects
his doctoral thesis
was an attempt
to disprove
the greenhouse effect is the source of
the high surface temperature of venus
he cut his teeth on a planetary global
greenhouse problem and then
applied it
to the earth
take the uh the ozonos for your
depletion problem this was done
by uh
roland and molina
at uh
university of california irvine by the
way
this wasn't done by the environmental
protection agency protecting us
it wasn't done by the department of
defense defending us
it was done by two
ivory tower
scientists
at the university of california irvine
and is a uh an important reminder
of why the nation should spend money on
basic research
uh
roland and molina used a
a
absolute reaction rate kinetics scheme
to figure out what the result would be
of the chlorofluorocarbons
in the ozonosphere to do that you need
to know reaction rate constants they
have to be measured in various
laboratories if you look at those
reaction rates you discover that a
significant number of the
reaction rates used
were derived
from
laboratory work supported by nasa why
did nasa support it
not because of interest
in the earth
but because there are
halogen compounds in the atmosphere of
venus
so by this
surprising indirect route
nasa played
an important role
in the discovery of the danger to the
earth's ozonosphere the second group
that confirmed
the role in molina findings was a group
under
mike mcelroy at harvard
that a whole computer program set up
ready to go so they could check roland
molina as soon as they heard of it why
did they have that program all set up
and ready to go because they were
working on the photochemistry of the
atmosphere of venus
it's relevant to the earth to study
venus
by the way mars which has no ozone
or no significant ozone permits the full
flux of ultraviolet light to reach the
surface of the planet and this may very
well have something to do with the fact
that in the surface layers to which we
have
so far dug
there is not only not a hint of life
but you can't find a single organic
molecule
that region is being fried by
ultraviolet light
and then
the final case nuclear winter
there were five of us who did the first
calculations of
the nature and magnitude
of
of this consequence of nuclear war
three of us were full-time planetary
scientists two of us uh
spent some fraction
of our careers in planetary science the
computer used was an asset computer it
was a very clear
connection
and the connections go much further our
first interest in
what the global climatic consequences of
putting a haze of fine particles up in
the atmosphere would be
came from work connected with the
mariner 9 mission to mars so
there are two things that come out of
this
these remarks the first
that
nasa
but the government in general
needs to devote a very serious program
of earth satellites to monitoring the
global environment looking for
items that change
and
prescribing solutions and secondly
that planetary exploration i'm talking
robotic vehicles
uh needs to be supported
for this reason alone if we didn't have
an ounce of adventuresome spirit in us
it's
you know didn't care about
the
adventure of exploration
for purely practical
everyday
reasons
it makes sense to explore the planets
now i want to
to go to uh
my last topic
which is
the other aspect
of what i believe
the us space program ought to focus on
there is nothing
in robotic exploration of the planets
in great astronomical observatories in
earth orbit
in
instruments in earth orbit monitoring
the health of our global environment
that requires people
it is much more cost effective and in
some cases much more reliable
to use robots than humans
nevertheless nasa is strongly oriented
towards uh
manned
and woman
space flight
and
as all ongoing bureaucracies it probably
needs a reason to continue flying people
i don't think that in itself is a
justification for doing it
but i think there is
a reason
and i think it's a very powerful reason
it is the complement the obverse
of the apollo program
the united states and the soviet union
have now fully demonstrated everybody on
earth that they are capable of
obliterating each other and most
of the human species as well no further
demonstration is needed no politically
driven space race makes any more sense
uh especially in this
recent
astonishing
gorbachevian period
what is needed though
is for the two nations that have
booby-trapped the planet with nearly
sixty thousand nuclear weapons
to demonstrate
that on a long-term basis they can work
together in high technology for the
benefit of the human species there are
many ways in which they
ought to do that
but the one that
has a practical basis
has
precedent
in the apollo soyuz mission
and has the uh
the very
real advantage
that the head of the soviet union
has repeatedly called for it
is
joint u.s soviet man and woman
exploration of mars
and
that's what i would like to spend my
remaining few minutes on
i believe that
a long-term goal of this sort
in which the two countries at first
gingerly with
proper concern for technology transfer
and
the possible unreliability of the other
partner
test out
a new relationship
in all the
preparatory space science needed
for
sending humans
to mars
i think as confidence grows
the
effect would be
very significant
there is in the psychological literature
a range of studies showing
that if you
well let me mention the classic
experiment
which was done in the 1940s
by
muzaffar sharif
in which
healthy well-adjusted
adolescent and sub-adolescent boys were
brought to a summer camp
divided into two groups
the eagles and the rattlers i think they
decided to call themselves
everything was very friendly they then
started playing
competitive games two sides against each
other
and there then got to be
lots of
dissension
um
i'd like to mention a
quote just a couple of sentences from
there
the tournament started in a spirit of
good sportsmanship but as it progressed
good feelings soon evaporated
the members of each group began to call
their rivals stinkers sneaks cheaters
they refused to do anything more have
anything more to do with individuals in
the opposing
group
secret hordes of green apples were piled
up
the rattlers seized the eagle's flag
one group deposed its leader because he
was insufficiently
aggressive um
and attempts by the counselors to
reconcile
were unavailing
then
there was introduced a set of common
problems which could only be solved
collectively
fixing the water main and others less
significant
in the course of dealing with common
problems
that affected both groups
the hostilities vanished
and to
quote the summary the possibilities for
achieving harmony are greatly enhanced
when groups are brought together work
towards common ends
then favorable information about a
disliked group
is seen in the new light and leaders are
in a position to take bolder steps
towards cooperation
the same
point was made by sigmund freud
in his famous
1939 correspondence with albert einstein
published in the book called why war
freud
says the following
anything that creates emotional ties
between human beings must inevitably
counteract war
everything that leads to important
shared action creates such common
feelings
on them the structure of human society
in good measure
rests
under the aegis
of a
declared
mars goal
a great deal
would start falling into place in nasa
manned space flight long duration space
flight space station
big boosters
staging in earth orbit
solar physics because you have to worry
about uh
about solar flares on the way to mars
and of course robotic
exploration
of the planets
without such a superordinate goal
i maintain that a lot of that does not
make much sense and is likely to
be
poorly supported
in a time when there are so many
other urgent claims
on the available federal budget
now
the soviet union
is in rather good shape
for
sending
people to mars eventually
they hold by a large factor the
long-duration microgravity uh record
long-duration spaceflight
uh it's likely to be a year with the
current
mir crew
they have the energia
booster
which is uh apollo saturn v class the
united states
foolishly threw it away our own saturn
fives
they have a very ambitious mars robotic
program
and beyond that they have the
repeated clear
endorsement
by president gorbachev
in favor of a joint u.s soviet
human mission to mars
i think it's rather clear that
eventually the soviets will go with us
or without us i also think it's clear
that if the united states does not wish
to join the soviets
and as i'll say in a moment
if it does as well
that other nations
europe
japan
perhaps china perhaps india
will join them
it's not a question of
if we don't join it won't happen
it's a question of it's going to happen
the human species is on the time scale
of some decades going to go to mars
and
is united states going to be involved
i maintain that there is no good
justification for us spending badly
needed funds
on a human mission to mars other than
the political goal of international
cooperation with specific
attention to improving relations on a
long-term basis with the soviet union
various democratic candidates uh made
strong
appeals in this direction including to
the surprise of some jesse jackson
it is uh
in resounding language in the republican
party platform
i'll quote the sentence
we must commit to a manned flight to
mars around the year 2000 and to
continue exploration of the moon
i know that most
party
platforms with a quarter will get you a
cup of coffee
so i don't know what weight to give this
but i am told
that this is intended seriously
by
the republican party
in addition
there
are a number of other congressional
census of the congress
bills that will be reintroduced in the
next 101st
session
there is the mars declaration of the
planetary society in which a remarkably
ecumenical
group of american leaders
um has endorsed
such a goal
and uh
there are a number of opinion polls
which show that the bulk of the american
people would be in favor of such a goal
um
it is therefore i claim politically
feasible
and it would do wonders
for nasa
i think it is essential
that this
set of missions if it comes to pass be
done
not just bilaterally between the united
states and the soviet union but
multilaterally involving many other
nations
who have a great deal to contribute
financially in terms of
intellectual scientific ability
engineering and also to play a nice
moderating role between the
two
superpowers
it would clearly be step by step
we would be doing experiments in long
duration space flight in shielding and
staging and robotic exploration
as i said before testing each other out
finally
let me say
just a final word about mars i had
intended to show some slides of mars but
i've been yammering on too long so i
mars is a world of wonders
it is vastly more interesting than the
moon
i claim both in scientific terms and in
public uh
wisdom
it is a dynamic planet
with an atmosphere with seasonally
changing ice caps
with
the possibility
by no means certain
of past or present life
with
signs of past climatic change
which
are
is something we ought to
understand we who are pushing and
pulling with our own environment
or to understand how mars once had
running water abundant rivers
warmer temperatures and today
is in a deeper ice age environment
the surface area of mars equals the land
area of the earth
it will occupy us for a long time
mars delivers
it uh
it is not a boring place
there are enigmatic land forms there are
great volcanic eminences one of them
three times the height
of mount everest
a
remarkable
polar terrain
there's lots of terrific science geology
meteorology
seismometry possibly biology
uh keep scientists happy but i stress
you could do all of that with robots
the reason
for sending people there has to be
political
so in my mind's eye
i see
sometime in the next next century
one or more great interplanetary
transfer vehicles constructed in earth
orbit
daily if we want it before the eyes of
the world's television cameras on the
nightly news every night
cooperative construction by many nations
the completion of the spacecraft the
boarding
of the cruise the goodbye to earth
the long many month
journey
to mars
injection into mars orbit
landing site verification
deboosting from mars orbit
setting down
on the surface
of mars the first landing on another
planet by the human species
there are some who are worried about uh
which nation will first step on the
surface of mars
my solution is you
bind the ankles together of the
american and soviet commanders and have
them hop out on the 0.38 gravity world
they'll
gently settle down
and
nobody will be first
imagine
now what i think
would be hard to beat in capturing the
imagination of people all over the world
a roving vehicle
with americans and soviets and others in
it
wandering across the martian landscape
doing going
to the exotic terrains that we could
never land in in viking
wandering down one of those ancient
river valleys looking for stratification
in the banks
looking for the geological record
trying to understand
the changes
in
in the environment of that planet
and
all of that on the nightly news
every night
and then finally the long journey back
to earth
i maintain
that that could put
space exploration space activities
on the front burner
all over the world for a long period of
time in the political context of binding
up the wounds of the earth
i think it would be a wonderful thing if
the planet named after the god of war
could help to
increase the peacefulness of the
inhabitants of our small and vulnerable
world
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much carl we do have
about
five or ten minutes for questions if
there are any so
there are microphones in the aisles if
people
have some questions
are there questions
joe
this is a soft question
in addition to supporting international
cooperation at the level of going to
mars with the soviets are there other
lesser projects such as the
international space university and other
initiatives that you would support that
might build some bridges to the soviet
union and uh another possibility is some
small uh missions communication business
for health and medicine that's been
discussed with the soviets do you see
some possibilities at that level we
don't get the big big bucks absolutely
and
search and uh
and rescue um
satellites in uh in earth orbit
and uh
activities across the board i think it
is to the interest of both nations
within
reasonable technology transfer
constraints
to
to do as much of that as possible
soviets have
good scientists in a lot of areas and a
lot of areas they have
significant
space technology
experience they have large budgets
and it's very much in the interest of
everybody in this planet for the united
states and the soviet union to find a
range
of
important joint activities to do
dr sagan and you didn't mention in your
description of nasa activities over the
last two and a half decades
anywhere
what effect the space shuttle and the
resurgent that has had on it and i know
it's a
fairly controversial issue could you
just mention what your opinion is of
that effect and how the space shuttle
may be utilized or should possibly not
be utilized in further exploration and
development of space
thank you it's a as as you recognize a
long and painful issue
i think
the united states made a uh extremely
serious
error
civilian program
more foolish than the military program
in uh putting all its launch eggs in the
single shuttle
basket it means every time you want to
launch something you have to send people
up not just putting them at risk but
making the whole launch business
much more
expensive
it
makes competition and
waiting in line
for
for
the next available
shuttle
when
if there were
non-reusable launch vehicle fleets that
nasa had been using that wouldn't be be
the case and of course there's the
the challenger tragedy i think
uh the shuttle
is an example of a
capability without a mission without a
real unique mission that could not be
done otherwise i mean the usual
justifications are yes it's needed in
order to put people up into space but
why do you want to put people up into
space well
we want to uh study human physiology in
earth orbit but why do you want to study
human physiology in earth orbit
so we can have longer duration
spaceflight by humans why do you want to
have a longer duration space flight
by humans
and we never get a coherent answer the
kind of answers that one can hear
humans have capabilities that machines
don't have
and so when there's an unexpected
problem the humans can solve it and the
robots can't
and then
there'll be some pointing to let's say
the the sky lab sunscreen which
required an astronaut and a screwdriver
to first order
but if anything like
the amount of money spent on humans in
orbit could be spent on artificial
intelligence and
a new generation of robots you could
have screwdriver wielding robots in in
earth orbit or tele operator controlled
uh machinery in which the human operator
is on the ground and the
robot is in
is in orbit to do that sort of thing
i think
sending people up into space started out
as political
the political justification then
withered
but it remained a constituency it was
very powerful in both the united states
and the soviet union
uh with the
considerable
inertia
of its own
i as far as i can see
the only justification for the cost
both in money and in
the danger to human lives
of people in space
has to be political or if you wish to
think of it in those terms historical
but
if that's going to really
work we have to understand precisely
what is the
goal of those humans in space
and i might maintain that a goal like
the mars initiative
makes sense out of that otherwise
redundant capability
yes please
uh dr sagan the idea of a man mission to
mars is a very exciting one
it's one that
captures our imagination
but if such a project were undertaken
and successfully brought to conclusion
how would we avoid the crap we found
ourselves in when we had the whole world
excited about going to the moon
once we got there and we gathered a few
samples we looked around
public interest fades it's going to be
tremendously expensive and what's more
we could get missions to the moon pretty
quickly and back
we're talking about a substantial
period of time getting the margin
in fact how do we sustain uh the energy
and the funding and the resources uh for
something like that
thank you it's a very
important question and i should have
gotten to it in my talk
um
i think the fact that it takes
longer
to develop
the technology and infrastructure to go
to mars is an advantage
if you believe in the argument
that what we want is a long-term common
goal for many nations
if it's too easy if it's too near
if it's too quick
then we run into the problem
that you said if it's
15 to 25 years away
then i think it has the right reach
to
prod this
continuing collaborative
multinational
enterprise
it is sometimes said
and i should say there there are
proponents of going to the moon and not
to mars on on those grounds
um
there are proponents going to the moon
on the grounds that that the russians
are going to go to mars so we better go
somewhere else
which
uh makes no sense whatever
in my mind
you could just as well argue the
russians are going into space so we
should stay at home
it is sometimes argued that
well the moon is a good stepping stone
to mars it's a good place to
practice out
mars roving capability or
or
staging or other things you want to do
on mars but i point out that low earth
orbit and the surface of the earth
are much better in much safer ways
places
to check that out
it's also sometimes objected that the
the mars goal
is doesn't work because it's going to be
a stunt as you sort of suggested we'll
go there once or twice and then it'll
end
like like apollo but
i point out
that the reason the apollo program ended
is because the united states
demonstrated its
extremely formidable
rocket capability in fact
the saturn v boosters far in excess of
the military boosters that
can reliably deliver nuclear weapons
halfway around the world
so you reach a point where you've
demonstrated you can annihilate
the other nation and then you don't have
to demonstrate that anymore
but you do not reach a point where
you've demonstrated you can cooperate so
you don't have to cooperate anymore
and so i maintained that in terms of
political goal
mars has continuance
which apollo did not have
beyond that
mars is so vastly more interesting in a
scientific and adventuresome and
exploratory sense than the moon that uh
i think we land on mars once or twice
and we will find so many
fascinating things that
mars will help us to continue
i want to take one more time okay
i think perhaps dr sagan you're being
too modest because even with in your
proposals
the i think a political objective is
only one objective but as
we think about what we're doing to the
planet here and perhaps uh in the long
run irretrievably irreversibly we really
have to find other places to live
for the human species and uh mars
probably isn't very habitable at least
not from a practical point of view nor
is anyplace else in the solar system
so we have to find some other solar
systems and go there now that's a much
longer objective
and it probably is an objective of
hundreds of years rather than decades
conceivably it's in unachievable
although i rather doubt it i uh my own
feeling is that it is achievable
and uh
that's a long-term objective for the
whole species right you could call it
political or social or whatever
what it is a coordinated and cogent
long-term objective and mars is uh
conspicuously the next step for it
thank you um
permit me to
disagree a little bit um
the earth is not a disposable planet
it's not uh
if once we mess it up then we'll we'll
go somewhere else there is as you
properly point out no other
habitat for the human species in the
solar system
the uh
the excess of births over deaths on the
earth every day is about two hundred
thousand
we are not within hailing distance of
the lift capability to put two hundred
thousand people every day even in low
earth orbit much less to mars or some
other
some other place
uh space flight is not the answer
to uh
solving the demographic problem
and
it's not the answer to
to
solving the environmental problem
if i thought things were that critical i
would say we should
simply spend our money in making the
earth a better place uh and i think
that's a good idea in in in any case but
as i've tried to indicate
uh i think there are ways in which going
to mars makes the earth a better place
in terms of the relationships of the
various quarrelsome nation states
and also observing the earth from earth
orbit
permits us to
gain a perspective and understanding of
our deteriorating environment which is
essential so we all
can survive and prosper on the planet
thank you
thank you carl
let me uh
[Applause]
let me ask our panelists to move forward
as i introduce their chairman
the idea now is to spend the remaining
time both communicating to you in in
short form uh the kind of things we've
been talking about in in our smaller
workshop and then hopefully engage you
in in in some give and take uh with the
members of the panel
on
on
the insights and conclusions that we
didn't reach that you think should be in
part of a deliberation
so can i ask all the panel to come
forward as i do this is doing things in
real time
uh and this is the sort of thing those
of you that are in the space business
will recognize as draconic
i have not warned any of these people
but we have no overhead projector
and so you can't use view graphs
uh
and we're not set up just the way the
panel is to show slides because you're
in front of the
screen uh so you got to depend on
rhetoric
um
there's enough rhetoric on these six
gentlemen i think to
suffice though the chairman of the panel
bruce murray professor of planetary
sciences at the california institute of
technology and vice president of the
planetary society
from 1976 to 1982 bruce was director of
the jet propulsion laboratory
before that an active participant before
during and since an active participant
in planetary exploration dr murray floor
is yours
thank you john and
it's um
a good feeling to be
trying to focus on the issue of
international cooperation in space
and do so in washington dc which plays a
central
role although they're not the
necessarily dominant role in that regard
and to focus on the title of this panel
is on the prospects of international
cooperation the point we we spent two
days talking about different facets of
this in a
a group that had both international and
u.s representatives
um
what we're we have here a collection of
people who are going to give some little
snapshots of parts of that discussion
and perhaps give the flavor of it and
discuss it and the way him and we'll
have some time for questions afterwards
but i will do it as a introduction to
this is in
my own way try to summarize
the what i thought were the key issues
that were sort of cross-cutting not
saying so-and-so talked about this
problem or that but rather what seemed
to be generic what was kind of flowing
out of it
and amy had an audience concerned with
international cooperation or at least
international relationships and policy
issues that that's been the focus this
is not despite carl's enthusiasm in mind
and most of us for space in its own
right the thing it brings together is
space as a part of an international set
of relationships and so that's really
the focus here
the
a key i mean certainly a key part from
the u.s point of view of the civil
program and nasa
is the fact that nasa started out as an
instrument of national policy the apollo
program as carl described and we all
know
was a
key uh element in u.s soviet competition
that period of time and
most would feel a brilliant response to
a set of circumstances presented
themselves
when that job was completed in 1972
no subsequent national priority or
objectives were established for nasa
and so what's evolved in that period of
time is an agency and a set of
enthusiasts set of budget support and so
forth in congress and elsewhere that has
diverse goals without any
stated objective by the united states
government as to what it's supposed to
do lou allen made a comment in our
meeting which i thought was very very
much the point he says
nasa is not nearly as valuable to the
government as it used to be
and that's really underlies a lot of the
bureaucratic and administrative problems
that that emerge challenger just
exasperated these
um so that's that's a problem that's
going to be dealt with or will have
mediocre outcomes
the second
uh
circumstances especially with the
gorbachev change
which is not only
opening up and novel but a choosing
space
activity as an instrument of soviet
foreign policy and clearly with the obj
establishing u.s soviet collaboration as
a objective in its own right
and picking up western europe by default
at least from my point of view
we are not positioned well to respond to
that we don't have policy guidelines and
they're they're fabricated sort of on a
case-by-case basis so the u.s responds
very sluggishly and slowly and the
soviets have in an adversary sense the
initiative and maintain it so that we
have to decide and do something about
how do we cope there's a new thing there
whatever we decide independent of of
what the value judgments about how we do
it we ought to do it there isn't a
policy apparatus there's sort of an
incremental decision-making process
which is sluggish and cumbersome and
makes us look uh in from the u.s point
of view a bit foolish frankly in the
international scene we don't seem to
know where we're headed an exasperation
is that this creates a tension between
the traditional relationships we've had
with our western european allies and
we're developing with japan
and the soviets and again we're not real
clear at
a practical level how we cope with that
are we i've got a new set of friends
over there are these still adversaries
in a different way how do we do a a mars
mission if how does western europe fit
in
is that part of them or not so
and the people trying to do this are not
do not have policy guidelines or even
attitudes in there in the structure here
to help make those decisions and so
again we're not doing a very good job
that i think is factual
what we should do is a matter of
opinion
third it cuts a little thing is the role
the moon is a little uh
is is there an international role for
the moon or not if is it is it the
antarctic
explanation or not
a fourth um
issue that we spent a lot of time on and
carl's touched on it too
is i think everybody agrees this mission
to planet earth the use of space as well
as other national assets to understand
the changes in the earth's environment
and
lead into policy attitudes what to do
about it
that's great we want to do it there's
probably money for that and even in
restricted budgets
the problem again is that we're not
organized properly in that case there is
no agency that has that job
there are agencies that have pieces of
there's not a particularly they're
certainly in the past it's not been a
good mechanism for them to work together
and even more difficultly this is
intrinsically an international job
it doesn't do any good simply to observe
space the earth from space if one can't
get surface and atmospheric ground truth
through it and that in turn force you
deal with other countries even if we
didn't want to on political grounds on
technical grounds we would have to there
is certainly no easy mechanism for that
so we got two
structural weaknesses in our structure
to deal with this
and then finally
looking further ahead there are some of
the the speakers uh
he
gave the uh
common view now that both europe and
japan's economies are growing so large
that in the world that we're going into
we're not going to be the dominant
player we're going to be a major player
but not the dominant we have to learn
how to do that but more importantly we
have to learn how to persuade the
japanese and the europeans to make
larger resource contributions to these
global projects
and that that's a leadership job by us
it's not something we can do ourselves
and again that that's a longer range
goal it's an immediate task but it's
something we need to be thinking about
for the future
well that was my list of of crosscutting
issues let me introduce the panel and
then turn this over to our first speaker
at the end of which we'll uh permit some
questions from the floor depending on
how our time is running
the um
i'll just go from left to right
dr harlan smith who's director of the
mcdonald observatory
cooperated with dr hans mark who's a
chancellor of the university of texas
and a former head of now a deputy head
of nasa in sector of the air force who
talked about the moon as a policy
objective for the
the united states man moon missions
the
um
roger bonnay is the director of
scientific programs for the european
space agency has been very active in
trying to get international
collaboration both to come and halley
and other things and has played a very
important role emphasizing the role of
europe as well as the rest of
the world in this bilateral changing
into multilateral space environment that
we're living in
important and
we appreciate very much his efforts in
coming here
the
next person dr john dutton who is the
dean of earth and mineral sciences
pennsylvania state university
is
an advocate for mission to planet earth
he doesn't really have to advocate
everybody's kind of agreed and he uh but
did a good job of doing that and he will
be our first speaker when we start
talking
dr john mclucas
is
currently chairman of the national
advisory council has
former secretary of the air force a
uh former key person at comsat
corporation has a very broad experience
in all elements of space activities and
is uh
been a strong advocate for the
international space activities
and then finally
from canada of the ministry of
state for science and technology
dr evans is uh
represents another country rajeh
represents aggregation countries in
western europe and esa
evans represents a country that has
worked both in the united states and
with canada
and
and with europe and of course is
involved in our
shuttle and space station programs as a
major player so that i think that's a
valuable perspective in its own right
we're going to then start out with dr
dutton
on the
whatever he wants to say
the priorities are set today in this
instance
not by the urgency of planet earth but
by the urgency of my flying schedule
but
it gives me an opportunity to say a few
things about earth science global change
you might reflect
in your own education
whether or not anybody talk to you about
the future
of planet earth
we've talked a lot about the past it's
it's a traditional part
of education secondary school
high school
in
college curricula
but it's not until the last few years
that we have started to be seriously
concerned
about the future of this planet
i think it's not that the future is in
doubt the planet certainly has a future
the point is
that it's going to be different
the world is changing
it's changing before our very eyes
and most importantly
this planet is evolving toward
conditions
never before experienced
in human history
it's moving toward this new unfamiliar
and perhaps inhospitable state
because of us
as a result of human activities
the changes are significant they're
occurring today
dr sagan did a very nice job of
explaining to you the elements of the
global warming that's coming from
greenhouse
phenomenon
carbon dioxide
largely a product of the use of fossil
fuels
and the problems with the ozone layer
i see a lot of you out there
experiencing the ozone problem you're
all hiding from the
ultraviolet light
so what do we do
well from a scientific standpoint first
of all we document the extent of global
change we determine the rate at which
it's occurring
we determine what the local
manifestations
of global change are
this requires a commitment to
observation a commitment to maintaining
records
the commitment to processing those
records
first of all it's a commitment to using
the data that is available today
we have a great deal of information
about the earth
but in our wisdom
or perhaps our bureaucratic inefficiency
we have tended to place most of that
data in right only memories
we could use it
second of all
we need to observe
the state of the earth the evolution
we need to study the interaction between
the atmosphere the oceans
the biosphere and the ice regimes of the
earth
and a good way to do that
as well is with what's been called
mission to planet earth
mission to planet earth involves
four or more
polar orbiting platforms
present plans are for two of those to be
built by the united states one by the
european space agency
one by japan
there's no reason that the soviet union
or for that matter other countries could
not contribute
polar orbiting satellites to take the
detailed snapshot of the earth that we
need
the other part of mission to planet or
another part of the mission to planet
earth
would be geosynchronous satellites the
kind that produce the weather pictures
that dr sagan mentioned
they're in orbit over the equator they
are looking constantly at the earth
finally there are a number of research
missions
designed to measure a variety of things
on the earth we have a stream of them in
the united states the european space
agency has some in mind japan is
planning some some of those will be
cooperative we need to continue with
them
given this database
we need to create computer models
of the evolution of the planet which are
similar in spirit to the computer models
that are used today to make weather
forecasts that are often remarkably
accurate at four to five days in the
future
with such models we can make attempt to
predict
what is going to happen to the
statistical state of the earth
some
decades perhaps centuries ahead
and with those predictions we can assess
the various alternatives in energy use
and energy sources that we might be
interested in trying
this clearly is an international
endeavor
mission to planet earth
you could say is a mission with a crew
of some four billion people
it's a global problem
it's a global study
and it requires a global solution
scientists the world over are concerned
about the earth the atmosphere the ocean
the biology and the ice we need all of
them and we need their talents to bring
this to successful
to make successful progress
these scientists are cooperating now in
a variety of studies
the world climate research program the
international geosphere biosphere
program
and of course they set
precedent for much of this with the
international geophysical year
some thirty years ago
they're talking about cooperating with
the international space year
in nineteen ninety two
and finally these space programs
do involve all of the earth and there's
no reason that they shouldn't involve
and that we shouldn't take advantage of
all of the space faring nations
and finally and maybe it's not the most
important reason at all
is that it's going to be expensive
enough that we should share costs
well nothing is as powerful as an idea
whose time has come
global change is here
the need for
the peoples of the earth to respond to
it
is upon us
we need to understand it
we need to predict it
and we may need to change
our own behavior and i think all of this
is indeed an idea whose time has come
thank you mr chairman
[Applause]
uh next speaker will be um harlan smith
and picking up on i guess the moon
dr mark regrets that he can't be with us
today he's over at the pentagon in fact
and i feel a bit like the the boy
replacing the 900 pound gorilla because
not only has he had the jobs that were
mentioned of being secretary of the air
force and social administrator of nasa
but he's also chancellor of my
university
but anyway uh hanson i see more or less
eye-to-eye on these issues and in fact
i've had probably good many more years
to think about the particular one i'm
going to stress today so maybe it isn't
totally inappropriate that i have this
chance to be with you
carl has asked and several have asked
already in the short time we've been
with you why the moon
i think there's a completely different
class of answer that carl did not touch
on that one of the questioners did
and it goes something like this
there are two possible
radically different scenarios for the
human race one is to stay on the earth
as long as the human race shall last and
that's a possible scenario
i think it's a pre-copernican one in the
sense that you know there was a time
when the earth was the only material
body in the universe
but i really believe that that in fact
is not the plausible or the probable
scenario assuming civilization lasts
in addition to robotic exploration i
quite agree with carl that's the way to
do most of the exploration
in addition to that i think there's no
slightest question that the human race
is going to migrate out into space
now the time scale is not simple the
costs are not small there will be loss
of life but i mean what in human
endeavors
in history have not involved high cost
high cost not only in you know expenses
but in human life
not that i advocate that but i think
that the human race is a pioneering
species which is on its way
ultimately perhaps the stars although
that's more difficult than any but
astronomers know that's many many many
centuries downstream should it happen at
all
but to the rest of the solar system
especially the inner part to some degree
an increasing degree as time goes on i
am very confident that's the case carl's
at liberty to disagree others may but
i'm stating my basic position
okay if the human race is moving out to
space how does one do it
the first step is
to be able to get into orbit well we
learned how to do that and then as carl
pointed out we destroyed it we actually
wrecked the machinery broke up the
machinery that built the saturn rockets
i think in 1974 it's an
astonishing thing
but anyway the russians have it and we
are recovering it so we have ways of
getting into space and even the shuttle
bad as it is in some ways is not
entirely a wrong-headed thing in my
estimation it's the first attempt to
build a vehicle that can fly into orbit
and fly back now it's a primitive
beginning
it's sort of not even a ford tri-motor
but you know you have to start somewhere
and back in the 20s and the teens we
didn't have boeing 747s either the
shuttle i think is an evolutionary
development that i personally do not
think the country need to regret except
that at the same time we threw away our
auxiliary
launch capability as well which was the
great mistake
alright so we start out being able to
get into orbit what do we do next we
build a space station most of you know
the russians already have a very
competent space station and we're
marching along behind we will probably
have one in 96 or seven
then where do you go next
now here is the crux of the question
do we then decide that we shall make the
leap to mars just like that
or shall we go next to the moon
i contend we should go to the moon next
not that i disagree that mars should be
a
goal immediately beyond that i
absolutely firmly believe mars should be
the subsequent goal and it in turn not
only for its exciting
science and history but also as a
further springboard for the human race
ultimately to move out and develop
resources of the solar system
i mentioned resources of the solar
system one very brief detour here
what are those resources fundamentally
there are three
there's effectively an infinite amount
of energy there in the form of solar
energy to be tapped in the free space
environment
and there's there's more energy than
can describe i've sometimes spent 20 or
30 minutes trying to get that one
concept across to a class the
indescribable amount of energy that is
pouring out from the sun large amounts
of which ultimately can be trapped and
made use of energy is the ability to do
work
if you can do the work you can do almost
anything else
there's virtually an infinite amount of
material out there now it's not always
an easy forms to work with with energy
you can work with it and finally there's
an awful lot of space and i think given
those three things energy materials and
space the development of the solar
system will in fact continue and the
reason for having people out there
supplemented in fact heavily using
robots
is precisely the development of space
now the moon is the next place to go i
contend on that route
but
is
it only for future development in fact
this point of development scarcely
appeared at all in our discussions in
the last two days
and it's you might say my idiosyncratic
point of view all i want to believe in
quite firmly
but i think also there are reasons
intrinsic why we should go to the moon
which are in several categories that dr
mark spoke of earlier today in fact
these include the
fact that we really can learn a lot it's
not absolutely essential to use the moon
as a way station to mars but i contend
that in so doing we will make the
martian expeditions a lot more feasible
successful and probably not even delay
them an enormous amount beyond trying to
do it in one fell swoop
also
if we wish to set up really continuous
shuttling to mars which i think is the
only thing that makes real sense because
you have to remember that if one talks
of human exploration of mars
these poor astronauts or
martian knots are going to land
somewhere on mars their job is to
survive for a few months before they get
in the spacecraft and get back they're
not going to be able to traverse
hundreds or thousands of miles and
explore all the wildly exotic terrain
they'll examine a local area which
already may be fairly well known or the
site wouldn't even been picked
by robots for that landing
ultimately when human beings can truly
deeply explore mars it's going to be an
immensely exciting place but in the
beginning for a long time to come it's
going to be a spot check and the science
will be limited
but the point is we'll do more martian
work we'll have an infrastructure in
place if we have the moon well developed
and if in particular the moon as seems
now can surely be done becomes the
source of the primary fuel oxygen for
the really large scale
interplanetary voyages of the future now
all that's background the foreground
that i particularly come to it from the
point of view of an astronomer is what
can you do on the surface of the moon
the answer is science a number of very
interesting kinds of science we don't
have time to go into i'll mention just
the one i'm especially driven by
astronomy
the moon is the place in the solar
system from which to do most of the best
astronomy of the future
now that's another long story i've spent
a whole lot of times talking this
subject alone no time to go into details
but briefly the moon offers you a an
atmosphereless place which nevertheless
is solid you can put down very low cost
telescopes large numbers of them you
operate them remotely from the earth
if repair is needed you have your little
lunar base people in effect wander out
and make the repair immediate proximity
to cryogens power repair and so on
it turns out that astronomy from the
moon should be a great deal less
expensive if you don't require the
astronomers to pay all the cost of
setting up the lunar base now that's
quite an if and it involves all these
other things but once the lunar base is
going astronomy should piggyback with
great success with extraordinary
developments especially in terms of what
we call interferometry where we get not
merely the present one or fraction of a
second of arc resolution on the sky that
we get from the ground
but one hundredth one thousandth even in
time a millionth of a second of arc
resolution on celestial objects
and telescopes of enormous size great
complexity essentially free uh low
temperature conditions for thermal
ir one can go on and on with the virtues
of the moon it's a great place which to
do astronomy
now very finally
the moon also offers as far as space is
concerned leading place i believe for
early international cooperation after we
indeed get going on this absolutely
essential mission to planet earth
because within reason when we get the
freighter lines going to the moon and i
do visualize them starting within 12 or
15 years
it will be possible for many nations
just as we do in antarctica to set up
their own little base but in
collaboration with others
and i sincerely believe that we'll have
an international observatory with a
large number of astronomical instruments
which are operated
uh both individually by countries much
the way the european southern
observatory has individual telescopes
from denmark or france or what have you
but all part of a complex and sharing
with each other only this will be truly
international and we will cut our teeth
there and then we will make the trip to
mars successfully carl i want to go to
[Applause]
thank you for a very uh i think cogent
lucid uh presentation of the idea of the
value of the moon
uh roger do you want to take over and
bring us back to earth
western europe impact
thank you boys
as the
non-american
participant in this workshop together
with other colleagues from canada and
from germany and france
i would like to say that it was for us a
great opportunity to participate in this
workshop and i would like to thank the
policy institute and the planetary
society for having invited us and
participated in this debate
i was invited because i represented the
european space agency which is uh as you
may not know but i
say it again here
an agency which puts together the
efforts in a coordinated way of certain
nations in western europe
and we have also canada as an associate
member
and as such we cooperate with the united
states and with soviet union also but we
also collaborate with other parts of the
world china and
india
it is uh to also to say that there are
other space agencies in europe
in france in germany in italy and in
england
it would be
dishonest not to say that uh some very
often sometimes during this workshop
the europeans and the non-americans felt
a little bit left aside in these
discussions
which mostly focused on the by the
dipole soviet union usa
and
we had some delicate moments to find our
place in this discussion
and in fact it's true that it's not an
easy matter and it's true also it's fair
to say that dealing with a
new partner
we who shows
of openness
perestroika or glasnost
our two words which are very popular
these days
needs a learning learning period and of
course this was a key element in our
discussions
but it's true also to say that space
exploration
has ceased today to be the affairs of
only a few countries or a few
organizations but is a worldwide
activity and an essential
motor of knowledge
uh in science but uh not only in science
also in politics and in international
relationship
so the question is no longer today uh
whether or with whom to cooperate but
rather how and
the example of soviet union was a good
a good
example during these discussions because
very few people didn't did not know how
to handle this this situation
we also have to deal with
making today lasting commitments
in a world which is changing every every
day if not every minute
the example again of soviet union is a
clear example of that
two years ago who would have guessed
what happens today and who knows what
will happen
in two years time so this
evolution is an essential element to
take into account when we deal
with long-term commitments
which probably dictates that we have to
work prudently but not necessarily
taking a negative approach to that
but ussr is not the only place where
things are moving 1992 will mark the
500th
anniversary of
the
discovery of
the
america by the europeans
but 1992 will be also a very important
date in europe this will be the time
when the borders between
the largest number of nations in western
europe will be opened
a real open market
and this is a changing element in the
world scene
it has it has been said that it creates
a new superpower i hope it is the case
uh it will be at least a triple
but we also see japan coming up at the
horizon and this is also an essential
element in the world scene so these
elements have to be taken into account
when we deal with international
cooperation on such big ventures
as a mission to
the moon or even more emission to mars
there are two ways to cooperate
internationally
one which is
simple
and the most cost efficient probably and
also the most scientifically rewarding
but probably the less politically
interesting is the coordination of
missions already existing in each nation
or in each agencies
whereby you add a lot to the science you
get out of these missions by uh
putting them together in a coordinated
way rather than taking the science of
each individual one and adding them
together individually
so as i said this is a low risk approach
scientifically rewarding but
not necessarily the best approach
politically the other one which consists
in defining a common goal and going
achieving this goal together
is of course the one that we are talking
about when we discuss more
the mars mission or even the moon
mission this uh is much more risky and
needs
a
new means of cooperation new means of
working new methods it's very difficult
to accommodate this for example i
remember in july this year we had thanks
to the planetary society and
we organized with planetary society and
issa a workshop
to assess how the europeans could
participate in the mars mission
um we found ourselves completely stuck
in a discussion where the europeans and
the americans on the one side said well
you need to go into a phase a activity
and then you go into phase b and
phase cd and the russians looked and
opened their eyes and they didn't
understand what we were talking about
what is a phase a what is phase b what
is face city they told us we design our
mission uh at the same time we we think
about it and these two different
approaches long-term planning in a sense
and real-time activity on the other side
are sometimes not easy to reconcile but
if we are serious about
going together on these big missions and
tightly coordinating or cooperating
requires that we learn the methods of
each of each others
we have been as i said able to cooperate
on both sides with the americans and
with the soviets in europe with the
soviets i would like to recall that
we coordinated our missions to to
harley's comet two years ago and that
was a beautiful success thanks to the
international cooperation
the soviets leading the way to comet
halle and showing exactly where the
comet was so that the europeans
following a few days later could target
very precisely the nucleus of the comet
and shoot at it at 500 kilometers
of missing distance this was also
possible thanks to the uh
crucial help of the deep space network
of nasa
but we also cooperate extensively with
the americans in in europe we have many
missions that have been done in
cooperation the ulysses mission this
mission which goes above the plane of
the orbit of the earth and will fly
above the poles of the sun
we have we participate in the hubble
space telescope
certainly as minor partners but
our participation is crucial to the fate
of the space telescope since we supply
one focal plane instrument a crucial one
and also the power system of the space
telescope but we also coordinate and
cooperate in the field of solar
terrestrial science and we also
just recently
accepted in our program
a participation into a new mission which
is being discussed at this time in the
united states a mission to explore the
rings of saturn and to land a probe on
titan the europeans would land this
probe on the atmosphere on the
atmosphere of titan and land it on the
surface of titan incidentally the name
of this probe is called huygens
from the name of the european astronomer
who more than 300 years ago discovered
titan through the lengths of his
telescope
in this changing environment
where we see
this new power arriving coordination is
necessary we cannot
do that
randomly as i said we have to learn and
we have to find ways of
knowing better our partners
in
the mission to planet earth i think
myself
that there is here a great potential and
a great necessity to coordinate our
efforts for the benefit of mankind we
are really and carl has shown us the
danger of not controlling what we are
presently doing on our environment space
offers a unique way to have the global
view uh in order to cooper to to control
better this environment but here uh how
can we
think of such a cooperation without the
major
industrialized countries which are the
main outputs of all these hazardous
elements in the atmosphere the cfcs or
the carbon dioxide
here uh i see a great necessity to
improve on the ability to exchange data
especially between soviet union and the
rest of the world where they have a lot
of data and where they need the data
from the west so this
dual link is absolutely essential and is
missing but it's a delicate matter
because it needs to transfer data from
that part of the world to this other
part of the world and
you need
the networks or the necessary element to
do that for the moon i think it is
another dimension there we are going to
a place which we know already we have
explored it we have landed on it we have
put man on it
we have bought
examples of this soil
and we know how rich it is in certain
elements
so the moon's mission is more or less an
exploitation mission
we need to exploit the moon
scientifically speaking it's a very
challenging place to put astronomers or
telescopes at least it's also a place
where you can find
enormous richness in the soil
so it's more
like an exploitation base that we are
that we should think of
on the mars mission here i think
we are in the realm of exploration
still
it's not because we have landed the two
vikings and that was a beautiful mission
and at the russians we land a series of
robots in 1994 that uh we we should we
we should say that we know the planet we
don't know the planet we have to go to
many places on this planet which is a
very fascinating one and here again it
is impossible given the resources
involved that this is not done in a
coordinated way
i
think that
my own experience our own experience in
in europe to cooperate with soviet union
has been to go prudently but in a
positive gradient and i think we are
certainly encouraged by the very
positive attitude of the present soviet
leaders in this approach
and during the workshop we discussed
and i certainly did certainly
strongly endorse this concept
of
making a small step in this direction to
study jointly just studying not spending
a big amount of money not recharging
hardware but just study a mission
to mars together with the soviets the
japanese the europeans or whoever wants
to join
we have to find this this approach
with europeans cooperate on the space
station with the americans the japanese
and the canadian we also cooperate with
the soviets we have to accommodate this
uh these dual activities this dipole and
i think it is essential that we get
together the five uh main space agencies
mine space
five main space powers together to work
in the future i will stop here but i
would like to make a suggestion to carl
sagan
uh
he had a problem to identify who would
be the first one to put his foot on the
on the planet mars and he suggested that
uh we should
fasten the anchors of the american and
the soviet uh commandant commanders of
the mission
first you could take a bigger rope and
maybe fasten the ankle of the european
on board and if you don't find the big
europe then ask the european to step
down first
they have done that 500 years ago when
they discovered a new world
they could do it again
[Applause]
thank you
the united states has much to learn from
the experience of europe becoming a
federation of nations and certainly in
the space experience there's a lot of
directly applicable experience and ideas
and i hope that we're aggressive and
brazilian
dr john mclucas our next speaker
is now coming to the podium
and we'll provide you a different
perspective on international cooperation
well we were
told that we should talk about what came
out of our meetings of the last two days
i suspect that most of us came out with
the same biases we went in with but
perhaps reinforced
to some extent but i i did learn some
things
for example i learned that carl sagan
does not talk only about mars
he used quite a large fraction of his
time talking about mission to planet
earth
but
i passed out at this meeting uh
two articles that i had co-authored on
exploration of mars
and so none of us is following the
prescribed scenario
i've gotten quite a bit of criticism
from my friends who say you're supposed
to work mission to planet earth you're
not supposed to work mars
uh so i think it's just as well if we
diversify a bit
in carl's talk he mentioned the
practical aspects of space as well as
the political and the
visionary
and
one of the most practical examples of
course is uh communication satellites
uh although and and they're not only
practical but they're a big thing and
they've had a
dramatic effect on the way we see the
world see ourselves the way we
communicate
and in fact i think they've had very
far-reaching uh consequences political
as well as otherwise
some people say the military
reconnaissance satellites are the most
important
outcome of space activity
i won't debate that except to say that a
few people see the results of the
military reconnaissance satellites and
everyone has a television and therefore
knows what the communication satellites
do
well we all know that arthur clark is a
man who invented the
geosynchronous satellite which is used
for communications
and we know that he also uses frequently
the term a global village
although he's not the only one who uses
it
arthur has chosen to live in sri lanka
which is a paradise at least by his
definition
it has a good scuba diving and a mild
climate
and perhaps it was the only country
available at the time who was willing to
pass an act of parliament to give him a
tax break on all the royalties he was
earning in the united states
but in any case
he chose sri lanka
and he's become something of a hero
over there
but
sri lanka
is a sad example
of what can happen in paradise i happen
to be chairman of the arthur clark
foundation and one of my jobs is to pick
the annual speaker who will give the
arthur clark lecture in sri lanka
this year is the 25th anniversary of the
communications satellite in synchronous
orbit
seemed a logical time to pick harold
rosen
and he has written a speech which he
should give next week
in sri lanka
uh describing the invention of uh
communication satellite in the practical
sense arthur had done it on a
theoretical basis
and i have a copy of his speech
unfortunately he will not be able to
give it next week because the situation
in sri lanka has deteriorated
to the point where it's considered not a
smart idea to go over there
and so uh this is uh i point this out
for one simple reason the communication
satellite has brought people together
all over the world
continents are now in touch with each
other which could not be in touch before
at the same time it cannot solve the
simple problem of a civil war
created by ethnic differences
in an island which is only 30 miles
across
you would think you wouldn't have to go
into space to solve that problem and yet
it's bigger than what the satellite has
been able to do
well the reason i'm here talking i think
is because i'm involved with some
international activities and the first
one i will mention
has already been mentioned by joe pelton
the international space university
i think this is significant in two
senses
this university was created by three
young men in their twenties
they call themselves first the space
generation what does that mean it means
they were all born after we were engaged
in space flight
as they looked around for practical
things to do it occurred to them that an
international space university which
would bring people together
from many countries could play a key
role
in getting people to learn to work
together
and that those people who plan the space
missions of the future would have a
total international perspective
so they
persuaded some of us to act as their
board
and to help them sponsor this activity
and we just completed our first
successful season
we had 104 students from 30 countries
convened at mit
and
everyone involved has pronounced the
results a huge success i see several of
our board members in the audience
including our chairman ian price
the first year as i say was at mit next
year we'll go to strasbourg
i think carl also set the stage for this
mr sharif showed that people who
learn to cooperate and share joint
experiences will be able to do good
things together
and now the next international activity
i wanted to mention is the international
space year
this of course is the year 1992
one of my daughters said when she heard
i was working on the international space
year you know there's an interesting
coincidence that's going to be the 500th
anniversary of columbus's voyage
i said it's not a coincidence
anyway in 85 86 the international space
year legislation was put on the books
uh congress the president signed off
and
a year later we were able to conduct the
first international space year
association conference in hawaii
under nasa's sponsorship and there we
had
nations from all around the pacific plus
europe
planning together on what could be done
internationally
with regard to space exploration and we
had six different workshops
uh space science
planetary exploration
space transportation etc
but the one that that i was most
interested in was the
remote sensing group
and i propose there's something called
international landsat
i thought that landsat would be a much
better project if it were operated
on a basis comparable to intelsat
well there was a frenchman there named
pierre bescone
who said well that may be a good idea
but you can't jump from
where we are today to an international
landsat why don't we form a remote
sensing council
and one of its agenda items would be to
look into whether
international landsat is a good idea
i thought that was a terrific suggestion
so when we held our second conference
in new hampshire in april of this year
i again talked about the
remote sensing council
well we had another good frenchman there
uber curian was chairman of this
particular conference
and
he convened a session with the
various space agencies that were
represented there they were 17 by the
way
and he came out at a coffee break and he
said john
i'm having trouble selling the idea of a
council
he said
we've got to come up with another term
some people say council connotes too
much authority
i said i didn't realize it connoted any
authority at all he said well i'm having
trouble with the term
uh what would you think of the term
forum
and i said it sounds like a wonderful
term
uh so anyway out of there came the sac
space agency forum for the international
space year in these 17
space agency representatives agreed
that they would convene periodically and
share their activities
on remote sensing
or
if you want to call it mission to planet
earth uh and since that time we've had
two more meetings and the number 17 has
grown to 22.
so uh i think that is moving along
by the way one of the people at that
meeting was uh rual sagdayev who many of
you know
and i i frequently say that if sagneyoff
didn't exist he'd have to be invented
because he he's the precursor of gorby
gorbachev
he was following his own model for years
before gorbachev saw him in action and
decided you know there is a way to
operate
and to win brownie points by acting more
like you know ordinary people
uh
but uh when i saw uh saghday up there in
new hampshire uh he saw me he rushed
over and he threw his arms around me
and i was sort of taken aback i mean i
don't have russians grabbing on to me
every day
and so i said you know if my air force
friends see me here they'll probably
lose my clearance
uh anyway sagadev is uh
an interesting character and he always
has something interesting to say for
example we had lunch with him here
recently and he said it's not true
that we don't have personal computers in
the soviet union
he said we have fifty thousand
and one printer
anyway at this particular meeting his
comment was
you're trying to find a term that
doesn't connote too much authority
he said i've just been made a member of
the politburo why don't you call it the
pulit bureau
well i think if we're going to
talk about space activities at a time of
budget constraints
we have to show that space is a
practical uh kind of activity and that
means we have to draw up certain
priorities
at the same time i think we have to
recognize that one of the main reasons
for being in space
is a political because uh
we started the apollo program because of
political reasons
uh
i claim that one of the main reasons
we're doing the space station on an
international basis is political and
people talk about how you can save money
by going uh international
i think that's probably true although i
think it's also true
that it's much more
difficult to operate and international
management structure than it is one
based only in one country
so i think there's many offsetting
factors but the political factor
overrides i think
any of the other difficulties of a
management nature if you can pull it off
successfully because these people who
are working together are going to
develop common ties and
reasons to cooperate more in the future
i'd like to think that as carl has said
that the political significance of
cooperation that involves the soviet
union would transcend what we've done
with our friends in the international
space station
and that
there might come a time when we would
think
just as casually about cooperating with
any nation on earth as we do
in cooperating with our friends in
canada europe and japan today
the last subject i wanted to mention was
my role as chairman of the nasa advisory
council
in that role i get an opportunity to
give nasa advice which they may or may
not want
but recently i went to a meeting of the
international astronautical federation
in india
and this is um
let's face it india is a third world
country
the inter international astronautical
federation typically meets in an
advanced country a country with uh high
technology with mature space programs
and so forth
but india is the you might say the
example of how a third world country can
mount a space program which has very
practical
at first they had an experiment which
nasa helped them do to show that
communication satellites could be a good
educational tool
now they have insights in operation not
only is it good for education but it's a
huge money maker they've found that
everybody wants to put ads on their
television programs and not only that it
stimulated the new television production
industry over there but anyway that's
not what i'm supposedly talking about
uh
in the uh lead-off sessions of that
conference there were several speakers
talking about different things
uh but
one of them was bill ballhouse talking
about space exploration the other three
talked about how space could be used
for what i'll call down to earth
problems i see one of the speakers
sitting there who talked about an audio
broadcasting satellite
uh they could take programs all around
the world
but
the the three people talking about down
to earth problems which the third world
needs space to help solve it seem to me
sort of set the tone of that whole
conference so i came back
composed a letter to the nasa
administrator and said
mission to planet earth is the way we've
got to go on a priority basis it's
obvious that every third world country
every advanced country all of us need
what we can get by intensive exploration
of
the earth's parameters
and this has to be our priority mission
about six months ago i found myself
talking to a second grade class because
i had a grandson in the class and i
pulled out various models of spacecraft
airplanes and various gimmicks and the
thing that surprised me about this
exercise was they kept me there for two
hours
but although they learned something from
me i learned a hell of a lot from them
i found that these uh seven-year-old
kids
knew
a hundred times as much about space as i
did at the same age and that they were
ready anything you mentioned to them
about what kind of activity you wanted
to carry out
or any international cooperative venture
you might imagine they were ready to
talk about so i think we've got to get
up in step with our own kids
and let me close on a small example of
international cooperation
there's several of us in the room here
who had something to do with putting
together
a 10th anniversary celebration of the
apollo soyuz event
now there was a political event and it's
a good example of how
you can gain political
mileage out of international cooperation
many people thought the apollo soyuz
event
was
sort of a nothing happening
i was so small
what really happened a handshake in
space
and yet when we brought together a 600
people in the national academy
auditorium
to celebrate that event you could feel
the chemistry the
the
vibrations in that room
people saying you know this was a great
thing why don't we do more of this
and i was reminded of some of the
problems we had in pulling that off
for example uh relations with the
soviets were very upset at the time of
the 10th anniversary
because of poland afghanistan and a
lieutenant colonel had just been shot in
berlin and so forth
and when we called the nasa
administrator and said we'd like to put
on this demonstration i'm sorry this
celebration of the 10th anniversary and
we'd like to have you participate
he said i can't go near the place and he
recited all these problems that we were
having with the soviets
and he said besides if we tried to
cooperate on that
the white house would be all over us you
guys don't understand the problem
well fortunately i knew someone in the
white house who used to work for me
he was a colonel
and uh so i called him and said you know
i think a call from you to the white
house i'm sorry from the white house
through you is all that's needed to get
the nasa administrator to cooperate with
us
the colonel made the call we had the
celebration
and
as i say 600 people had a hell of a good
time celebrating international
cooperation
now i don't know
what which event leads to which next
event
i think
there's no way you'll ever know
but the soviets were impressed with the
fact that we were willing to take an
initiative at a time
when the relations were not ideal
and they sent people over all the
cosmonauts who participated in that
event were there with us
people had their arms around each other
and
the alexi leona and
tom stafford were on tv the next morning
together
they had their arms around each other
and i remember alexis last words he said
i would go anywhere with tom
the advantage of international
cooperation
i'll use my time
[Applause]
john deserves some extra time because i
neglected to mention he's been the
chairman of our whole conference so he
deserves a lot of credit for putting
this together
our last speaker
dr evans from canada is going to give us
the view from our close neighbor
as uh
i think both the view of the problem and
perhaps the view of ourselves in that
regard
well thank you very much bruce i'd like
to echo roger's sentiments that
uh certainly i and and the canadian
government are very pleased that we were
invited to participate in this
conference and we extend
our appreciation to the organizers for
having us come down
now we've heard a lot in the last day
and a half and today in today's
plenary session here
about some very high ideals in terms of
space cooperation and in terms of
international cooperation we have lots
of ideas
missions of planet earth a return to the
moon
and a voyage to mars
what i'd like to do in a very quick
wrap-up uh
from from my perspective is to try and
and bring us a bit down from some of
these high ideals and explain or at
least talk a wee bit about some of the
practical sides the practical problems
of in fact carrying off these very large
international cooperative programs
and what i'm going to give you is the
perspective from the small guy canada is
a small guy in the space business
to put us in perspective we spend about
we're about eighth in the world in terms
of our expenditures in space as a
percentage of our gnp
but nonetheless
we do feel that we have contributed to
our own
national
economic and social strength through the
use of space and also we believe that
we've been able to contribute to various
programs around the world
we do cooperate as roger mentioned as a
cooperative member of the european space
agency
we have cooperative programs with russia
with the united states of course
japan sweden and many other countries
and what i'm going to give you is a
perspective from somebody who's just
come from the front lines of negotiating
the space station
agreements
i was a co-chairman of the canadian side
responsible for
for our participation in the negotiation
of the intergovernmental agreement
and the memorandum of understanding
in my view the space station agreements
have forged a substantial new
ground and have set a new baseline
for international cooperation
i think we also have to appreciate how
long it took to do that
i can remember the first visit of james
bakes to canada with the invitation to
participate in space station and i
believe that took place sometime in
1984.
it was in 1988 near the end of 1988 that
we eventually signed the international
agreements that was four years of
intense
discussion negotiation
between friends and allies
and what i would like to caution about
is at least put on the
open for people to think about is when
you start involving
other nations with whom you have not had
such extensive and long-term cooperation
how long will it take to negotiate the
agreements for a trip to mars
what did space station agreements do
they negotiate they really set
new ground in terms of political
commitments
for the first time we have a
multilateral treaty between nations
with respect to an international
cooperative space venture
these uh international treaties have
established the very difficult
ground rules in terms of legal
cooperation the legal aspects of living
and working in space together
these documents have addressed the very
touchy issue of technology transfer
how can we have
all these nations working together to
build hardware which will exist together
and with foreign nationals from uh
for many nations working on the space
station using each other's equipment
but primarily i believe that what space
station has done is forge a new way in
which international programs will be
managed
and to some very large extent i believe
that the way in which this program is
implemented
over the next several years the success
or failure that we collectively the
united states canada europe and japan
the success that we collectively have
in actually making the space station
management process work
i think will have a significant
influence on the way in which
major future major international space
programs are undertaken
there were several lessons that we had
to learn as we went through the very
arduous and sometimes difficult process
of negotiating these agreements
one thing which is very clear
is that the space agencies around the
world
are not in control
of such major programs it is the
governments of the various countries
that are in control
i go back a long time in the space
program and i remember negotiating
agreements with nasa with esa
with japan
on projects which involve just the space
agencies of those of those countries
those are very simple agreements to
negotiate because the technical people
have exactly one common desire and that
is to produce the best piece of hardware
to meet a common set of objectives
when you move into the era of creating
international treaties
you bring in a whole baggage
of other concerns
and i think it's it's something that we
all have to bear in mind is that the
there has to be a very strong political
government will behind
these projects in order for them to work
another thing which was alluded to today
at lunch by james begs in his speech to
those of us who are privileged
privileged enough to be there
is a lesson i think that was also
learned in this process
and that is that the united states no
longer
can claim to be the leader in everything
in space
if we go back in the past 25 years that
was clearly
the case
however
in my mind there is a new order and as a
small player i think i can say this
there is a new order in the
international space arena
the european space agency has had
more than 10 years experience
in making 13 nations at the government
level cooperate
in international space programs
the european space agency
is going to double its space budget in
the next three years
japan is emerging space power
with goals of having its own
independent
manned space capability
all aware of the progress and the
prowess of russia and china
and i believe that this
this new playing field this more level
playing field is a fact of life
which in the
space station negotiations i think the
united states had some difficulty
realizing
the other important thing that we
realized that with this leveling of the
playing field with the oncoming of
strong players internationally in the
space business
technology transfer is a two-way street
that means that no longer is the us
concerned only about protecting its own
technology and its transfer
that the rest of the world has similar
concerns
and so there is now a new force a new
impetus i believe on the on the
international scene
to ensure
that we share our technology towards a
common purpose and that we do so in a
regime which meets the individual
objectives of the various countries
i think the prospects for international
cooperation are better as a result of
the fact that we have the space station
agreements in place
they are a forerunner
of what will be necessary for
a multilateral
manned mission to mars or multilateral
exploration and visit
our revisit to the moon
however i believe that space station
is a turning point in terms of these
international treaties and management
setups and organizations
and that
as we go forward
we'll find that there will be more equal
partnerships
and that we will find that
in some instances the united states will
take the lead in other instances other
nations will take the lead
i also believe
as we listen to
my i guess what i took away from this
conference
is
and i apply my space station experience
to
the concept of moon missions and mars
missions
that the time is now to start to plan
and work
with all the international partners
towards a common goal
it takes a long time to put these in
place
and if it takes four or five years for
friends and allies who've had a long
history of cooperation to put an
agreement of this nature in place it's
going to take much longer to bring in
the rest of the world's countries thank
you
[Applause]
well thank you very much for some very
fitting words
i think we do have some time for
questions what i'd suggest carl we got
an extra seat once you come on up and
let the provide a target here
and i guess the best way is for people
who have questions simply to
approach one of the microphones i'll try
to recognize you and necessarily repeat
the question
no speak a little louder i don't believe
that there's
a great deal of skepticism that given
enough money and the desire to do so
that we can technologically stage a
mission to mars
one of the concerns that was expressed
at a recent
conference of the american astronautical
society
is how
fit is man physiologically and
psychologically to undertake a mission
that will last anywhere from 18 months
to three years depending on how it's
staged
that is going to take a long time to
develop and demonstrate the human
technology to coexist
and to exist
in a small environment for a long period
of time an example that was made is that
when the russians come back from their
very extended missions in mars excuse me
in earth orbit
that they need physical assistance when
they depart the spacecraft because of
the condition of their physical
uh
state who's going to help the mars
visitors
uh we'll let carl respond to that
well there's no question that uh that
physiological issues have to be
addressed uh i remind you however that
uh
uh
soviets have already been in earth orbit
for
longer than some of the trip times to
mars
i spoke to one of the soviet cosmonauts
who had been up for many months and he
said when he landed he was able to walk
a thousand steps along the center line
on a highway
sort of an interesting image of him
emerging from the spacecraft and doing
this drunk driving test
and so
he was a physician
so it was his uh his contention that
this is not a serious problem if it is a
serious problem
then the alternative is to spin the
spacecraft up so you get uh
uh through
the centrifugal pseudo force
1g or 0.38 g or whatever you want you
want to do
but there's no question that you would
not commit people to such a mission
without a great deal of experience
in a simulated mars flight and that's
one of the many things that has to be
uh done that's why it takes time to to
do the preparation but there is no hint
of insuperable physiological
difficulties
before let me just add to that that
we've
talked a lot about the goal the
long-term goal of human flight to mars
or
the moon but especially mars
and discussing the political benefits
and so forth what we haven't talked
about and i think it tends to corrupt
the conversation a bit is that that's
not what people would be doing now
that's they wouldn't nobody's going to
run in in the wilderness scenario and
ask for a budget to go to mars
what would the net from now the end of
the century
realistically by any nation
is you've got to solve at least three
critical problems which can be solved
within current budgets and current
technologies and current programs
provide their focus
one of them is you have to know more
about mars that's robotic that's fairly
straightforward secondly you need to
know more about humans that was a
question mentioned here both
physiologically psychologically a lot of
subtle things you do that through space
flight as well but very carefully done
and thirdly you have to know about
reliable closed ecosystems which is
another thing this these spacecrafts
have got a lot of recycling and they've
got to work for years and that's a new
technology
those all can be done
nationally or they make very nice
candidates for binational or
multinational programs
they don't cost very much and they they
enable the human species to go sometime
in the next century to mars they also
provide the critical political
information as to whether these
countries really going to be able to
work together
and you do it in within technically
manageable and financially manageable
chunks and so i want to be sure that's
clear that we're that i don't think
anybody's advocating making a decision
to go now or to commit the kinds of
funds that are required but simply to
pick it as a goal and then do the
enabling things for the next decade
well i've used the chairman's
prerogative uh on this do you want to
add to it harlan just make one uh make
one additional comment anyone who's read
stories of the napoleonic wars period
for example knows of the incredible
conditions that men were crowded under
decks and ships that sometimes took the
better part of a year to go from
anywhere to anywhere
now admittedly they use the lash to keep
them in shape and maybe we should worry
about that for the space program of the
future but no seriously human beings are
immensely adaptable under difficult
conditions and these will be very
selected people under highly stimulating
conditions with all the resources the
human race can bring to bear i have no
doubt i agree with carl that the voyages
in that sense can be made there are
other hazards
when you identify when you begin to
speak if you wish you might identify
yourself
thank you dr murray my name is les doran
with final frontier magazine
i wonder if you could address a point
which i believe dr evans touched on
briefly
something on the scale of an
international mission to mars is a
decades-long undertaking costing
billions and billions of dollars
and i wonder if you gentlemen have any
thought on
how
an endeavor of that sort can be
insulated against change in the
political winds right now
of course we have the movement toward
perestroika and toward golosnist and the
soviet union but there's no guarantees
that that's going to continue for an
indefinite period and in the united
states there's no guarantees that
a future
american president will continue to
support the the outlays needed for such
an endeavor so is there any way to
insulate a joint mission tomorrow an
international mission to mars against
those changes in the political winds
who wants to answer
carl again
well i think this question of cause and
effect um i think
at least my my reason for supporting
uh such a goal
is
in order to produce a political help
produce a political climate
in which
the two nations have this shared common
purpose and
and uh do not have uncomfortable uh
changes of the sort you mentioned so i
don't think it's a question of
of first we
we magically
produce a global situation in which
neither nation has any chance of
defecting from the cooperative
relationship and then we establish the
joint mission i think instead we
establish the joint mission in part
to accomplish that improved relationship
between the two of the two countries and
of course there's some
risk of failure but the stakes are so
high i mean i remind you that the
the cost for each side of this mission
is roughly the same as a single
strategic weapon system and we have
plenty of those
uh it seems to me
worth doing
uh considering the importance of the
issues at stake quite apart from the
adventure and science of mars
exploration
the other aspect of this which
do for this audience ought to be
emphasized that in a program of this
type you would segment it in time that's
what i'm referring to there are
near-term milestones
like 10 years but nevertheless that's
the enabling technologies
and then if those milestones are met one
and prepared as a later decision to make
the commitment to go ahead and go
so you segment it in time and you also
segment it functionally and we've looked
there's been a lot of study of mars
river sample return by a group a nasa
sponsored group of this and a lot of the
attention given to how you do that it
turns out that if that's a criterion of
the structure of the program that's
rather straightforward and so the idea
of developing functionally separate and
compatible synergistic units but that
has standalone capability if one of them
fails or doesn't go so you can design i
think a lot can be done in program
design and in system design if it's
understood that's a requirement and
that's part of our learning process in
this new world we ain't going to be the
dominant one that sets the does the
system design sets the program goals and
then invites our
secondary allies so to speak to come
join us i think that was the message
that derives from the talk we've heard
from our
foreign participants here is that when
we're no longer the big gun
even with the soviets if it's the
egalitarian of the soviets or
multinational involving east and soviets
and other countries then we're going to
have to design programs differently and
i think that's possible we've got to
change our mindset to do it
just one one point that i was trying to
make is that
space station is a very large program a
very large multi-latin multinational
program
you have to realize that space station
in essence
changed the direction of the
very significantly the direction of the
program certainly in canada in europe
and japan they've all focused on space
station as a primary objective
this led uh
those international partners canada
europe and japan
to think in terms of an international
treaty as a way of buffing the program
from the whims of annual budgetary
processes
and
so we have tried that
approach in the space station program to
try and and use that to buffers from
those those problems
you want to
take the phone identify yourself my name
is ron griffin with the vitro
corporation the question i have is can
someone briefly describe the major
advantages
of deploying telescopes on the moon
for exploring the universe as opposed to
just putting them in space like the hst
thank you yes i'd like to speak to that
when you put a telescope in free orbit
you can do it if it's in near-earth
orbit you get into all kinds of
complications now let me mention a
couple first of all you're whizzing
around in only 90 minutes you're moving
it eight kilometers a second with
respect to the atmosphere you're
encountering ionized oxygen at a
ferocious rate the earth fills half your
field of view
you can get a dark sky exposure for
maybe 40 minutes at a time it takes an
hour or two to move the telescope from
one orientation to another in extreme
motion somewhat less for
closer ones you have to balance the
thing to the order of a thousandth of a
second of arc against gimbals incredibly
difficult expensive it is this is the
reason why space telescope costs one and
a half billion dollars even though it's
smaller than uh
my relatively modest 107 inch telescope
of mcdonald
now uh that's tough
we could put much bigger telescopes on
the moon for much less money if we only
had to pay the transportation costs to
the moon and had light weighted units
there that's one level of argument they
really will be cheaper provided the cost
of building a lunar base is amortized
against the human move into space and
does not charge against astronomy and i
agree the astronomy budget couldn't
carry it
now
that's only uh the most obvious example
let me mention another you'd like to do
what we call interferometry in space in
order to get high angular resolution
in principle you can do that by putting
remotely
floating vehicles in space and probably
some of those problems are soluble but
it's all going to be expensive to
maintain baselines orientations
constant naming of the telescopes the
source you want to study and so on in
principle it can be none but
staggeringly expensive on the moon if
you have a lunar base you go out and
plunk down your little telescopes
i'll mention just one more and then i'll
subside but again this is a long story i
have a long several long articles on
this
let me mention one more
if you wish to explore new domains of
frequency that have never been studied
before you normally find exciting new
astronomical results
there is a domain from roughly a few
hundred kilohertz in frequency up to
about 10 megahertz that is essentially
totally unknown it's a big the biggest
spectral window we know essentially
nothing about
it would be almost impossible to build
an effective system to observe this in
space and you can't do it from the
ground because the earth's ionosphere
blocks it on the surface of the moon it
would suffice to lay out little
elements really about the size of a
pencil in intervals of hundreds of
meters each of which has a little chip
solar battery a little transmitter to
send signals to a common computer for an
incredibly low cost you build an array
of tens of kilometers in size on the
moon and got an extraordinarily
effective radio telescope of a kind that
can be built nowhere else in the
universe these are just a very few
points
again a lucid answer and i can assure
you there's a lot more where that came
from so
what i'd like to do because of our time
situation is
uh acknowledge the two questioners are
at the microphone and that's where we're
going to cut off and hope that we the
panelists responses can be fairly brief
too
my question is
is there any ongoing programs or even
exploratory meetings on an international
scale or even national scale
and if there isn't the feasibility
of exploring new means of propulsion in
space beyond chemical propulsion so we
can take up greater masses at greater
efficiency and get greater distances and
quicker time
who's volunteers harlan do you want to
take i think that's yours
you're a jpo man well not recently um
as far as i know we we did a little bit
of work or there was a little bit of
agitation this back in the about 1980
and it turned up
matter antimatter
uh and it turned up uh exotic
sales with giant lasers and so forth
those are the two things the outcome of
those have been the giant sales became
the basis of a science fiction novel
by
bob forward and and technical papers
with freeman dyson
and the antimatter is something that you
watch because they take one antimatter
particle at a time in cern and they try
to keep it a magnetic bottle and they
put another one in and they put another
one
and if you want to extrapolate that way
it's a long in the future the answer is
that there as far as i know there is
nothing
in the time scale we're talking about
including going to mars and i and by the
way i include any kind of nuclear
rockets in that regard that competes
with existing chemical systems and
there's certainly no constituency to
develop them
beyond that you know science goes on
technology goes on it's it's hard to
know at what point some
you know radical change might take place
but there's certainly nothing that one
can foresee or that i foresee in that
time scale
specifically one
area
evidently new material processing our
developments has allowed the thinking of
solar electric propulsion and ion
generation just in the last couple of
years uh ted taylor who was behind the
orion project is very enthusiastic about
this potential i think the problem is
that you can't show that you can the
mission to propose to do you can also do
chemically the chemicals exist and that
therefore there's not an incentive to
launch a large development program
let me uh give our last i'm sorry we got
to sign off the last speaker here
go ahead you're
yeah
the name's kevin owens i'm just a member
of the planetary society
and one of the issues that has me
puzzled is we've discussed a lot about
international cooperation and the cost
the engineering and the systems to get
to mars and the moon
but there's a little discussion of uh
after we've gone there and come back is
what do we do next you know like uh is
there been thinking about homesteading
these places or
we find out what's there and then just
do like we did with the moon
and say well we found out what there was
to find out
um
i think the easiest answer is a national
commission space report which is widely
available deals with that
hope and aspiration and also some of the
difficulties and rather great extent uh
and
beyond there it's kind of voting your
conscience about the future i think that
but i think that report really is the
the best response to that
so
uh with that in mind i'd like to turn
the meeting back to the chairman here
and let you take over here
thank you bruce thank you rest of the
panel
god we're right on schedule it's
remarkable
we're done i think it's been a uh i hope
you found a useful afternoon i think the
retention of a significant portion of
the audience suggests that that you
found in our public discussions the same
kind of intellectual excitement and
challenge that we've been finding for
the past day and a half i thank you all
and
who knows when the next one of these
things will
happen here at the university but you'll
certainly know about it thank you
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
you've been watching a conference on
space exploration sponsored by george
washington university
be sure to join us later tonight for a
live viewer call-in program on the
recent soviet troop reduction proposals
with ambassador edward rowney coming up
at 6 30 pm eastern time 3 30 p.m pacific
live on c-span
and coming up in a moment a look at the
congressional budget process with
rudolph penner of the urban institute
[Music]
since the removal of manuel noriega
sunday beginning at noon eastern time 9
a.m pacific time
[Music]
coming up next carl sagan director of
planetary studies at cornell university
addresses the inter-parliamentary
conference on the global environment it
is the first u.s sponsored conference of
legislators to focus on the global
environment and includes representatives
of more than 40 nations
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the first u.s sponsored
inter-parliamentary conference on the
global environment
today
together this week we're making history
we begin a task of tremendous importance
with implications for this generation
and every generation to follow for our
children and our children's children
thank you for joining us here
thank you for your courage leadership
vision and your energy and for the
commitment your presence reflects
more than 42 nations from all parts of
the globe are represented here
many different voices with many
different concerns
will all be heard
during the next three days as we work
together
to find one voice with which we can all
speak out
to advocate the policies our global
environmental crisis demands
i would like to take just a moment to
recognize the host delegation from the
united states senate and ask that
members of the host delegation stand
first of all senator john chafee of
rhode island the ranking member of the
senate environment and public works
committee
senator chapin
senator john heinz a member of the
senate finance committee
of pennsylvania
[Applause]
senator john kerry of massachusetts a
member of the senate foreign relations
committee
senator tim worth of colorado a member
of the senate energy and natural
resources committee
two members of our host delegation
senator rudy boschwitz of minnesota and
senator max baucus of montana are unable
to be with us this evening with but will
be attending the conference sessions
later on
one of our vice chairs from the united
states house of representatives is here
congressman bill greene of new york of
the appropriations committee
i would also like to recognize walter j
stewart
secretary of the united states senate
[Applause]
now i would i take particular pleasure
and great honor in recognizing
some of the delegates who are also the
heads of parliamentary bodies in their
own countries
mr laurent fabius president of the
french national assembly
[Applause]
nelson carnero president of the senate
of brazil
[Applause]
marco antonio dardon president of the
congress of guatemala
[Applause]
lucien xavier michelle adrian naran in
jacques president of the national
assembly of madagascar
[Applause]
muttari musa president of the national
assembly of niger
[Applause]
during the next three days we will work
together in plenary sessions and in
smaller groups focused intensely on
seven different issues about which we
will hear a good deal more tomorrow we
will hear from scientists researchers
policymakers and even poets we will see
the first ever whole earth photograph
and the very latest in a special film
made from earth orbit about our earth
our goal will be to produce specific
legislative strategies for action
sensitive to our various concerns that
will mean real changes and real progress
the problem we are facing
is so difficult and unprecedented that
sometimes we must move beyond mere words
to poetry
and so we begin this evening with an
original poem
composed especially for this occasion
the first time he has composed a poem in
english the legendary poet of conscience
who is himself a parliamentarian from
the soviet union it is my pleasure to
introduce a wonderful friend and
parliamentarian evgeny yestershinko a
delegate to the soviet congress of
people's deputies
such a change of time when american
senator could inspire
a russian poet to write one poem
i'm sorry for my pronunciation
the last petals
dedicated to
my brother senator elgor who did
a lot of things for mother nature
the last
purple
but almost not palpable
pale
petals
probably the last child
revolving around the pedals
the slow
and creaking pedals
of probably the last
bicycle
the rusted smell
of probably the last roof
remind remains
in the transparent soul
of probably the last
ice cream
your lips my beloved
are like last
petals
on the dried up tree of life
mother earth looks like a widow
bleeding from her own
incredible children
night
we
live at the strange time
of the moral ottoman
last petals of conscience
last
pets
last polar bears pirates poets
less
political peacocks
less profits last prophets
last sweet peaty
of probably the last
babies
last peaceful pleasure to play with
puzzles last privilege
to have faces
without muscles
at the earth
day
at the funeral
of earth
at the day
of common
source
when nobody wants to die
first
i feel
like a lust petal
of a flower
not
yet
burned thank
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you
thank you so much for that original
composition which is so moving to us at
the start of our proceedings
before our keynote speaker
we must attend to several conference
formalities by addressing these matters
this evening it is my hope that we will
be able to begin
immediately tomorrow morning with the
formal proceedings of the conference
if there is no objection to proceeding
with these matters for the selection of
officers i turned the podium to
president laurent fabius of france
president fabius is an internationally
respected parliamentarian and president
of the french national assembly and
former prime minister mr fabius
we will
give the gavel
to you for these
conference formalities
mr fabios will be speaking tomorrow
morning as well to give us an
international greeting
[Applause]
thank you
i will speak english
pidgin english
and it will be very very quick very
short i move
that the
organizer and chairman of the host
delegation of this conference
senator
al gore
be named the chairman
and that we also name a group of white
chairman
to assist
the chairman in conducting his duties
that's all
is there any objection
to that difficult decision
seeing no objection
the chairman and the chairman are so
selected thank you very much
thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah
thank you very much we do have two other
procedural matters that it would be
helpful to address briefly this evening
we need to adopt the conference rules
and conference agenda which all of you
received and the package of materials
distributed at registration
these are fairly self-explanatory
and if there is no objection i would
propose that we adopt them is there
objection
hearing none the rules and the agenda
are adopted for those who are not
parliamentarians
and who have attended
other conferences
please understand that we
parliamentarians have to have rules
in order to proceed
finally i would ask that we appoint a
coordinating committee of the conference
who shall have the responsibility of
preparing each day's
working documents for consideration by
the conference at large i would suggest
that the coordinating committee consist
of the working group chairs and
co-chairs as will be determined by each
working group tomorrow and if there is
no objection we will so designate the
coordinating committee
thank you for attention to these matters
and now let me
introduce our honored speaker this
evening our keynote speech tonight comes
from an individual
who has helped us dream
and has helped us see what before we
could only imagine
carl sagan has inspired not one nation
or one people
but many nations and many peoples
the children of those of us here in this
room
know him on a first name basis
because he has taught them
so much through the magic of television
all over the world
carl sagan is a pulitzer prize winning
author whose television series has won
emmy awards and peabody awards
if i tried to share with you tonight
every award he has earned for his
outstanding contributions to our
understanding of the world he wouldn't
have much time left to speak
carl sagan has been a leader in the
mariner viking and voyager expeditions
to the planets
for which i might add he received the
nasa medal for exceptional scientific
achievement and many other international
and national awards
his scientific research has enhanced our
understanding of the greenhouse effect
on venus and here on earth dust storms
on mars the organic haze on titan the
origin of life and the search for life
elsewhere in the universe
he has most effectively sounded an alarm
that is being heard worldwide
alerting people to the global
environmental crisis before us
i am honored to know carl sagan to be
able to call him a friend and tonight to
introduce him to you carl sagan
[Applause]
thank you senator gore i'm
most happy to
be here
at this
gathering
of
members of the human community from all
over the world
you know we humans started out
in east africa
some hundreds of thousands of years ago
and
spread
all over
so that there's hardly a place on the
planet
that is not occupied by human beings
and in all that course of time
we've been divided
into
small communities
wandering tribes and only
lately in the last blink of an eyelash
compared to this great time scale
have
we begun coming together
again even knowing
about each other
so gathering like this is kind of a
gathering of the tribes
in which humans from all over the world
come together
to discuss common concerns
but this is not just any group of humans
it's a group of humans who have
actually a possibility
to make things better
i very much hope that you will
several people have asked me why
i as an astronomer
am involved
with
these issues and
there are many many different uh
schemes of causality that are
responsible but i want to just stress
one
i'm a
planetary scientist it's been my great
good fortune to participate
in
what is certainly never before occurred
in human history
the direct
exploration
of other worlds
by robots constructed
by our species
and so
for the last 25 years
i've
been lucky enough to
be involved
with the
design
and execution of missions to other
worlds in which a spacecraft
flies past or orbits or lands
on another planet
or one of the moons of another planet
those other worlds are
extraordinarily beautiful
highly instructive
as i'll mention later
there are
very important lessons
for our world
that we've gathered by studying other
worlds
one of my interests has been the search
for life
the possibility of living things
on those other worlds and before we look
no one is in a position to know
whether
life exists on many worlds in the solar
system
or on
just
one only
namely ours
well
we have now recently completed the
preliminary reconnaissance of the solar
system
our spacecraft
have now passed
beyond neptune and pluto the outermost
planets
we have
gone
past
the worlds in the solar system we have
four spacecraft heading out
into the space between the stars
of those dozens of other worlds
that we have examined
we have not found
any trace
of life elsewhere
in the case
of mars for example
where we landed two spacecraft and
examined the surface
for years
we found
not a mouse
not a blade of grass
not a microbe
not even an organic molecule
we have found the
stirrings and premonitions
of life elsewhere
organic molecules being synthesized
on worlds in the outer solar system
but no trace of life
and this
gives a certain
useful perspective i think
you can have dozens of worlds
that are
complex
rich
environmentally diverse
and have life
on only one of them
life is rare
it is therefore something
precious
and at the end of this long
set of voyages of exploration
i think it's very natural to turn
our sight home again
to recognize
that what we have here
is precious
and needs
to be cherished
if you look
at a picture of the earth from space or
if you talk
to astronauts and cosmonauts who have
been in space
one of the most striking aspects of the
view of the earth
from a few hundred kilometers up
is how
thin
the atmosphere is
there's just this
faint blue aura
that surrounds
the
earth it has a distinct appearance of
fragility
and it is fragile the thickness of the
atmosphere compared to the size of the
earth
is about the same as the thickness of a
coat of shellac
on a globe
of the earth in a schooling say
there's not
much air
or
consider the ozone layer
about which we are rightly concerned
if that entire layer were brought down
into this room the pressure and
temperature of this room
it would be about um
the thickness
of this pinpoint
that's all the ozone there is
to protect us
from the dangerous ultraviolet light of
the sun
when we humans started out
our numbers were very few
our technological powers were very
limited
the idea that we could affect the global
environment was absurd and the issue of
course was never raised
but now
our population
is immense
more than 5.1
000 million of us
our technological powers have become
vast even awesome
and now we pose a danger
to this
thin
and fragile atmosphere
not intentionally not because we intend
to do it harm who would want to harm
the life-supporting
environment
but simply because
our technology is powerful
there are many of us
and we are still not very good
at thinking ahead
at recognizing the future consequences
of present action
i will come in a little bit to
to talk about uh
at least one of these
environmental issues but
you are a group of parliamentarians
you must make decisions on policy you
must figure out
how to decide
which issues to devote how much
attention to
and
i'd like to talk a little bit about that
very grave and important question
human history has
faced this kind of issue before
and i want to
describe to you
two cases that come from
the classic western tradition
of ancient greece
what do policymakers do
when faced
with predictions
of catastrophe
the first story
actually both of them
have to do the greek god apollo
apollo was an olympian
god of the sun
but beyond being in charge of sunlight
apollo
was also in charge of prophecy that was
one of his specialties
all the olympian gods could see into the
future a little bit
but apollo
did this on an industrial scale
he established oracles all over the
classic world
uh the most famous of which was at
delphi
in greece
he uh
sanctified the priestess who was called
the pythia
and kings and aristocrats and
occasionally even ordinary people
came to this article to beg to know
what the future holds
among these
supplicants
was crisis
king of lydia
we remember him a little bit in the
phrase rich as creases
part of the reason he was so rich is
that he was one of the guys who invented
money
the first coins were
were minted in lydia
in his time lydia is in anatolia
contemporary turkey
as as happens to uh
rich people on occasion um his ambitions
could not be contained within a small
volume
and
so
according to the history of herodotus
he got it into his head that it would be
a good idea to invade persia
persia was the
superpower of the seventh century bc
the persian king cyrus had united the
persians and the medies into a very
powerful empire
so naturally creases had a little
reservation about going ahead and
invading
persia
so
naturally as anyone would at that time
he sent a
delegation of emissaries
to delphi
to
ask questions
and you can imagine them laden down with
the opulent gifts for the delphi after
to the the
oracle of delphi because
after all prophecy doesn't come free
um
and uh the question that his emissaries
put
was
what will happen if crisis makes war on
persia
without hesitation the pythia instantly
answered
he will destroy
a mighty
empire
the gods are with us crisis must have
thought
time to invade
so
he invaded and was humiliatingly
defeated
uh not only was
lydian power destroyed forever but he
himself
was destined to live out the rest of his
days as a kind of minor functionary
in the persian court
offering little pieces of advice to uh
often indifferent officials
a kind of hangar on x-king
well
time passed and the injustice of it
really got to him
after all he had played by the rules he
had
gone and asked the pithia he had paid
handsomely
and she had done him wrong
so he sent another emissary
this one on a
much more modest scale appropriate to
his diminished circumstances
and asked in effect how could you do
this to me
here's the answer as recorded in
herodotus's history
quote
the prophecy given by apollo ran
that if crisis made war on persia
he would destroy a mighty empire
now in the face of that the priestess
says
if he had been well advised
he should have sent and inquired again
whether it was his own empire
or that of cyrus that was spoken
but crisis did not understand what was
said
nor did he
question again
and so he has no one to blame but
himself closed quote
now if the delphic oracle is just a scam
to fleece credulous kings
then of course it would have needed
excuses to explain away the inevitable
errors in prophecy
disguised ambiguities
were its stock in trade
but
the lesson
of crisis is germane
to
the questions before us today
even of oracles we must ask
questions
intelligent questions
even when what we're being told tallies
with what we want to hear
the policy makers must not blindly
accept
they must understand
and since the prophecies that concern us
today involve scientific issues
the policy makers must educate
themselves on science
and this
advice it seems to me is fully
applicable to the modern
oracles who are the scientists and the
think tanks and the universities
the policy makers send sometimes
reluctantly to ask of these articles
and the answer comes back these days uh
often the articles
volunteer
prophecies even when no one's asked them
the first thing to do
is to understand
now i want to tell you another story
about apollo and oracles
this one is quite different
this is the story of cassandra
princess of troy
it begins just before the the greeks
under agamemnon invade
troy at the beginning of the trojan war
cassandra was the smartest and the most
beautiful of the daughters of king priam
and apollo constantly on the prowl for
attractive humans
fell in love with her
strangely this almost never happens in
greek myth
she resisted his advances
she said no
so
he tried to bribe her
but what could he give her
she was already a princess she was rich
she was beautiful she was happy
but apollo was very clever
he promised her the gift of prophecy
and that offer was
irresistible she agreed
quid pro quo
so apollo did whatever it is that gods
do to
make
seers and
oracles and profits out of mere mortals
but then scandalously
cassandra changed her mind
she said no again
apollo was not amused
but he couldn't withdraw the gift of
prophecy because after all
he was a god
and whatever else you might think of
them
gods
keep their promises
so instead he condemned her to a cruel
and ingenious fate
that no one would ever believe her
prophecies
what i'm recounting here is in
eschalis's play agamemnon
so cassandra predicts to her own people
the fall of troy
and nobody pays attention
she predicts the death of the leading
greek invader agamemnon
and
the greeks don't pay attention
she even predicts her own death
and nobody was the slightest been
interested
they didn't want to hear
they made fun of her
both greeks and trojans called her the
lady of many sorrows
today maybe they would dismiss her as a
prophet of doom and gloom
at the end of all this she says
i prophesied to my countrymen
all their disasters
but they ignored her
and they were destroyed and soon so is
she
that's the other
extreme
in the policy response to predictions of
disaster if we're faced with an ominous
prediction
involving powerful forces
that uh
may not be readily influenced or even
understood
we have a natural tendency to reject the
advice to put it off
to ignore the prophecy
dealing with the
danger
might take
time effort money courage
it's politically expensive it's
difficult
it might require that we change some
priorities in our lives
now
i don't for a moment want to suggest
that uh every prediction of disaster
made by scientists is true and there are
many cases in which scientists
like everybody else made mistakes
but there's a way
there is a error correcting mechanism
built into science it's part of the
ethos
of science
and
that's why there's a community that
argues and checks each other's
statements and yells and complains
that is a
healthy and vigorous
sign
nevertheless there's a tendency no
matter how well
supported
the prediction of disaster is to
be tempted to
put it aside
what's more
if the factors precipitating the
the problem
are long-standing then the prediction
itself is a kind of
rebuke
why have we permitted this peril to get
so far
shouldn't we have informed ourselves
about it earlier
don't we ourselves have complicity in
letting this come about
is now this is these are uncomfortable
ruminations that our own inattention or
inaction
might have put us and our loved ones in
danger and so there's a natural tendency
to reject the whole business
it'll need better evidence we say
there's a temptation to minimize it to
dismiss it to forget it
this is a very common and very human
response
psychiatrists have a name for it
it's called denial
to deny
the
danger
i don't know if if the following remark
is going to translate at all it'll uh
pose a real challenge to the translators
but there's a rock and roll group in
america called dire straits
and there's a line in one of their songs
that goes
denial
ain't just a river in egypt
now these stories of crisis and
cassandra represent the the two polls of
policy response to such predictions
crisis himself representing the poll of
credulous uncritical acceptance
propelled
in his case by greed and other character
flores
and the greek and trojan response to
cassandra
representing the poll of
solid you know immobile
rejection
of the possibility the job of the policy
maker is to steer a course
between these two souls
and i believe
that it's perfectly
possible to do that
and in the case of some of the problems
before us
the
seriousness of the issue is so well
established
that we cannot i believe
exercise denial anymore
there are a number of these global
problems
depletion of the protective ozone layer
is certainly one
but
considering
that
we are going to have a question period a
dialogue afterwards
i'm not going to take the time to
discuss that here
or
any of the other important issues that
you will be discussing at this meeting
save one
and that one
is greenhouse
warming
in a way
it's
the most serious it's the most difficult
it uh responding to it requires
the greatest
change
in how we think of the world
and so let me try and address that
but before i do i just want to point out
that we now have a precedent
that the nations can get together
and can agree on steps
even
expensive steps
to
mitigate or avoid
such a danger and i'm
referring to the
montreal protocol
in which
33 i think
nations have agreed to phase out the
production
of the ozone-destroying molecule
chlorofluorocarbon cfcs
despite the fact that it will be
expensive for the industries involved
and that is a demonstration
that the nations of the world can work
together
on these issues it's a sign
of optimism a reason for hope
now let me talk a little bit about
the greenhouse effect
i myself
got involved in the greenhouse effect as
senator goerth said
by studying it not on the earth
but on our nearest planetary neighbor
venus
where it is
vastly
larger in proportions
than it is here
the greenhouse effect is something like
this
imagine the earth sitting in space
and the sun let's imagine that that
that that
bright television light
is the sun
the amount of sunlight falling on the
earth
warms the earth
the warm earth
then radiates
back into space to cool itself off and
the temperature of the earth
one would think is determined by the
balance between the amount of sunlight
that is absorbed and the amount of
radiation that's radiated to space
if you do that calculation
we know how bright the sun is we know
how far away the earth is from the sun
we know how much sunlight is absorbed by
the earth
if you do that calculation
you would predict and it's done in
elementary astronomy and meteorology
courses you find the temperature of the
earth
would be
35 degrees centigrade cooler
than in in fact it is
something's wrong with the calculation
what's wrong is that we've forgotten
something
that the earth is not airless that there
is a thin
layer of atmosphere that surrounds the
earth
some of that atmosphere is in front of
us right here in this room
so uh
i can see
people in the back of the room i hope
people in the back of the room can see
me our eyes work in visible light
ordinary visible light the air except in
places like los angeles and mexico city
is transparent to ordinary visible light
on the other hand
in the infrared part of the spectrum
beyond
the color red
wavelengths longer than red
the atmosphere is not fully transparent
and at some wavelength some colors in
the infrared it's
opaque
and that means
that if we have lots of
infrared absorbing gases in the
atmosphere
they may not block the sunlight that's
coming in to warm the earth
but they will block
the infrared radiation that the earth
radiates back to space
and then the atmosphere acts as a kind
of blanket
warming the earth
some molecules in the air like oxygen
and nitrogen the most abundant ones
don't absorb
almost not at all in the infrared so
they are not greenhouse gases
but other molecules like water vapor or
carbon dioxide
or those cfcs i talked about a moment
ago
do absorb in the infrared and are
greenhouse gases
the more of those
gases
the more infrared absorption
the more blanket
and
everything else being equal
the more the temperature of the earth
should rise
there's no question
that since the industrial revolution
we have been pouring
co2 and other such gases carbon dioxide
co2 and other such gases into the
atmosphere
recently
because of the exponential growth of our
technology we've been pouring
many more of those gases into the
atmosphere including new
gases that were never known in nature
like cfcs
and
all the calculations show
that the temperature of the earth should
be increasing
we do not know
precisely by how much
there is not yet
perfect agreement
on these matters
but the bulk of the
calculations show
that temperature increases of a few
degrees centigrade and the average
temperature of the earth
should happen
sometime in the next century
now that doesn't sound like very much a
few degrees centigrade it's a few
degrees centigrade warmer in this room
with the lights on and
now the lights off
what's a few degrees centigrade
but an average
temperature increase in the average
temperature of the earth of a few
degrees centigrade has much greater
implications for local and regional
temperatures and i'll show you an
example of that
shortly some of these predictions
are very dire
they include
the
conversion
of crop growing regions into scrub
desert
including
the american
midwest at least almost scrub desert
they involve the rising of sea level
and the eventual inundation flooding
of coastal cities all over the planet
involve the destruction of natural
ecosystems
the spread of disease
the
obvious
likelihood of
conflicts over water rights
think of a place like bangladesh
much of which is already
nearly at sea level and there is not
the fiscal resources to build
dikes and levees as has been done in
holland which has a similar problem
it seems very clear
that
tens of millions of people
will find
their homeland underwater in bangladesh
alone
if some of these predictions are
fulfilled
there will be vast numbers of
environmental refugees you can see that
putting all of these issues together
we can foresee a very serious
set
of problems
that face all of us
there is essentially
no
winners
everybody all over the planet
is a loser
now i would like
to show a few
slides
i think it's just
10
and i promise to go through them quickly
this is very dangerous for an after
dinner speech
and i recognize i'm taking a risk
but i want to illustrate a few of the
items that i've been saying
and say them in a in another way
this
picture
is of the surface of the planet venus
taken by one of the
soviet union's venera series of
spacecraft
first spacecraft to land
on the surface of venus
venus is a
it's the nearest world it has the same
mass size density as the earth
you might figure it's very much like the
earth
but it has a massive atmosphere
90 times the pressure
of the atmosphere of the earth
and that atmosphere is made
primarily of carbon dioxide co2 which we
know to be a major greenhouse gas
the temperature
of the surface
is
i'm trying to do a calculation in my
head
it's uh about
470 degrees centigrade
about 900 degrees fahrenheit
it's hotter than the hottest household
oven
it's hot enough to melt tin
or lead
and this comes about
through a massive greenhouse effect
so
if anyone tells you
that there is a doubt about whether a
greenhouse effect exists or can be
serious
please
direct them
to the planet venus
now i'm not proposing that what's
happened on venus is that there were a
a race of venusians who drove
fuel inefficient autos and that's that's
how they got into this problem
this comes about as far as we know
without
the intervention of
supposedly intelligent life
but it is
a very important object lesson
next slide please
and speaking of planetary object lessons
i i
cannot resist the temptation to spend
just a moment
with you on the planet mars
this is a photograph taken by the united
states viking 1 spacecraft
in
1977
a
lovely beautiful instructive world
that's the subject of another talk
i mentioned
the antiseptic
character
of this surface
not a microbe not an organic molecule
why not
the reason
seems to be
that there is a planet-wide ozone hole
on mars
there is essentially no ozone in the
atmosphere mars the ultraviolet light
strikes the surface of mars
unimpeded by the martian atmosphere
and the result
is a surface
which is made antiseptic
by
oxidizing compounds
peroxides superoxides
and
this also
may be a useful reminder to us
of the importance of an ozone layer
next slide
now let me try to just
take you through a few
slides illustrating the greenhouse
effect
here is
this is a beautiful photograph taken by
the meteo sat satellite of the european
space agency
uh of africa and much of europe
uh taken in ordinary visible light
the next slide
shows exactly the same area
photographed by exactly
the same satellite at almost exactly the
same moment
but
at a wavelength of 10 microns in the
infrared
this is a wavelength where the
atmosphere is still mainly transparent
in the infrared
red is hot and we can see
the hot places on the earth and by the
way also you can see over uh zaire and
and
much of central africa a set of clouds
which
uh also work in this case to keep the
heat in
but now next slide
if we look at one of the wavelengths
where the atmosphere absorbs
we can make out none of the features
of the surface of the earth
we're looking here at high altitude
features
and the reason is that at this
particular wavelength
the atmosphere of the earth is opaque
this is an illustration
of greenhouse
how the greenhouse works
next slide
here
is a
picture
notable in many different respects one
of which is that
it accompanied a
very
excellent
op-ed piece in the new york times on
earth day by our chairman senator gore
um showing
the result of boring chorus through the
antarctic ice cap
done by the soviet vostok
team
in which
are plotted
both
the observed change in temperature over
the last tens of thousands of years
and the observed change in the amount of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
and notice how well
the two curves quite different track
each other
the temperatures are determined from
oxygen isotopes
in this core the deeper down in the core
the further back in time
and the carbon dioxide abundance in the
atmosphere is determined from little
bubbles of air that have been trapped in
the ice
so
each point in
each
depth in the core corresponds to a
certain moment in the past history of
the earth
you determine the temperature you
determine how much co2 is in the air
when there's more co2 the temperature is
higher when there's less co2 the
temperature is lower
this is a very significant and useful
demonstration
that adding greenhouse gases to the air
actually does
increase the temperature and now
the carbon dioxide abundance is much
higher than it's been anywhere in this
period
and
the imminent prediction is that the
temperature
temperatures
will be much higher as well
and in fact even though
the
average temperature of the earth has not
been much increasing during the decade
of the 1980s
the decade of the 1980s still has
the five hottest years
in the 20th century
and
just
speaking anecdotally this year looks to
be another hot year
next slide
this is for three different gases
how much of the gas there is against
time in
recent years this is the carbon dioxide
increase with time
here is a gas called methane its
increase in time
here is one of the chlorofluorocarbons
its increase in time there's no question
that human activity
and mainly the burning of fossil fuels
is increasing
the amount of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere
next slide
here are
this is one set
of computer models
and uh i can't quite make out the times
just one minute
so i don't know if you can make this out
but there is a mercator projection map
of the earth here western hemisphere
here eastern hemisphere here and it's
the same in each of these four maps
this is 1960 this is right now
this is 2000 and this i can't quite make
out but it's about 2050.
2020.
2020 2050. thank you
and
the browner it is the warmer it is and
you can see
the
clear trend
and something like this is the trend in
all
of the three-dimensional general
circulation computer models
that have been run
this one from the
guttered institute of space
sciences in new york
and the next slide shows for just
the same circumstances that there are
maps underneath here as well and for the
same years
a measure of drought
and you can see
the drought
getting progressively
very
serious
now
what should we do
about this
the next slide
this is my last slide
is from a
official
white house
hand out
at a meeting
held just a week ago
on global warming
and
there were many issues
discussed
in that handout one of which was called
balance
balance in the parlance of the white
house by the way i understand this is a
non-partisan
gathering
but on the other hand
there is glasnost now even in the soviet
union so i'm sure you will permit me a
personal remark
um
balance in the view of the white house
you can clearly see it
has two
pans
on the scales of a balance
on one
side
is the planet earth
and on the other side
are six
bars of gold
and maybe you can notice that they
exactly balance each other
in the view
of those who put this picture together
this is a
perfectly
good way to address the problem
uh i certainly happy to go along with
the white house on this the question is
is the picture drawn correctly
or might
the earth
weigh
more heavily
than six
bars of gold
i think it's perfectly possible to
treat the issue
on the grounds that the white house
suggests
but the answer
is not
a perfect balance
between the earth
and money
because
the earth or at least the part of it
that sustains
our life and civilization
is
priceless
and i would like to argue
that before we are absolutely sure
which means
that we are either
in desperate greenhouse warming
or not
it would be wise to take certain
precautionary steps
now i have the lights please and the
slides off
i'm not done
now
what should be done what is a reasonable
set of responses to this
new
oracle this set of
mutually supportive prophecies by the
different
scientific oracles with some differences
between them of course
the main problem
is the burning of fossil fuels
when you take a lump of coal and burn it
in the oxygen of the air the carbon in
the coal combines with the oxygen in the
air
carbon c
oxygen o2 makes co2
it is a an irreducible consequence
of the burning of coal oil
natural gas
petroleum wood
and so on
one thing surely that can be done is to
have a more
efficient burning
of those fossil fuels
so for example
in this country the united states by the
way
is the worst
carbon dioxide producer on the planet
the soviet union is the second worst
and
if we were to lump all the countries in
the developing world together
they would represent the third
worst producer of carbon dioxide and
therefore
it is very important to remember
that this is an issue we are all in
together
we we're all in this greenhouse together
certainly the countries that have the
largest responsibility have the largest
contribution should have the largest
responsibility
but
everyone on the earth is producing this
more efficient
burning of fossil fuels
a third of uh almost a third of u.s
production of carbon dioxide comes from
driving cars and
buses
trucks
why do we drive
cars that get 20 miles per gallon
when it is perfectly feasible
in an engineering sense to have cars
that get 60 miles a gallon
everybody got 60 miles a gallon
everybody could go as far as they
ordinarily go
and we would have reduced the amount of
co2 put up into the atmosphere by
internal combustion engines by
two-thirds
and this
goes across the boards
every area of energy use
can be made more efficient
by
feasible technologies
and by the way if you think of the
development of these technologies it
becomes very clear
to capitalists that there is money to be
made
in dealing with the environmental issues
it's not that
the coal oil
gas and auto industries are going to go
bankrupt
because they may have to change their
ways of doing things on the other hand
just the opposite
this has a wide range of investment
opportunities
for smart corporations
second thing we should do
is to make
large-scale
research and development investments on
alternatives
to fossil fuels
the paradigm of these alternatives is
solar power
which converts sunlight into electricity
or sunlight into hot water
producing no polluting gases no
greenhouse gases no radioactive waste
and such systems
are within hailing distance of being
competitive
with other means of generating
electricity
if we were to include
even in our minds
a kind of tax on the fossil fuel
industry
for the damage
that they do every time some co2 goes
into the atmosphere solar power would be
fully competitive
right now
with the burning of fossil fuels for
those regions of the country that
that have sunlight i happen to come from
a place in upstate new york which has
sunlight only rarely
the third thing
that we ought to do
is massive
reforestation on a global scale
growing trees take carbon dioxide out of
the atmosphere
they are a kind of anti-greenhouse
machinery
we plant a forest
co2 gets taken out of the atmosphere
there is a
corporation not far from here
called
i think applied energy
systems it's in arlington virginia
they are building a
power plant i think maybe coal-fired
in connecticut anyway somewhere in the
northeast
which will of course put carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere
what aes has committed to do
is to plant a forest in guatemala
which will take out of the atmosphere
the same amount of carbon dioxide
that its power plant will put into the
atmosphere
over
the anticipated lifetime of that power
plant that's an example
of responsible corporate behavior
instead of
planting forests
we humans are destroying forests at an
amazing rate
of an acre
a second
an acre of land every second
is denuded of its trees
worldwide
this is stupid
and should stop
and the final
mitigating step that i want to call your
attention to
has to do
with the population of the human family
all of these other issues
no matter how heroic
we
change our
practices
in fossil fuel efficiency and finding
alternatives to fossil fuel and planting
forests they will all come to naught
if we don't do something about the
rapidly increasing population growth
on the planet every human
has to burn fuel to go about his or her
daily lives the more people
the more
greenhouse gases
now
let me just say a couple of words about
that
there is a uh
a very
mistaken view
that you sometimes can come upon
in the developed world
that the problem with the population
growth
in all those poor countries
is that those poor people don't
understand
why
they should limit their population
or that there is an unavailability of
birth control devices
i believe the situation is very
different from that
i believe that the billion poorest
people on the planet
tend to have many children
out of
a careful cost benefit analysis
if you're very poor
it doesn't cost much
to raise children they might be helpful
in
carrying the water and
and the
wood
since no one is educated
you don't have to pay at all for their
education
and if a few of them survive
they might be able to take care of you
in your old age because your country
doesn't provide anything like social
security
it makes sense on the time scale of the
human lifetime
under such circumstances to have many
children
and
it is clear if we just look back in the
developed world a few generations the
generation of my
grandparents and great grandparents for
example
people had huge families
they do not have them today why not
all over the world
there is a very
interesting phenomenon that's been
called the demographic transition
and it occurs east and west buddhist
countries and catholic countries
communist countries and capitalist
countries
and it goes like this
when the per capita income
is
raised above a certain very low level by
american standards
the population growth rate automatically
turns down
people make that cost benefit analysis
anew
and decide to have
fewer children
the solution
the principal solution
to the world population
crisis
is to raise the standard of living of
the poorest people on the planet
and so if we wish consistently to follow
through
the implications
of our
proper concern about global warming
we must address the issue of poverty
and i believe
in the old adage of providing not fish
but fish hooks
there are ways for the developed
countries
to provide self-sufficiency to help
provide self-sufficiency
for the poorest people on the planet
and the cost
can be
readily estimated
and the key fact is
that it is enormously less
then the amount of money that we
spend on arms every year
the world military budgets are now at
one trillion dollars
one million million dollars
every year a modest fraction of that
would be enough to raise
the standard of living of the billion
poorest people on the planet and there's
one other aspect of that that has to do
with the status of women
there are a few places on the planet
which have
substantial per capita income and still
have very large
population growth and they are all
places i believe
where the status of women is very low
where women are not educated are not
permitted to be educated
and
are not
co-equal
with males
so i think
a very sober
non-ideological approach to these issues
would drive anyone concerned with these
global environmental issues
to the
reduction of poverty and the increase of
the status of women
worldwide
you don't have to have uh
any sense it seems to me of
the justice or humanitarian aspects
of these mitigating steps although
they're obviously there
you only have to be concerned about the
future of the planet and you're driven
in that direction
you have genie of tischenko in his
stirring poem
talked about
moral
autumn
it seems to me
that
if we merely have a sober
assessment of the situation facing us we
could
automatically
find ourselves
in a moral
spring
there is one final aspect of this issue
i'd like to mention
and that is
molecules don't have passports
molecules are very stupid
but they do not understand
the importance of the concept of
national sovereignty
they do not recognize
national boundaries
and on those pictures of the earth from
space it's very hard to make out the
national boundaries
the national boundaries are man-made
the earth
is really there
so carbon dioxide or cfcs put up by one
nation do not stay over that nation
they are carried by the general
circulation of the earth's atmosphere
all over the planet
and therefore we are all in this
together
these global environmental issues
have a fascinating
trends
ideological
trans-national
and trans-generational
character
they force us
to think
of the planet as a unity
they force us to think
about our responsibility
to future
generations
there is a
passage
in the bible
in the book of proverbs
which sometimes haunts me
it goes
they set
an ambush for their own lives
if we do nothing on these global
environmental issues
that's
what we
will be doing
but if we use
our intelligence
which
is the secret of the success of our
species
if we use our ability to foresee
the future consequences of present
actions
if we draw upon
our common
humanitarian feelings
then i think
that we are fully capable
of solving
these problems
and in the process
making the world a far better place
than it is now
i wish you all success
in your work
[Applause]
we have time for only three questions
if you do not speak in english
please do not hesitate
to ask your question
anyway
we have
headsets up here as well
so anyone who would like to
ask a question
please
raise your hand and stand
and we will repeat the question for
those who might not hear it
three questions who would like to ask
the first
also knowing that 80 percent
of these gadgets
are reduced
in the northern part of the earth
in spite of this
the sun there
is destroyed fairies and more
in the thousand reports
the questioner who senator gore tells me
is from egypt
asks the
perfectly reasonable question
the cfcs are mainly made in the northern
hemisphere
and the biggest destruction of the ozone
layer is a whole over the continent of
antarctica as far south as you can go
how does this come about
the answer has to do with the
circulation
of the earth's atmosphere the movement
of air at high altitude
the
cfcs are
are remarkable
they were invented by brilliant chemists
who were motivated to find a perfectly
harmless and inert molecule
to use as the working fluid in
refrigerators and air conditioners and
other
other
useful functions
they made a molecule so inert
that it's impossible to destroy it down
here
so the molecule leaks out of an air
conditioner
and it bounces off molecules in the air
it bounces off telephone poles and
buildings
does no damage to it at all
eventually
they are carried
to stratospheric altitude
and it's there that they meet ozone
molecules they are match
and destroy them but that circulation
carries
the
cfc molecules all over the planet
including
to the south pole
and there
there is
a
vortex of polar air
and
a kind of cloud
that is prevalent there and it's that
mix which makes the greatest destruction
of ozone happening over the south pole
however there is evidence
of the ozone layer thinning at many
other latitudes
and senator gore reminds me that
there is one not quite as
as thin yet over the north pole
other questions
why
to did 10 000 years ago
here is a question uh rather similar to
the to the previous one
why did carbon dioxide increase
10 000 years ago surely there were no
fuel inefficient automobiles then
the carbon dioxide content of the
earth's atmosphere
has been oscillating
varying
within certain limits
over
as far back into earth history as we're
able to determine
the important point and and the reasons
obviously do not involve
human beings or human
technology or probably not 10 000 years
ago
was a special time for humans
in which we
our numbers were growing very much was
the end of the last ice age maybe we had
some contribution there but before that
surely not
there are a set of natural processes
which increase or decrease the amount of
carbon dioxide in the air
the more growing trees for example the
more carbon dioxide the the less carbon
dioxide in the air
and
forests and plants are
destroyed and grow for all sorts of
reasons including the motion of
continents and
the impact of objects from space but the
main point is
that the variation of the carbon dioxide
has been within limits
and is now
rising
out of
that range
that it has in the past
and that
rise out of the range
is
without a doubt
uh due to human activity
senator gore do we have time for another
question or two or
as the outcome one more question
i'll be glad to repeat the question
but
my question really is
instead of focusing on youtube
or conserving whatever
remaining tropical forest
we already have but our past diminishing
and it so happens that
by coincidence
the only remaining tropical forests on
earth happen today
in that vegan countries you sent around
central air
western amazonia and southeast asia
including the philippines
and our country for example have
15 million dwellers in the upland areas
putting pressure on the forest because
there is no
alternative livelihood and if 46
of our gnp goes to that service
there is no way we can help out these
people and the forest is going fast
it's it'll be gone by the year 2000 and
i'm not sure if that situation is the
same in other countries
now since the creditor countries by
coincidence
as well
happen to be
the co2
producers
and we all live in one ecosystem
can we not have some kind of a burden
sharing so that we would be able to
conserve
our forest number one
number two
companies also because of their
occupation on the bottom line
do all sorts of all sorts of stupid
things
our occupation on gnp
without
consideration of the cost of
environmental degradation or destruction
also freedom to do all sorts of stupid
things i understand there are countries
in europe that are now
instituting in their gmt calculations
the cost of environmental degradation
and destruction
is there a way this can be
on a worldwide global scale
also be a development in the future
thank you thank you i clearly made a
mistake by not asking you to to come up
here that was a very eloquent uh
statement uh thank you so much well
the the question had several parts to it
uh one was the distinction between
growing forests and conserving forests
and surely existing forests should be
conserved
not so much because they take carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere
but because they
are a unique repository of species
diversity we are destroying plants and
animals
i don't mean individual animals we are
making species of plants and animals
extinct so that they will never live
again on earth at an appalling rate
i don't think we have a right to do that
in the first place in the second place
there are many practical uses that such
plants and animals can have for the
human species so it's foolish
as you correctly said to do that
secondly the question is said in
places like the philippines where he
comes from
the
forests remaining stands of forests old
forests are being destroyed
because poor people need the trees
for lumber for firewood
and so on
and this is connected with the large
fraction of the gross national product
of such nations that goes to the
retirement of debt the questioner asks
if
international debt the questioner asks
if we're all in this greenhouse together
and if the developing countries the ones
that have lent the money
are the biggest polluters on the planet
might there not be a reason for them to
ease
the debt retirement requirements or
you didn't say this but maybe you meant
cancel them all together uh you want my
personal opinion
absolutely
the the idea of a crushing debt burden
uh prevents
education it prevents development it
prevents
the demographic transition which is
needed to control population growth
and this then brings me to the last
point
which has to do the distinction between
short-term and long-term goals
if we always focus on the short term
we will lose
we have to simultaneously worry about
short-term and long-term issues now for
politicians is a particular
concern here
there is a temptation
to take steps
which will have benefits
during the term of office
of the politician
in the united states this is two years
for representatives four years for
presidents and six years for senators
but the issues we're talking about
are 10
30
50 years in the future
if politicians are only concerned
about the shortest term turnaround
so that the benefits of their policies
can be reaped while they were they are
still in office
then
the need to make long-term planning
is going to
to be missed
but there's one way in which long-term
and short-term objectives can be joined
and that is if politicians
who are
solely devoted to the short term
are voted out of office
then
[Applause]
eventually there will only be
politicians who worry about the long
term
so
you know
what you have to do
and those of us who are not politicians
know what we have to do
thank you
carl may i may i tell them that we'll be
around after dinner
carl sagan has said that he will remain
uh here in this room visiting with those
who did not have a chance to ask a
question
and we'll be glad to
talk with you
individually about the questions after
we conclude our
formal session here this evening
let me make two points before we
call it a night
first of all
anyone who wishes to speak
during this inter-parliamentary
conference
will have an opportunity to speak
we want to hear
from all the voices
that are represented
around the world
here
in this room
please let us know when
you would like to speak
during the discussion of the working
group reports
or during the debate on wednesday
morning
on the conference resolutions
and we will make certain that you will
have an opportunity to speak
we heard in the last question
an important message
that those of us from the developed
world
must hear
during this conference
carl sagan said during his address the
issue of the global environment is
linked to the issue of poverty
interdependence
is one of the themes we will be
discussing
the second point in closing is
we want to begin our sessions this week
promptly at the hour indicated in the
program
tomorrow morning for example
8 30 a.m
means 8 30
a.m
please be on time because we will begin
at 8 30
a.m
thank you all very much and join me in
thanking carl sagan again for a
wonderful speech thank you carl
[Music]
we invite you to join us on tuesday
morning at 10 eastern time for a live
coverage of a senate appropriations
subcommittee on foreign operations
hearing on the fiscal year 1991 budget
secretary of state james baker is
scheduled to testify
up next more remarks from the
inter-parliamentary conference on the
global environment
[Music]
so
[Music]
get the opportunity to look at some
recent white house photography that's
sunday beginning at 10 pm eastern time 7
p.m on the west coast
[Music]
coming up next we bring you remarks by
william riley administrator of the
environmental protection agency and
professor carl sagan who spoke this
afternoon at a caring for creation
conference sponsored by the north
american conference on religion and
ecology
[Music]
good afternoon and i want to welcome you
to
this
significant session of the
intercontinental conference on caring
for creation
from around
the united states north of us in canada
and from other parts
of the world we have
people who have come to
look at
their religious commitment in a new way
to care for creation
to save the earth
this afternoon we are particularly
i might say blessed and honored
to have
three very significant
people who will be with us
to share their light
and their insight
and their commitment
to saving the earth saving the planet
and the
ecosystems
of the planet
our first speaker and one who is
has an exceedingly busy schedule
just got in from the bergen conference
and other things in europe
i believe earlier today
or last night
oh you didn't go to bergen okay
reroute it okay that's all right
we're working on things but has been
going from
i might say
meeting to conference to parliament to
white house to
major leaders around the world
bringing with him a vision
and a commitment to
conservation and
and environmental
understanding and values in a way that
is very significant
in this
the 1990s
for that reason we are going to
do something very special that i think
and the board of directors of the
north american conference on religion
and ecology ecology in a particular way
i think is appropriate
and it's an award called the eco-3 award
which i will presently explain
through its eco-3 structure called the
eco3 trial the north american conference
on religion and ecology
proposes to facilitate collaboration
among sci humanist
ecologists and economists
the meaning of the prefix eco
comes from the greek oikos meaning
household
family community all three collaborative
partners share a common interest in the
household of the earth the humanists are
those who come from the various faith
communities religious organizations and
spiritual traditions
they are working together
from a shared faith or value perspective
to renew the face of the earth and to
care more responsibly for creation
through their interfaith household
ecologists are those who have an
expertise or interest in the
environmental or conservation movement
they also see scientifically
that the household of nature
ecology is in grave danger and now
warrants a call for deeper ethical
response to save the earth's ecosystems
economists literally those who manage
the household are those managers and
stewards who have the skills and
responsibility
to make the earth community run in a
just and sustainable fashion
these economists may be leaders from the
public sector or the private one
they can be elected representatives or
environmentally minded
government people business people
philanthropist investors executives as
well as trained economists
william riley administrator of the
environmental protection agency
is given this award by the north
american conference
on religion and ecology in recognition
of his work in three areas
first for his record as a
conservationist
in his public and private life
william t riley has devoted his
professional life
to environmental issues throughout his
career at the world wildlife fund and
now as administrator of the
environmental protection agency
mr riley has inspired his colleagues
offered vision and clarity to
legislative and private initiatives
for improving life on this earth and
creating creating a significant platform
from which to in
involve everyone in the process of
environmental renewal
secondly
william riley is being given this eco
three award for his long-standing and
continued dedication to the spiritual
dimension
of the environmental issues confronting
us today
mr reilly recognizes that for today's
citizen to be religiously committed
means to be deeply committed to
environmental issues and personally
involved with caring for creation
william riley has not only preached
this reality but has practiced it as
well in the exemplary
model of his own personal commitment to
caring for mother earth and thirdly mr
riley is receiving this eco3 award for
his early and continued support of the
efforts behind this conference
at a time when most of the environmental
community had not yet begun to grasp
the importance of the religious
dimension
the value dimension to the environmental
crisis
william riley not only understood this
fundamental fact of reality he acted
upon it
by becoming one of nacre's initial
supporters and funders
through his position
in as president
of the world wildlife fund
for these reasons we award
to william
to riley this afternoon the eco-3 award
and we give him something
that will remind him of his
history and of ecology and of the
environment
and as i give him this
waterford crystal
vase full of
full of beautiful spring flowers
i want uh you to know that we wanted to
have not just a plaque
but or not something simply to hang on
your wall but you may be getting one of
those too
but
we're giving you this
bill
with a really
sincere thanks and a heartfelt
feeling within
the community here that you are a
genuine leader who combines the best of
both
a spiritual commitment
to see that we must care for creation
and a respect for science and economics
that makes you realistic in this pursuit
thank you
we'll put it on
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
because of the very
rapid nature of his work and
the
unbelievable amount of things to do
bill reilly will have to leave us after
his
talk but i believe
his presence among us both honors us and
connotes the very important
decisions we are making here in
responding
to
the bioregional plans
and calling forth religious leadership
to work with scientists
ecologists and economists to make this
a truly sustainable
and regenerative earth
well thank you very very much don that
is a
moving introduction and really a
touching
dedication and
perfectly appropriate gift this
this these spring flowers the
the
early fruits of the spring creation
i
am very honored to be the first
presented
with this eco-3 award
and i'm
particularly
touched to be recognized in the category
of economist
i fear that you may do violence
by that categorization both to the
profession
and perhaps to my reputation in some
quarters
in one fell swoop
but
and in other quarters i guess i have to
confess you will simply astonish
by suggesting that degree of sensitivity
to economics on my part
but from my point of view
from my point of view
it is a a very satisfying honor that you
confer on me
and i really appreciate it
i'm here
to
discuss issues to which i attach
of
great significance
with many old friends
and some colleagues
and i'm here i should warn you at the
outset
as is often true i find
in my present position
to talk about a lot of things that i
probably know much less about than most
of you
that hasn't deterred me yet
and
a lawyer there are those who would say a
lawyer talking about moral and spiritual
values should be disqualified
at the start
but
i do feel strongly about some of these
issues i complement the
concerns
and efforts that have brought you
together and i very much hope that
they're successful i think they're
vitally important to the achievement of
objectives that certainly as
administrator vpa
are very important to me in my public
duties
and i think more fundamentally
significant to the
spiritual development
and to the reconciliation of humans with
nature which i take to be
our common concern
one of the most interesting
and arresting phenomena in nature is the
coming together of two great rivers
the missouri and the mississippi north
of
st louis
the allegheny and the monongahela
which joined together at pittsburgh
the rio negro and the salimosh that
formed the mighty amazon
at manaus
from the airs i remember particularly in
the case of that latter great confluence
it's possible to see how two great
rivers flow together for a time without
fully merging each retaining its
distinctive color
its mud
its minerals or even its pollution
but finally they flow into each other
and they become broader
and far more powerful
than either tributary
such confluences occur not only in
nature
when men and women of faith marched and
suffered at the selma bridge their
message in word and deed was that racism
is evil
they added a vital moral force to a
movement to reform the law
a force that joined a demanding and
irresistible moral current
to the milder movement of our laws
together
moral indignation
and
legal reform
created a new reality
and as a result
civil rights
received
an enduring sanction
this conference of ecumenist
economist
and ecologist must aspire
to create such a confluence
it is time to recognize i think both the
achievements
but also the limitations
of the movement that has been called
environmentalism
it is time to acknowledge the important
spiritual dimension that the community
of faith
can bring to efforts to protect the
environment
fundamentally
environmentalism is about
reconciling humanity more satisfactorily
with the natural systems upon which
human life and civilization depend
during the past 20 years the united
states has made great progress in
protecting its environment
my friend the writer rice odell
has identified
three great achievements of
environmentalism during this period
first and most obviously
the air is more healthful
rivers and lakes are cleaner
parks and wilderness preserves are
larger and more numerous whales and bald
eagles are coming back
second
americans have a genuinely new way of
looking at things
we are
somewhat more
future oriented and set quality of life
concerns of health
safety the experience of unspoiled
nature
alongside economic growth and
materialism
by no means have we abandoned
our economic aspirations economic growth
during these same 20 years was
significant and it generated the wealth
necessary to pay for pollution control
but we have redefined our economic
aspirations
and have adjusted them
and have imbued them with new concepts
that represent more demanding
expectations
we speak now of sustainable development
and recognize
a wider web of life
in which we see ourselves dependent on a
natural order that embraces other
species
to some of these species humans have
always shown affection
the furry animals come immediately to
mind
but increasingly
while we may not love the swamp rat
we do
exhibit a certain reverence for the
distinctive life form he represents
and our laws provide some protection
for the niche in nature he occupies
this reverence is a rationalist not a
religious sort of thing it's based on a
darwinian insight that all life forms
are related and ever evolving in a
mutually supportive progression
we may need the swamp rat
depend on him even in ways science has
yet to discover
maybe he thrives on a pest
regulates a natural system has some
still to be determined role
in keeping it all going we are not
certain
that very humility in the face of
natural phenomena is an environmentalist
innovation
what we don't understand
we forbear to disturb
alter or destroy
so often humankind has gotten it wrong
where nature was concerned that there is
wisdom
in technological caution
a third great achievement of
environmentalism has been its
development of some key legal concepts
and its advancement of their
acceptance and effect the need for
public analysis of environmental impact
of decisions
the reasonableness of demanding that
alternatives
be considered
the right to know about toxic emissions
from plants
the right to sue the government without
claiming an economic interest these once
novel ideas have been advocated advanced
and codified in law
they're generally accepted by the
society as reasonable and necessary
to good government and their influence
is profound
in odell's view
these reforms
have contributed to a more refined
democracy and have conspicuously
advanced the democratization of society
well i have described some of the
contributions and achievements of
environmentalism
these reforms were conceived in 1960s
protests
born in anger and outrage at pollution
you could see
touch and smell
now they have become accepted
but they are not enough
the world today faces two kinds of
threats that require
more than mere laws to address
first
while we have confronted and tamed many
of the most egregious sources of
pollution at least in the united states
in western europe
we now must come to grips with pollution
sources that are scattered
diffuse
and individual
we must come to grips with individual
behavior
and with the consequences
of the way we lead our lives
with very high levels
of waste per capita
with water pollution that does not come
from the end of a pipe
but that runs off farms and city streets
and with air pollution
it comes from cars idling in congestion
our laws work less well
at confronting problems of this scale
and so the bush administration is
seeking new ways to fashion laws to
design economic incentives that reward
behavior that is environmentally
responsible
government command and control
approaches
may well have taken us about as far as
they can
the second kind of threat that we have
only recently begun to understand and
acknowledge
is the danger posed to the global
environment
the threat to the very
stability of critical life support
systems of the planet
our discovery of the ozone hole over the
antarctic
more recently over the arctic
have revealed how destructive human
activity can be and how far advanced it
can become before it's identified
correcting for ozone depletion and that
ozone hole
now is as large in size as the
continental united states
will take
many decades
long after
humans have ceased to manufacture the
chlorofluorocarbons
these long-lived chemicals will still be
migrating up to the stratosphere
and destroying its protective layer of
ozone exposing us all
to more cancers
and more cataracts
i have frequently spoken to the need to
foster economic incentives to address
environmental problems i believe very
strongly that we must work to ensure
that economic incentives
line up with environmental goals
for protecting the ozone layer
or reducing acid rain
or conserving tropical forests
but it also is increasingly clear that
we must go beyond compulsion
laws and incentives
we must engage the heart which is not
reached by appeals to law or science
in 1986
the duke of edinburgh in his capacity as
president of the worldwide fund for
nature convened representatives of five
major religions in assisi to prepare
statements about human responsibility
for nature
christians jews hindus muslims and
buddhists all
joined together in a
beautiful
and historic act of celebration of
prayer
in the historic basilica of saint
francis the church where the saint is
buried
each of the representatives of the
religions in attendance and later the
baha'is and the sikhs issued statements
setting out their faith's theological
basis for supporting the conservation of
nature each of these faiths
came together reflected
and on the basis of their tradition and
their history
their scripture
prepared thoughtful
theological
statements
these statements are very powerful
appeals to the faithful to believers to
recognize the implications of their
beliefs
for their conduct regarding the
environment
the reasoning behind initiatives such as
the assisi meeting
and i guess this conference as well
has been expressed in an insightful
series of lectures by john d
siziolis eastern orthodox bishop of
pergamon
he's written of the great confidence
western societies place in ethics
whether enforced by legislation or
taught by churches
however
he argues by appealing to human reason
we do not necessarily make people better
while moral rules especially after their
dissociation from religious beliefs
prove to be more and more meaningless
and unpleasant to modern man
there are he writes other forces besides
the human intellect
that decide the direction in which the
fate of the world moves
theology in the church ought to embrace
areas other than the ethical that is the
rational prescription of behavior
if they are to be of any use in this
case
well as a government official my concern
is necessarily with laws
for you
as leaders of the community of faith
the focus is on values
and fundamental beliefs
you therefore deal with the whole person
not merely with behavior
but with the well springs
that feed a fuller worldview
where i am concerned with pollution
you are concerned with creation
and with the basic relationship faith
should imply for conserving the natural
order
i congratulate you on coming together on
uniting humanist economists and
ecologists to reflect on the fate of the
earth and on the full
dimensions of individual personhood
president bush spoke to the duty of the
individual during a visit to spokane
washington last september
he said through millions of individual
decisions simple
everyday personal choices
we are determining the fate of the earth
the new alliance inaugurated here today
can make a powerful contribution to
inculcating that sense of responsibility
the president spoke to
alliance will help us as don conroy put
it
to dream a new dream of the creation
truly renewed a dream of a creation in
which we all care for the air for the
animals and for the ecosystems
in his 1990 world day of peace message
pope john paul ii added his voice to the
growing number of religious leaders who
recognized the spiritual dimensions
of environmental problems
last january i called upon the u.s
catholic conference to issue a pastoral
letter on nature in the environment
i set out several specific issues
such a letter might usefully address
and i call upon you to do the same thing
within every north american faith
tradition represented here today
in the next year
i would like to see each faith each
denomination represented here
formulate its own authoritative
restatement of the moral and spiritual
basis
for the stewardship of nature
these statements could have a powerful
influence for environmental betterment
on individuals
on
makers
on business leaders
on citizens of all faiths
although i realize that one very
powerful message of this conference is
to go back to your home communities with
action as opposed to words i hope that
one result of that action will be the
statements for which i am calling
statements that i think could have a
significant impact
on parishes on churches on communities
all across north america
such statements i would hope
would make a significant difference
not only
in the making of laws
but also in the keeping of
laws
there simply are limits to what laws can
achieve
among the burdens of modern life that
chafe upon free and creative people are
layers of requirements rules and
regulations ministered by large
bureaucracies
surely one of the sources of alienation
and discouragement in modern life is the
daily encounter with large organizations
to whom ordinary individuals just don't
seem to matter very much
try as we will to limit our laws to
issues that really do matter to the
well-being
health and safety of society
we contribute sometimes
to a deadening of the spirit
and the truth is that laws cannot
ultimately do all that we ask of them
to that discovery we must not respond by
adding ever more restrictions and
requirements
instead
we must respond by recognizing the role
of education
of non-governmental groups
and of belief
i would urge you not to direct your
recommendations
to government
but rather to individuals
let me be clear
whether in caring for the poor
or achieving racial justice
or protecting the environment
government has a large and vigorous
responsibility
but it is not enough
when consumers buy green products
when drivers use clean fuels
when people opt to recycle or improve
energy efficiency these are decisions
that made on a large scale
can matter more than laws
and you are in a position to inform
and inspire such choices
to give greater meaning and significance
to everyday
decisions not as imposed requirements
but as willed
and informed personal commitments
this society i believe is open to such
values
we aspire to be more
than a civilization of consumption and
consumerism
a throwaway society that uses discards
and then moves on leaving its mess
behind
we do not want to define success merely
as
having more
but also as being more
you in this audience and the
institutions you represent are concerned
as much
probably more than others
with defining what it means
to be more
so i wish you well
and i thank you for listening to this
lawyer bureaucrat go beyond his brief
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
to introduce our next speaker
is a man who
has shown
the ability to
touch the life of the church in the 20th
century
and of all religions
by his
both intellectual and ringmaster ability
i might say
he has the ability to
convene
all types of people
from the president president havel
recently
the magnificent ceremony in saint john
the divine
to stand with dr carl sagan in moscow
with secretary gorbachev in january
when they made the appeal
appeal to scientists and religious
leaders to join hands to save the earth
so without further ado
i give you
dean and james sparks morton
[Applause]
well my friends i have the honor of
introducing to you carl sagan but it's
really like
um introducing a scientist
in the scientific realm who corresponds
in the religious realm say to
introducing the dalai lama or to
archbishop tutu or to mother teresa
because on the one hand they're all
household words you know when you sort
of think religion you say well yeah like
mother teresa and when you think science
you sort of say like carl sagan but
so much more because those three
religious folks are certainly
amazing exemplars of their particular
faith traditions
but you can't keep them in a box
anymore you can keep carl sagan in a box
because he's all over the place and
that's
uh what's so
fantastic but before introducing him i
do want to say something
not about the august folks who are up
here but about the august folks who are
out there
because i think what makes this
washington meeting really very
interesting
is the fact that
bringing together
sort of religious folks who are involved
in the environment
is really new
at the cathedral we've been involved in
environmental programs since 1972
and we really could count on perhaps
one hand other religious organizations
in america
because we were really looked upon as
strange ducks
you know i mean what you're religious
people why are you concerned about
rivers
you know why are you concerned about
green things all you have to do is
read
a certain cardinal who happens to live
in new york's
sermon on earth day to find out where
religion still has to go
to get the message
but you folks who by and large are lay
people
have been the people in the trenches in
the environmental movement
and you've been doing that out of your
synagogues or out of your churches or
just out of your own convictions in your
own backyards and in your own city lots
and
that to me is what's so extraordinary
about finding an occasion when you were
really the the fighters in this um
peaceful war um are in one room
and so
uh with all due respect to
those on the platform i think the real
credit is to those who were in the round
tables and
i salute you
[Applause]
now
in
to introducing carl
we go back
about
a decade uh
we started uh a
series of free concerts at the cathedral
on new year's eve and
he was the he and leonard bernstein sort
of took the cake and they were the
uh it was the first one and and carl
spoke about uh
on new year's eve
nuclear winter
that was how many years ago when did you
84 okay
six years ago
and um
part of our loneliness at st john the
divine has been that our buddies in this
have have have really all been
scientists and um
some anthropologists and some
philosophers
running to both starting with us in 75
and lovelock in 79 and bucky fuller in
80. and
it's nice to see some of the people who
are here
brian swim and peter berg
really we've been working with but we
haven't been working with quote
religious folks because there weren't
any that we could you know sort of
reverse collar types um
with the exception of perhaps
tom barry and we were saying up here
professor joe sittler at the university
of chicago there were very very few
professional quote religious types in
on the environmental agenda
and so that's
that's the great that's the great change
but carl
was one of those
heroic scientists who dared to go into
one of these hot religious places and we
just emerged from a press conference and
you know he was asked was he was he an
atheist or was he a theist and you know
he well he'll give you an answer in a
minute but uh
it was really wonderful now i'm going to
do two things um i'm going to
tell you all the stuff that carl has
done it's going to be very
i'm not going to tell you all the stuff
he's done because there's two pages
he'll all go to sleep but
he is the david duncan professor of
astronomy and space sciences he is the
director of the lab for planetary
studies and these are both at cornell
and he played a leading role in the
mariner and the viking the voyager
expeditions to the planets
for which he got the nasa medal
he's published more than 600 scientific
papers
but
like bishop tutu they're not just you
know in-house stuff
he's written many many popular books
and he
got the emmy and the peabody award for
his television series cosmos which i'm
sure many of you saw it was in 60
countries and it was looked at by 300
million people
and then that of course had a book along
with it
so his
just extraordinary output and uh
recognition
in the scientific community but in the
larger humanistic community is
extraordinary
well that's that's one thing
but
what
i want to
sort of leave you with as an introducing
carl is
this really amazing thing that comes out
of
his understanding of things
which is very political
and it's an effort that we've been
involved together in
really starting in
1988
when together we were part of a
remarkable conference in oxford along
with mother teresa and the dalai lama
and a great
cast of characters
on trying to get
the political community and the
religious community joining forces
and after that and in preparation for
the moscow conference uh that was just
this this past january um we thought
wouldn't it be really important even
more important than political and
religious leaders to get scientific and
religious leaders making common cause
for
the saving of the environment
and
carl will describe this in in detail but
starting a year ago
we put together and he sent out
an appeal to
a number of distinguished scientists
around the world
nobel laureates scientists in this
country in france and israel in russia
all over the place
and when their responses came back
and the request that he made was we want
to make common cause with religious
leaders
are you with that
some 37 most distinguished men and women
around the world said yes
and
this appeal
is on the table over there so get a copy
as as you leave the session
and then i assume the responsibility for
sending the appeal with the signatures
of the
37 scientists
to
religious leaders around the world
we now have some 300 signatures of
really top people in the world saying
yes we religious people want to make
common cause with
the scientists so that together
we can work to cherish the earth now
that's going to take a long time but
what it does represent is really a new
threshold but new thresholds are what
carl sagan's all about so mr threshold
[Applause]
thank you jim
for that most generous introduction
very happy to be here
with you
and uh
because we're
about half an hour behind schedule and i
had wanted to leave time for
questions from the audience i'll
try to
shorten
what
what i had intended to say
this is a most peculiar issue
that humans
have become
in this
innocent manner
a danger
to themselves
we're not here talking about nuclear war
where at least there is some intent to
do harm
we're talking about the most
innocent acts of
burning a lump of coal or
developing
a harmless and inert material to act as
the working fluid in refrigerators and
air conditioners
who would have figured
that that
would pose a danger
when we started out
we humans a few hundred thousand years
ago or if you take the genus homo
uh maybe a few million years ago
there were of course very few of us
we lived in east africa our technology
was rudimentary
and uh
we
had no idea of
posing a danger to the global
environment we didn't have an idea of
there being a global
environment nevertheless if contemporary
hunter-gatherer societies are any
or any guide
we had a very
profound sense of living in harmony
with nature
as all the rest of the plants and
animals do because those who don't are
dead
and so natural selection produces such a
harmony
and there's no question that we
were part of such a harmony
now imagine the pages falling from the
calendar
uh the advantage of the human species
selective advantage
is our intelligence our ability to
foresee the future consequences of
present actions
and our
hands
which permit us to build
and with those tools we have
gone to every part of the earth
some of us
live
under the oceans
some of us live in space
we have been astonishingly successful
our numbers now are 5.3 billion
and our technology has reached
formidable
if not awesome
proportions
if there was no concept of having
stewardship of the earth a million years
ago
today
there is at least
a very great need
if you stand back from the earth
as those apollo astronauts did in the
late 60s and photograph the earth from
a distance in space so you can see the
whole earth
there is this blue aura that you can see
surrounding the daylit hemisphere
and it's just the atmosphere seen
edge-on
and what is most impressive what many
astronauts have
remarked upon
is how thin how fragile how vulnerable
it seems the thickness of the earth's
atmosphere compared to the size of the
earth
is about the same as the thickness of a
coat of shellac
on a
library globe
of the earth
there isn't
much
air
and so
we now have
the prospect
of inadvertently danger the
life-supporting environment the
environment that supports the human
species and many other
species of committing what
religious people sometimes call
crimes
against
creation
there's a wide range of these problems
that i know you've talked about at this
meeting
there are some
local some regional and some global
let me talk about the
two of the global issues
in part because they are
among the most serious
and in part because they
force upon us
a way of thinking
which is novel to many
although it certainly has deep roots in
the world's religious communities
those two problem areas are ozone
depletion and greenhouse warming
the ozone layer
if brought down to the pressure
temperature of this room would be about
that thick
about three
millimeters thick
there isn't much ozone
it protects us against dangerous
ultraviolet light from the sun
which if not impeded if it could reach
the surface of the earth
would produce a
range of
catastrophes
the one that's most discussed is
skin cancer especially in light-skinned
people like me dark-skinned people are
much better protected and that certainly
would be uh serious
but that's
minor compared to the other longer term
consequences
which include
a
challenge to the human immune system the
ability to fight disease
if the ozone layer is breached and
people have spent some time out of doris
it's something like getting a global
case of aids
except there's nothing special you have
to do to get the aids
except keep voting for the same
politicians
and then
still
more serious
is the fact that increased ultraviolet
light
damages the microorganisms that are at
the base of the food chain
uh upon which
the rest of us
depends so the simplest example of this
is the oceanic food chain where at the
ocean surface there is a community of
one-celled microscopic plants called
phytoplankton
and they harvest sunlight they're
primary photosynthetic
producers but
since they're at the surface of the
oceans and if there's more ultraviolet
light getting through the ozone layer
they are vulnerable to a depletion in
the ozone layer
well these guys are eaten by little
one-celled animals
which are eaten by a little shrimp-like
crustacea which are eaten by little fish
which are eaten by bigger fish which are
eaten by and so on and then at the top
of this
ecological pyramid are
dolphins whales and people
and on the land
there is a similar food chain
in which again the primary
photosynthetic producers are vulnerable
so
if you eliminate the organisms at the
base of the food chain
then the rest of the food chain
collapses as well that's the ultimate
danger of ozone depletion
greenhouse warming
is
the buildup of invisible
gases their invisibility is precisely
part of the problem because
you can't just by looking to see that
there's a danger
which keep the heat in
and build up the temperature of the
earth producing
great regions of drought and continental
interiors including
the american midwest
and through the volume expansion of
seawater and the melting of polar ice
sea level rising and some of the
projections for
the end of the next century
are
extremely serious
drought the destruction of croplands
worldwide
an assault on natural ecosystems
and a rising of sea level sufficient to
for example flood
bangladesh
and produce tens of millions of
environmental refugees
these
problems are very serious
they are happening however slow enough
that it's possible to do something about
it the slowness is an advantage in that
respect but a great disadvantage in
another respect in that the changes are
occurring on time scales longer than the
terms of office of politicians
if a politician can take
a presumed unpopular action
which will in his or her estimation
benefit
the politician while still in office
then that's the kind of risk that
politicians are willing to take if the
benefit however happens uh 10 or 30 or
50 years in the future
to benefit some other office holder
then
from the narrow perspective of getting
reelected it's not nearly so attractive
these long time scales
represent
one of the novel problems
of these global environmental issues
now i want to stress that
we are not absolutely certain
what the configuration of danger will be
for the ozone layer we can already
clearly see it there's no question of is
there an ozone depletion there is this
enormous hole over antarctica about
which william riley talked a smaller one
over the arctic and a clear thinning of
the ozone layer at intermediate
latitudes including the latitude of
washington
and
the telltale chlorine atoms
of
the cfcs have been found in association
with the ozone depletion
so there it's very clear what's
happening
you
stop making cfcs and other sources of
ozone depleting chemicals and the ozone
layer will on a time scale of
100 years
heal itself
but note the time scale
make heroic actions now
and the ultimate benefit is a century
hence
delay longer
the healing is also delayed longer
on greenhouse warming there is not yet
so clear a signature
there is a range of
what in this business are called
sophisticated
computer models but of course they're
only as sophisticated as the people who
write the computer programs
but there are five different search
programs they all give
consonant answers
they predict correctly
the very different climates of
say mars and venus
venus by the way
having
a surface temperature of 900 fahrenheit
hotter than the hottest household oven
hot enough to melt tin and lead
because of a massive carbon dioxide
greenhouse effect there
i'm not suggesting that there were
once a species of
venusians who drove fuel inefficient
automobiles and that's
that's why venus is in trouble but
but the idea of an earth-like world
gone to such
hellish conditions
uh is worthy of note
by the way
the
surface this is a theological aside the
surface conditions of venus
are
remarkably
similar to the classic religious view of
hell
in case
in case you have to confront a skeptic
who wants to know where it is
[Music]
i i thought i'd provide a little help
here and there on theological matters
where i am able
um
those same computer models correctly
predict
the past climate of the earth
they correctly predict the present
climate of the earth
it is reasonable
that they are correctly predicting the
future climate of the earth given the
amount of co2 and other greenhouse gases
that we're pouring into the atmosphere
maybe not
maybe there's some undiscovered mistake
that all of the scientists involved in
these models are making
it's not impossible we can't be 100 sure
but which is more prudent which is wiser
to do nothing and hope that a mistake
has been made
or to take these predictions seriously
even if there's a chance you will
the precautions you will take will be
unnecessary
i want now to come back to this issue
by uh discussing what it is that has to
be done
and then let's think about them in the
context of
will we really be angry at ourselves for
having taken these steps
if the computer models are wrong
so what should you do
first thing you should do
is stop producing cfcs
the chlorofluorocarbons see they do
double duty
not only do they destroy the ozone layer
they are an important greenhouse gas
they'll get us one way or another
so
we should stop producing them
and indeed in a
in a remarkable and important
agreement
of most of the
relevant nations
there is a so-called montreal protocol
in which
essentially all the cfc producing
nations except for india and china two
important exceptions
have agreed
to cut by one half their production of
these molecules by the turn of the
century
it's important by one half their
production of these molecules by the
turn of the century
it's important it's pres its precedent
is important but it's not nearly enough
those gases should be reduced to zero
that's the first thing we ought to do
secondly to mitigate greenhouse warming
we should
use
fossil fuels more efficiently
by that i mean
if i had a car that
went 70 miles a gallon instead of one
that went 25 miles a gallon
i would not be putting as much carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere for each
mile that i go
in driving my car
this is a kind of technological
solution or mitigation of the problem
on the other hand
there's not something that we can do as
individuals i cannot go and drive a 75
mile per gallon automobile because they
are not commercially available
so
it's no good to tell me as
my friend mr riley did
that
we shouldn't complain to the government
or the industry we should just do it
ourselves
[Applause]
how shall i go about by myself driving a
75 mile per gallon automobile i i'll be
glad to take instruction on this issue
i'm ready
but uh
seems to me this requires some uh
activity
in washington and detroit
ultimately we're going to want to phase
out fossil fuels we're going to want to
convert
to a
an alternative energy economy
and
and what that
is
we can still discuss but in my view
it is unlikely to be nuclear power for
all the obvious
pollution concerns
and much more promising is solar power
which produces no greenhouse gases and
does not involve radioactivity and is
already economically competitive with
fossil fuels if we take account of the
environmental cost
of the burning of those fossil fuels
that's the kind of technology we should
be after and
incidentally because
developing countries
tend to be located in equatorial
latitudes
where there's more sunlight
this is also an ideal kind of technology
and could be for them and could be much
more indigenous that is the technology
homegrown
than big fission or fusion reactors
then
we should grow trees
trees take carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere we need
massive reforestation on a global scale
instead what we are doing right now
is uh destroying an acre of forest every
second think about that for just
a second
there goes an acre
a whole acre
every second day after day
year after year we're being extremely
stupid
and then the final thing in my view
which has to happen
has to do with world population growth
because even
if we took the most heroic measures
about
stopping the production of cfcs and
making much greater
fossil fuel efficiency
and then on a longer time scale
converting to alternatives to fossil
fuels
and grow enormous amounts
of new forest even then
we would
be not out of the woods at all
if the number of new humans
overwhelms the steps we're taking
we're taking every human being has a has
a right to live and what's more
even in exceptionally poor countries
in your everyday life you
produce carbon dioxide
um
so if we look at who are the biggest
polluters on the planet in terms of
greenhouse gases
number one by far is the united states
something we should take just pride in
number two is the soviet union number
three is the developing countries
put together so it's not an issue of
high technology versus low technology
although that per capita of course
americans
do much more than people in
in equatorial guinea
but
but even people without
elaborate
industrial
economies
make significant contributions to the
burning of wood
to
the greenhouse problem
and by the way
i can talk about it in the question
period greater length but
in my opinion the only appropriate way
of approaching the solution of world
population growth
is
by helping to raise the per capita
income of the poorest billion people on
the planet
it's a thing called the demographic
transition and it happens
in capitalist countries in communist
countries and catholic countries and
buddhist countries east and west
it's fabulously
ecumenical
and
what it is is
poor people have lots of children not
because they're stupid and not because
they don't know about birth control
although those things having birth
control access helps of course
but because they make a kind of
desperate cost-benefit analysis
that if their children are dying
at an enormous rate if they have lots of
children
then there might be some to survive to
help with whatever
the domestic economy is and maybe even
survive to such a time when the parents
are too old and would help the parent
it's the only available social security
for a billion poor people on the planet
when the per capita income rises and
there are alternative sources
of help for the
meager plot of land
and help for the old age of the parents
then without the government ever saying
a word
the population
growth rate turns around and
i find this is true of many americans
think back three generations in your own
family
how many children did your
great-great-grandmother have
how many children do you or your
siblings have
and you will see a substantial drop in
almost every case in the birth rate and
that has happened
because the
economy has improved the per capita
income has gone up in this
most affluent nation
those
are the steps which need to be taken
how many of them can be done by
individual effort
it seems to me
that this is a case where the main
driver has to be
government
and industry
and
there is of course a
a role
for individuals
and that is one of the blessings of
democracies
and that is
individuals can play their part
by voting out of office recalcitrant
politicians it's very straightforward
i can't improve the greenhouse effect
much on my own
by my own
energy economy at home i can make some
contribution but i can make a bigger
contribution
by
voting against
politicians who
say that
they can't do anything about this
problem
there was a two or three weeks ago in
washington a
international conference on the
greenhouse effect hosted by the white
house
this is the one where the white house
was accused of
of urging study rather than doing
anything of going slow of stressing
uncertainties
to the
enormous annoyance of uh delegates from
all over the world especially from
western europe it's almost nobody who
supported the united states
position on this and at the
end u.s delegates were
reduced to saying oh we're not just for
studying we want to do things too but
didn't specify anything in particular
there was a very telling diagram in the
white house handouts
it was stressing the complex issues
involved here and one
and each issue that was stressed had a
little uh cartoon to
to make it clear to people who had
difficulty reading what the issue was
and there was one one issue called
balance
and
what it showed was a traditional
pen
scales
two trays
in one tray
was the planet earth
and then balancing it on the other tray
were four
bars of gold
a balance
four bars of gold the earth
well
don't want to
don't want to fix the earth because it
might cost money
i think that is a very
revealing as well as a very
bad
example
for the white house to be telling us
yes economic growth is important yes
it's even conceivable that poor people
benefit if rich people make more money
but
but if the environment that sustains all
of us
is significantly deteriorating
i suggest that even the people who are
making money are going to be in trouble
industry is going to be in trouble the
national economy is going to be even in
more trouble
and this is the classic battle between
short-term and long-term which is
central to the issue that we're fighting
well
in
in an attempt to
to try to
deal in a practical sense with these
issues as
jim morton mentioned to you
it occurred to us that
this was a time for
science and religion to
uh see if they could work
together
on this
most important
question
so i i wrote a an appeal
was able to get a
number of very distinguished
scientists from
many nations men and women
to sign it
and then through the good offices of
dean morton um
this appeal was distributed
to
the world religious community or some
representative sample of it
with a
very striking success the
the
letter that was sent
to religious leaders was signed besides
dean morton by theodore hesburgh the
former president of the university of
notre dame
the reverend leonid
kisikovsky the president of the national
council of churches
ahmad
the grand mufti of syria
and
elie wiesel
nobel peace laureate
and in the uh
the brochure
put out by the cathedral of saint john
the divine
there's a list of the categories of
signatories
37 heads of national and international
religious bodies 50 cardinals llamas
archbishops head rabbis patriarchs
mullahs and bishops
17 indigenous religious leaders
55 professors of theology seminary
presidents cathedral deans heads of
religious order
and so on
it's breathtakingly ecumenical
who the signatories are
and i think
shows a uh
a very great promise
that uh
religious people worldwide
recognize that this is a serious issue
and are willing to work
to solve it i'd like to read to you
the
last part of this appeal
we first describe some of the
of the issues as i have done here
and then go on to say
by their very nature these assaults on
the environment were not caused by any
one political group
or any one generation
intrinsically they are transnational
transgenerational
and trans-ideological
so are all conceivable solutions
to escape these traps
requires a perspective that embraces the
peoples of the planet and all the
generations yet to come
problems of such magnitude
and solutions demanding so broader
perspective
must be recognized from the outset as
having a religious as well as a
scientific dimension
mindful of our common responsibility
we scientists
many of us long engaged in combating the
environmental crisis
urgently appeal to the world religious
community to commit in word and indeed
and as boldly as is required
to preserve the environment of the earth
some of the short-term mitigations of
these dangers such as greater energy
efficiency rapid banning of
chlorofluorocarbons or modest reductions
in the nuclear arsenals
are comparatively easy
and
at least at some level are already
underway
but other more far-reaching more
long-term more effective approaches
will encounter widespread inertia denial
and resistance
in this category
our conversion from fossil fuels to a
non-polluting energy economy
a continuing swift reversal of the
nuclear arms race and a voluntary halt
to world population growth
without which many of the other
approaches to preserve the environment
will be nullified
as on issues of peace
human rights and social justice
religious institutions can here too
be a strong force encouraging national
and international initiatives
in both the private and public sectors
and in the in the diverse worlds of
commerce education culture and mass
communication
the environmental crisis requires
radical changes
not only in public policy
but also in individual behavior
the historical record makes clear that
religious teaching
example and leadership
are powerfully able to influence
personal conduct and commitment
as scientists
many of us have had profound experiences
of awe and reverence before the universe
we understand that what is regarded as
sacred is more likely to be treated with
care and respect
our planetary home
should so be regarded
efforts to safeguard and cherish the
environment
need to be infused
with a vision
of the sacred
at the same time a much wider and deeper
understanding of science and technology
is needed
if we do not understand the problem
it is unlikely we will be able to fix it
thus there is a vital role for both
religion and science
and the last paragraph reads
we know that the well-being of our
planetary environment is already a
source of profound concern
in your councils and congregations
we hope this appeal will encourage a
spirit of common cause and joint action
to help preserve the earth
so
i'm very encouraged that
this document which i consider to be not
not pulling a lot of punches
has
received such strong and ecumenical
support
i'd like to conclude
with just a couple of other remarks
there is a
passage in the book of proverbs
that uh haunts me in this context
although of course it wasn't written in
this context
it goes
they set an ambush for their own lives
and it seems to me
that through the unthinking development
of
our enormously powerful technology
we are in danger of doing just that
but it is certainly not too late we have
caught the problems early enough
and all it takes
is a
deep
committed dedication to solve these
issues and it seems to me
that there is a peculiar
silver lining
and it goes like this
molecules don't have passports
they're exceptionally stupid they don't
understand
the profound importance of the idea of
national sovereignty
so
so you
strike a match or burn a lump of coal or
drive your car and the carbon dioxide is
wafted up and carried by the general
circulation of the earth's atmosphere
everywhere
no one nation
can solve the greenhouse or ozone
depletion problem
it has to be done by everybody on earth
it requires a global effort so
these problems as as i said in the
appeal
have an intrinsic
trans-ideological
transnational
and
transgenerational
aspect to them
it doesn't matter what your ideology is
if you want to resolve these problems
you're going to have to work closely
with other nations
and if you truly want to understand what
this issue is about
you must be concerned about generations
as yet unborn it seems to me that
binding up of the earth
and of the generations
is something that many religious
traditions
have talked of
talked about
and here is a case
in which if we do not embrace
these broad and grand perspectives
we are in the deepest of trouble i
believe we are an intelligent species
we are equal to this task
and we are about to see
a transformation
of human society
thank you
[Applause]
superb
it's dr maloney
we have
the chairman of our board dr thomas
malone to introduce the next speaker
who is a theologian who has over the
years
done some
rather remarkable
and penetrating
studies
that probe into faith and reason
in naming the whirlwind and in other
things i'm going to ask for
dr malone where are you there oh there
he is he's going to come
and enter
yes we're going to have the questions
after
dr
gilkey and so the chairman of our board
dr tom malone is
widely known
in the
halls of science and in
other
realms as one of the
chief atmospheric scientists
one of those who
deal with global realities
i won't go into all his pedigreed and
all his works but as past immediate past
president of sigma psi the scientific
society and
international
secretary for the national academy of
sciences he has done much to advance the
cause of science at this crucial time
and
in facing the global crisis he has
challenged and encouraged us
in the faith communities of the world
to take up a new challenge tom loom
[Applause]
thank you don
the deliberations of the past
several days
it seems to me
have confirmed
the conviction
that
an increasingly
interdependent
world society
is at a crossroad
three options
lied before us
to snuff out
civilization with the nuclear exchange
that's one
second
to strangle
civilization
by exceeding
the caring
capacity planet earth
and there's a third option
is to use our innate reason
and
intrinsic
creativity
to
see a probable future
and to envision
a possible future
consistent
with the dignity
of individual human beings
and what is required
and it says so in the book of proverbs
where there is no vision
the people perish
we've just heard an example
of a man with great vision from the
scientific field
and now we're going to hear someone who
has a corresponding vision
from the
field of
fundamental
moral values
and beliefs
a noted author
a
constantly
profound thinker
we're privileged to hear him
and out of the creative and dynamic
interaction with the grassroots and
speakers like we have here before us
i think we can rest assured that there
is a future for humankind
this platform with professor carl sagan
to me two quite unexpected events
surprises surprised us this winter
one was the collapse of communist
regimes in eastern europe
the other
to those of us who are observers
the thawing if i may put it that way of
professor sagan's well-known attitude
towards religion
and his willingness which i welcome
to join with representatives of religion
in caring for the earth
my delight to be here with him more than
equals my surprise
our present relations to nature are
mostly indirect utilitarian and
contrived
nature is for our practical existence
day to day
primarily the supply house of raw
materials
for the industrial goods and the varied
services we need in modern urban life
and the dumping ground for our refuge
through scientific technology we have
come thoroughly to dominate nature
to remove most of her threats to us
so as to use nature for the purposes of
our own well-being
only our sporadic need for leisure
promotes a different relation to nature
that's symbolized by the weekend
or the summer vacation
this is hardly mutuality
interdependence
it remains dominion of a sort
but were it not for the political weight
of this role of nature for our leisure
crying out for an unspoiled nature
the practical relation of technological
production
would log strip mine develop and then
pollute the whole thing there
it is strangely appropriate that both
professor sagan and i be here as
representatives perhaps
of science and of religion
for science and religion alike are
deeply involved in the burning issue of
nature
each
both is part of the problem
and potentially
as we've heard as part of the answer
science has provided our main and now
our soul cognitive relation to nature
it is through science physics chemistry
astronomy
geology and biology
that in our age we feel we know what
nature is
that is what its reality is
it is further a dogma of our time
that our only way to know is through
science
and so nature is for us
what the relevant sciences define nature
to be
the heavy not to say tragic consequence
of this for our subject
comes from the fact that scientific
method
objectifies whatever it seeks to know
thus is known by science nature becomes
a system of object
entities with external relations with no
inwardness
no for its selfness
a system made up of homogeneous
quantitative
and quite purposeless parts
and because it is not for itself
and has no value of its own
is not a reality so to speak in itself
nature becomes a fit realm
to be used by our technologies
for our purposes
science knows officially only quantity
homogeneity and causedness
and inert
vacuous to use whitehead scornful term
purposeless
valueless
material
nature
nature as mere object
becomes fit to be nature
as raw material
no wonder herbert marcuza
said the picture of the world
modern science provides
if taken as all there is to nature
is the ideological justification
for the industrial exploitation
of the world
the scientific understanding of the
world is a system of object
and the scientific development and
underpinning of technological industry
have prepared first our minds and then
our instrument
for our fatal exploit
of nature
yet it's recognized
i say this as i see my colleagues taking
notes
let yet let us recognize
unofficially if not officially
science portrays a much more mysterious
nature than it can scientifically
describe
a cosmic development strangely ruled by
taylor
as brian pointed out the other night
a wondrously fekund creative nature
capable of life
of ideals
of even the scientific observer
a nature full of new and unexpected
random yet meaningful turns of wondrous
novelty
and diversity
this mystery of nature
yes one may say the divine mystery
is animated in every cosmology
even if it is scorned
by scientific positivism
another factor however must share the
blame
our religious tradition
the so-called biblical tradition
this is not simply a matter of dominion
the countless generations that divine
command to dominate the earth
meant hunting
herding fishing clearing and farming
precisely the cooperative relation of
mutuality that preceded modern life
it did not because it could not
imply the absolute control
and use
that make exploitation and desecration
possible
whatever they did to their own towns
medieval men and women hardly polluted
europe's rivers
made toxic its soil
killed its forests fouled its air or
created the warming effect
dominion has become destructive and
hence one can say demonic
only when it became a total and
unchallenged dominance
when the theoretical know-how and the
right instruments were there
for our absolute human control
and that has only been in the last three
modern centuries
the fault of the so-called biblical
religions christianity and judaism lies
deeper
ironically precisely in that which is
most created
in these traditions
the first element is familiar the
de-sacralizing
of nature
in these traditions god is one
and transcendent to nature
nature's forces therefore cease directly
either to be or to manifest the divine
nature is thereby stripped of both
divine and demonic powers
this is surely a gain in understanding
god
however it is more ambiguous for our
understanding of nature
this
de-sacralization prepared the way
for the strictly reductionist mechanical
and inert understanding of nature
that appeared with the development of
modern science and modern technology
the de-sacralization of nature
stripped nature of its sacred creative
power and its inherent value
more importantly
our religious traditions fail to replace
that sacred status
with the apprehension of nature as a
sign and instrument of the divine glory
and the divine creativity
secondly for the common jewish and
christian traditions insofar as there is
a common element
it is not nature that holds center stage
but people
with them community
and also history
the religious relations of god the men
and women
and the moral relations of men and women
to one another
represent the major
concerns of true biblical religion
and none of this this nature figure in
any really significant way
it is in effect
merely the temporary stage on which the
drama
in present history of the relations of
god the human beings
and of the latter to one another
are played out
thus in both traditions nature is
radically subordinated to history
as in earlier christianity history was
subordinated to eternity
nature is thus in effect been
religiously ignored or demoted
creating a religious vacuum so to speak
into which other interests could and did
rush the creative religious and moral
command
to honor
love and serve human beings
to recognize human dignity
and to protect and increase human value
immensely creative for our subsequent
cultural life
did not apply to nature
nature had no soul
it is there only as an object among
objects for our use
a mean
and not an end to which we were
unconditionally
obligated
in all of this that i've described as if
staged by a providential demon
we note how our scientific knowledge on
the one hand
our technical and industrial power
our religious traditions
and our present sociological locus
most of us live in a human world
a world of human constructs
towns cities highways
colleges factories office buildings not
in nature
have worked together
to lure us in the west into forgetting
nature
while nonetheless with the other hand
looking one may say the other way
we have pillaged robbed and exploited
nature
as senator gore so eloquently said
yesterday
neglect
indifference even ignorance
are in no way innocent
when they cooperate with
in fact make possible
exploitation
as dominant over nature we threaten
nature
as dependent on nature we are thereby
ourselves threatened
because we are as humans in some strange
ways more than nature
we can and do threaten her
through all that makes us more our
intelligence
our practical ingenuity
our infinity of will
through the human in us
that same more incidentally which makes
science
and the scientific observer possible
we are also however part of nature
in fact
nature's child
a dependent
and mortal creature among natural
creatures
and thus
we are threatened
the ecological crisis with nature
reveals the paradoxes of our human being
and our ambiguity especially our moral
ambiguity
through the very wonder of our science
and technology
wonders whose praises professor sagan is
so persuasively sung
the terrible vulnerability of our
contingency and mortality
as well as our ruling greed
have become manifest
of course if we were rational we would
at once control ourselves
and cease to exploit
and destroy
but we are not rational
such self-control
seems for the moment beyond us
with regard to exploitation
we are also will
infinite desire
a seemingly unlimited greed
as well as objective observers
we seem not to want to save ourselves by
saving nature
a kind of modern writing of saint paul
not
if it requires real self-control
and real sacrifice
yet even more paradoxically
it is our very rationality as modern
culture has defined rationality
scientific inquiry technological
innovation
industrial practicality and organizing
genius
that together threaten nature and with
nature that same rationality
the paradoxes of human being portrayed
by every profound religious tradition
but often ignored in a secular culture
humans as infinite and finite
self-transcendent and creaturely
willing the ideal and yet enacting the
destructive
image of god and yet fallen to put it in
the terms of my own faith
are evident here
the ambiguity of human beings vis-a-vis
nature
is as vividly portrayed in our modern
scientific and industrial encounter with
nature
as in the most primordial of fertility
myths
and ritual sacrifices
modern scientific culture has not
matured itself
out of our ancient
historical dilemmas
and self-contradiction
rather it exquisitely illustrates them
and dominant now over the fate of both
history and nature as in many an ancient
myth
is an old enemy in fact the oldest one
the final one
our own
waywardness
for ruling over science over technology
over industry over our own politics
and so over our common history
is what the buddhists of term desire
and our own tradition
concupiscence
an infinite greed for goods
driving us
where we don't want to go
the rescue of nature is necessary
and i agree
nothing in history is without hope
this is a fundamental religious
apprehension
its grounds are different in every
religious faith
but we all share it
this is first of all of course an issue
for science
it has been morally concerned
and amazingly idealistic scientists like
professor sagan
who have first understood and first
warned us about these dangers
and who know if any do
how we might deal with them
it is secondly an issue for public
policy and so for politics
and i suppose that's one reason we are
in washington
at bottom however
these are spiritual matters
matters on the one hand of attitude
and on the other of moral choice
by attitude in this case i mean our
sense of kinship with nature
our sense of respect
and a moral obligation to nature
and so the drive
deeper even than thought
to act in harmony with
nature but note
such spiritual attitudes depend on what
we think
the reality of nature to be
how therefore we also
know nature
spiritual attitudes lie back of all
fundamental political movements and
changes
as changes in eastern europe now witness
it is because of changes in such
attitudes
of respect for the other
of commitment to justice
and the discipline necessary for
self-control
that our tragic racial situation has
eased a little bit
the new roles for women have also
appeared
when spiritual attitudes change laws can
change not before
ecology is thus in part a religious
issue
and
our responsibility
at the basis of political action
lie spiritual attitude
to oneself
to others
to nature
to god
how we use our scientific knowledge
how we control or do not control our
industrial and our commercial
development
these depend also on our common moral
choices
as communities
and i agree thoroughly with professor
sagan
these cash out
into political action
and these depend in turn on our sense of
obligation
the depth of our commitments
and above all
on our openness to some measure of
self-sacrifice
interestingly
in the most ancient religions
sacrifice
even self-sacrifice
realities that horrify
the modern soul
was always necessary if men and women
were to restore their abused or broken
relation to nature there is hardly a
primordial myth
that doesn't tell this story
of the broken relation to nature
and the need of some sacrifice to
restore it
this gives me the creeps in relation to
our present problem
the same now applies to us
only if we have the moral
self-discipline to be proven
and prudence requires moral
self-discipline
it requires control on ourselves
can nature be saved
as we are learning
in order to enact in this case our clear
self-interest
namely the rescue of nature on which we
depend
immense self-discipline is necessary
who would have thought these so-called
primitive themes in relation to nature
the themes not only of the sacred
creativity of nature of which i've
spoken
but also of discipline and sacrifice
would return as relevant even essential
to modern technological civilization
and let us recall this
such inward changes in us
the dominators
are in this case especially important
here there are no exploited voices to
cry allowed
no oppressed merc
persons to march in our streets
to protest
to act in political rebellion
we can if we will continue to ignore all
of this
continue to preserve pursue our glut of
consumers goods
and
die
our rationality
our ideals our good intentions
being ruled by our greed
how then do fundamental spiritual
attitudes change
for on them we have suggested
depends the possibility of new moral
obligations
commitment and choices
and on these latter depend the
possibilities
of new public
or practical policies towards nature
both religion and science are part of
the problem
as i've tried to note
let us see how they might help in these
changes of attitude
attitudes and moral obligations
represent needless to say
especially the area for which religion
feels responsible we will therefore
begin there
i wish to suggest an obvious but
slightly heretical notion perhaps most
creative notions are heretical i don't
know
history of theology seems to hint that
if not say it
we should proclaim and teach that nature
is an image of god
imago dei
a creature that is also a sign or symbol
of god as are we
hence nature has value in and for itself
as do we
an inherent integrity order and worth
that we must respect
as we do in the case of another person
nature is a thou as the great martin
buber said
an image of its creator and thus not
merely our instrument or material
but a genuine other to us
nature shows forth mirrors as an image
the glory the power the wisdom the
infinity
of its creator and preserver
in fact the god of the hebrew and the
christian scriptures
is one imaged continually
and conceived through
the signs and traces provided by the
grandeur
the power the immensity
the order
and the beauty of nature
it is through analogies from nature
as well as from persons community and
history that god becomes god
nature is not only a sign of god
it is also of ultimate concern to us
for the nature is the source of all life
and so of the future of life
nature is as nothing else is our mother
and creator
we not only tower over nature as
observers and users
as scientists and technologists
and vacationers
as creaturely humans we all are also
absolutely dependent on nature
thanks to evolutionary science
we now know this in a quite new way
namely
that it is through nature
that god has brought us into being
and preserves us there
interestingly and ironically we have
returned through scientific inquiry in
our own age
to this knowledge possessed and
celebrated
by all primordial religions
let me reiterate this
our change scientific understanding of
our origins
has transformed or should do so
our sense of our dependence on nature
heretofore most western men and women
have recognized their dependence in the
present on nature for air for food for
rain and so on and on
but traditionally in our minds
the creation of men and women by god
was seen as a quite separate event
from the creation of nature by god as so
to speak independent or separate
creation
but now
believing jews and christians who also
accept as do most of us in this room
the evolutionary account of our origins
in nature
we now understand god's creative work in
a quite different way
and this can be emphasized in all of our
religious groups
god has created us as humans through
nature
through the long slow processes of
development in nature
the long cosmic geological and finally
biological processes
that are produced first are cosmos
then our world then life and finally
ourselves
a process of creation though without its
theological thrills elegantly described
by professor sagan
in this sense
as for the earliest religions nature is
in fact our mother
the instrument god has used to produce
us
much as god produces each one of us
through our own mother and father
our dependence on the divine for our
existence in life
is directly expressed in our dependence
on nature
as primordial religion knew
in nature lie the sacred powers of life
of fertility
of community
of health
and of security
as well as the powers
and order of existence
both our scientific and our religious
inheritance have heretofore
been quite blind to this
one final word then about science
reality and nature
as we have seen as the creative source
of our existence or being
in all its facets
nature as infinite as power as order
life and beauty
the reality of nature far transcends
the inert determined external vacuous
system of objects
pictured by empirical science
although that scientific description is
itself alive
with deeper implications of mystery
implications of spontaneity of novelty
of random changes evolving into life
with its self-direction its purposes its
feelings
reactions and finally consciousness and
self-consciousness
nature reveals itself in us
as living subject
it reveals itself in us
as being as power and as life
and it reveals itself around us
as
strategic power
and order
it is not only an object of our
inquiries it is also the living source
of our being
including the being of the objective
scientific inquirer
who looked at and defined
nature
nature thus manifests itself to us
as more than all we can know
or ever could know of it
it manifests itself in ourselves as
subjects
as well as studied objects
as a mystery in part
only fathomed by our empirical
investigation
science represents a wonderfully
accurate
but nonetheless limited perspective
on this wondrous mystery of the universe
and the cosmos
the reality of nature creates us
supports us lures us
it offers itself to our inquiries and to
our youth
but it eludes our final understanding
as it will elude our final domination
this sense of nature's mystery of its
sacred mystery
and of its depth
integrity and richness
and inherent value
can well supplement our attempts to
objectify
and so to use nature
thus can a renewed chastened and humbled
science
like a renewed and humbled religion
become a participant
in the homage to nature
rather than the cognitive basis for its
exploitation
and only thus in chastened partnership
can we begin to control that
exploitation
so as to rescue nature from ourselves
her children thank you
[Applause]
[Music]